tout bugger en fait
ça ça a carrément fait tout bugger du
coup on va pas essayer de les remettre
mais ça fait vraiment tout bugger à un
point assez
embêtant je vais essayer de réparer le
truc
je suis vraiment désolé
ok bon c'est réparé
c'est quoi qui a fait bugger bah en fait
c'est les caméras qui se relancent et
qui reboot
et quand j'ai voulu la remettre celle de
Ding pour la énième fois ça a tout fait
bugger bon c'est pas très grave alors à
5 à 4 dames E7 comme un petit peu prévu
danse 2 mais après tout qu'est-ce qu'ils
veulent sur
peut-être une petite nul non sûrement
pas parce que si tu veux faire nul tu
joues pas à 4 mois tu bouffes sur ces 6
et tu rentres dans une ligne forcée donc
il viole quelque chose c'est Roscoff
dis-moi s'il te plaît
je crois ici avec le noir
j'entamerai pas ce genre de position en
fait
donc ta pâte
tu as pas de
solution j'entame répond à ce genre de
position parce que je déteste jouer ce
genre de truc écoutez six mois je veux
pas réfléchir je veux jouer
mécaniquement
je joue sans doute que
je sais si ce jour
je m'amuse pas du tout quand je joue ce
genre de position
tu t'ennuies complètement
ouais ok sinon à part donc
ça peut dire quoi quand tu joues ça ou
pas autant que ça ça c'est intéressant
en fait ah parce que parfois c'est un
peu mieux pour les blancs parfois c'est
rien du tout et c'est intéressant de
comprendre les différences à part donc
mes chers amis il y a une autre idée un
petit peu plus simple c'est de jouer à 7
avec les défauts bougent quand elle est
ici et puis
qu'est-ce que tu veux ça ça aurait été
plus moi
en espérant que le mec répète pour faire
une petite nulle quoi contre l'écho
c'est très fort cavalier à
7h30
[Musique]
je pense que même si tu fais cavalier B8
il repart quand même
voilà donc sinon je peux imaginer que il
y a une certaine théorie ici il y a
peut-être des parties jouées ici mais
c'est l'un des rares cas où je sais pas
du tout au courant principal parce que
en fait quand je travaillais pour les
joueurs de Lite
quand on parle des joueurs d'élite mec
oui donc ça veut dire l'écho et grichu
que deux fois à chaque fois je disais
bien avant travailler je disais il y a
une seule règle
quoique ce soit moi j'analise pas
[Musique]
une seule fois
donc tu es beaucoup moins fort que Baki
dans Berlin ah c'est sûr
d'ailleurs il était très bien il était
très bien parce que comment s'appelle
Maxime il est sorti quand même et je
pense sous l'influence de Baki il est
sorti quand même peut-être à 5-6 grosses
complètement humain
0000 dans toutes les
idées de baquillage mais de qui c'est
humain ça peut pas être baquis
[Rires]
trop fort trop fort à qui
alors comment elle est beau oui comme
d'hab
et maintenant à en général les points
voudraient bien
mettre le four sur F1 parce que comme ça
il comment dire il défendent
il surtout il est comment il marche pas
sur les pas des autres pièces oui mais
le problème avec torrent avec les
décisif 4 c'est bien sûr que
je garde
ça le problème
maintenant et donc
rien enfin
[Musique]
donc il a fait tour là donc il est OK
pour faire tourner
alors
2 c'est 6 food 3 avantages blancs
même si on est en train de comprendre
pourquoi
je sais pas
ok quoi que peut-être peut-être elle
veut dire que quand elle est de 7 h 3
que les gf6 que va laisser 4 est-ce que
Vital comme quoi t'as pas de bêtises
parce que le pionçant le sang que ta
mère peut-être c'est plus ou moins ça
mais vous savez dans de telles positions
en fait c'est pas trop la peine de
croire à l'ordinateur
parce que l'ordinateur n'est pas très
fiable en fait
et il a toujours le tendance de donner
un petit avantage à celui qui a plus de
pièces développées comme les bandes ici
mais en général au fond de soi-même les
positions très sèche en fait
trop dur
c'est pas trop dur de jouer cette
position si tu veux pas gagner mais si
tu veux gagner oui il est vrai
c'est assez compliqué
on ne sait pas tu as trop les pièces qui
se marchent dessus je me sentirai pas
bien
juste j'aime pas le choix de dingue
pourquoi est-ce que je l'aime pas
premièrement il est assez nouveau dans
ce type de position et deuxièmement
quand même l'horoscope savent travailler
et là je pense que mes pots est en train
de sortir ce que les préparer contre
ce qu'il a préparé il y a un peu de
temps donc encore pendant quelques cours
il va citer c'était
pas l'idée les plus malines en fait
c'était pas l'aider les plus maligne
pourquoi pas répéter les Français en
fait
en forme pourquoi pas tenter une
Sicilienne aussi enfin je dois dire que
est-ce que ça aurait été une mauvaise
idée de jouer pour le Championnat du
Monde
c'est
une très bonne idée de jouer tu as
besoin de deux jours pour opérer
je sais parce que Dalias richniko soit
même en fait et rien du tout mais le
problème éternel bien sûr c'est parce
que bien sûr le problème éternel c'est
le deuxième coup et le troisième coup
donc c'est reçu le mot parce que jamais
renseignement se sentir aussi bien que
maintenant
et maintenant c'est juste l'ordinateur
c'est assez terrifiant avec les banques
en fait je sais de quoi je parle parce
que je travaillais pendant plusieurs
jours et je pense que donc les lignes
n'étaient jamais aussi bien pour les
banques
ouais ça le problème
tu peux essayer de jouer ce que avec E6
au deuxième pour éviter les faux
poussins mais il y a un tas d'autres
problèmes ces trois les B3 etc mais B3
ça va non
un petit peu plus compliqué
d'ailleurs j'étais là en premier
je m'appelle
Tourville joueur
c'est que
comment dire réjouis ce que me réjouit
parce que c'est pas un coup évident donc
peut-être elle sait de quoi
avant il est au courant de ce qui se
passe alors ok déjà première chose à
dire il y a pas de C4 mes chers amis
parce que ceci et ça perd une pièce pour
les bons
sinon les bois en veulent faire quoi
Foufa avec les décors
qu'est-ce que ne pouvait alors il veut
absolument faire ton Besson on
adversaire et lui absolument suivre les
sagesse de Frédéric je pense qu'il
s'appelait Frédéric Nietzsche
celui qui tombe il faut que tu l'aides
par contre j'étais objectif ma parole je
pense que c'est rien du tout est-ce que
tu as déjà marché sur le chemin de
Nietzsche toi qui a un grand fanad
Frédéric Nietzsche oui moi bien sûr
comment dire si tu es un bon joueur tu
étais assez violent non mais je veux
dire est-ce que tu as marché
physiquement au premier degré sur ce
qu'on appelle le chemin de Nietzsche
dans quel sens
pour les gens qui connaissent tu connais
la ville d'aise non s village ah oui oui
ici pas loin d'ici
[Applaudissements]
village et il y a un chemin qui part de
la montagne et qui arrive jusqu'à la mer
qui dure à peu près une heure à faire à
pied qui s'appelle le chemin de
Nietzsche parce qu'il marchait sur ce
chemin
de Nietzsche je vais dire au premier
degré non croyable ça parce que tu as un
grand fan de Nietzsche non
oui bien sûr parce que c'est l'un de
ceux qui a décrit plus ou moins qui a
enfin
pronostiqué qui a view bien sûr le
prophète quoi
donc
une fois à pied et que tu marches
d'après la gueule j'ai toujours aimé
et bien sûr c'est hyper pittoresque sur
les rochesses c'est tout ça dans
l'impression que je sais pas c'est un
petit peu amer malheureusement
maintenant c'est devenu un village très
prisé des instrats grammeuses et donc
c'est un village où il y avait pas tant
de touristes avant même si on avait
beaucoup qui se pose news non pas de nu
mais du coup il y a énormément de
touristes maintenant là-bas et c'est
devenu compliqué il y a trop de monde
avant c'était quand même assez connu
mais il y avait plus de monde qui allait
avance enfin tu peux faire le chemin de
niche la prochaine fois que tu viens de
voir pour penser quoi
il a fait H3 c'est le coup numéro 1 de
l'ordi
bon pour éviter des cavaliers G4 pour
alors
pouvoir chauffer
de toute manière paraît très très
modeste ok tu réussis à jouer et alors
c'est ça les questions
le type de fois
alors avec ce que tu veux tu vois
écoutez d'après les virtuel maintenant
15 minutes plus tard je peux dire que ça
va entièrement pour les noirs
sauf que malheureusement mon favori dans
ce match il est en tel talent énorme de
décevoir dans chaque partie tu es
presque que j'ai toujours peur parce que
pas à partir de hier j'ai encore plus de
peur que que avant mais normalement oui
oui c'est tout à fait en français on a
une expression qui dit plus de peur que
de mal mais je pense qu'avec Ding c'est
autant de peur que de mal
[Musique]
alors comment ils font pardon
H6
les premières réactions et que moi par
contre
parce que tu peux plus jouer je sais
donc bien sûr dans ce cas-là que se
fonce dans cette direction de pouvoir se
matériaux sur 5
si vous voulez toute logique
sauf
bien sûr bien sûr objectivement apparent
j'ai pas fou ce 4 peut-être il y a pas
de focus parce que
peut-être
alors toujours ces 6 faut c'est 4
cavaliers de 7 quand
elle était choisie entre que les Bussy
ce que les fuites plutôt que je suppose
qu'est-ce que c'est chiant de jouer ces
positions
d'ailleurs j'étais en train de essayer
de comprendre que si tu joues pas faux
faim mais tu joues jamais
ça c'est juste complètement égal
complètement égal d'ailleurs si tu
abuses ça peut facilement devenir un peu
mieux parce que n'oublions pas la Tour
Blanche est sur un mais le tour noir est
sur de 8 donc les Noirs ont comme quoi
en demi-tour pour contre les colons quoi
et le cavalier B6 c'est bien placé parce
qu'il touche à 4 oh oui et tu as pas
trop dans le vieux de jeux B3 parce que
dans ce cas-là toutes les formations des
pions peut devenir assez parce que faut
éviter
c'est pas toi qui vantait la préparation
de nepomyachi il y a 5 minutes de ça bah
qu'est-ce que tu veux je suis
contradictoire je suis contradictoire je
me conterdis sur chaque mois en fait et
comme ça pendant
toutes les deux heures que d'habitude je
suis là en fait
sur chaque mois en fait il faut que je
suivre
et puis se dire en gros
d'ailleurs j'ai une question par rapport
à la partie d'hier ouais si tu veux
Pascal est quand même important on peut
prendre deux minutes pour en parler
[Musique]
et je vais te montrer une variante parce
que je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
avec ce qu'a dit à Nantes et guéri par
la peine pour la peine et donc je vais
te poser la question donc petit
digression sur la partie d'hier qui est
importante pendant que les joueurs se
récitent encore la théorie
non
attendez trois c'était une chose mais
est-ce que tu es d'accord avec eux que
c'est inhumain parce que moi je crois
qu'ils ont fait une erreur
personnellement après dan D8 ce qu'il
fallait voir des dames 4 bon vous deux
il y a dans ma chambre
de ses forcer dame B1 et chèque roi des
deux seul coup dame B2 échec bon à
savoir que tu aurais pu gagner des temps
pour arriver au 40e peu importe roi des
trois seul coup
[Musique]
dans ces deux seul coup dame D1
bon là tu comprends que sur dame F1 il y
a roi des deux et que tu repars de
l'autre côté pas très dur donc
ça peut pas aller parce qu'il y a dame
bien et ça revient donc trois ou quatre
seul coup
dame 4 foutez trois seul coup tu menaces
dames si c'est chèque et de mater donc
cavalier des six forcés et là ils ont
tous dit que c'était inhumain parce
qu'il fallait trouver roi E5 qui est la
première ligne de l'ordi mais là où je
suis pas du tout d'accord avec eux
et je comprends pas ce qui est dur en
fait
[Musique]
ils disent que c'est vraiment dur parce
que dame prend des trois dame F6 roi H7
D8 dames et il y a encore qui va les
Français 4 échec
c'est introuvable
il y a rien dedans mais roi E3 cavaliers
F5 vous prend F5 je vois pas mais retro
c'est hyper simple en fait tu fais
Roader
ça je comprends pas en fait
bah c'est pas ce que je sais pas il veut
le dire que la qualité du jour dans ce
match et excellente parce que
je sais pas ils sont plutôt terre comme
quoi
j'ai pas complémentaire envers le joueur
mais en fait les qualités au niveau de
comment s'intéressant hyper intéressant
sinon les qualités du jour de ce match
vraiment pas top vraiment pas top c'est
pas une critique ce n'est que une c'est
ce n'est qu'une résumé oui c'est loin
dans le calcul mais non c'est pas très
loin c'est normal
vous savez les amis en fait parfois dans
parfois quand les positions de telles un
peu facilement calculer si vous voulez
vendre 30 cours en avance tout
simplement parce que c'est pas une arbre
de variante oui mais c'est juste direct
tant que c'est forcé en fait c'est pas
trop dur de calculer un second
sa biographie qui dit ça mais à liquide
il pouvait calculer 25 coups dans des
variantes forcés sans difficulté
tu as fait combien de simultané à
l'aveugle 12 adversaires 12 adversaires
Vlad ouais ça c'est pour juste pour
reposer le bonhomme il a fait une
simultanée à l'aveugle contre 12
personnes en même temps c'est ouais
c'est assez violent et d'ailleurs je
dois dire que j'ai pas senti les limites
j'étais bien payé je fais sur 12 g je
savais très bien d'ailleurs les amis
pour l'information générale à l'Union
soviétique ça a été strictement interdit
tu en as gagné combien sur les 12
je fais une news j'ai gagné tout le
reste
strictement interdites parce que comme
quoi pas bien pour la santé mais mon
commentaire personnel ce que j'ai pas
senti les limites
j'ai vu que 12 GTA ça allait et j'ai
senti que 25 bah je peux faire 30 je
peux faire si je suis très bien payé
par contre
je sais pas si je pouvais aller jusqu'à
60 70 comme à liquide les autres je sais
pas encore du monde officiel c'est 52 25
30 facilement mais il y avait un
problème mes amis c'est long non non
c'est pas ça le problème il y avait un
problème je peux pas m'endormir pendant
trois jours
pas bien pour la santé disons
je vous cache pas les vérités je prenne
d'alcool
la tête une fois une fois c'est lancé
et il s'arrête pas
elle s'arrête pas c'est juste que tu as
toujours des variantes dans ta gueule
qui passe en fait et comme ça pendant et
puis finalement le quatrième le
quatrième journée
finalement je pouvais m'endormir pendant
j'ai pas deux heures peut-être si tu as
fait ce bruit c'est que tu as pas dormi
[Rires]
52 je crois mais 12 c'est déjà très
impressionnant les amis 50 dos et ça a
été le record mondial ça parce qu'en
fait je crois en fait à un moment donné
il y avait un Brico
enregistré par un grand maître hongrois
qui s'appelait flèche flèche j'ai pas
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait j'ai pas 45 ou je
sais pas quoi mais tous les endroits
m'ont dit que c'était du fake en gros ça
veut dire que après 10 minutes du jour
donc je suppose que le record de Aliki à
l'époque le record de majeur fallait
pour et peut-être le record de guerrier
aux États-Unis ce sont des vrais et le
record du monde
il y a les vidéos et tout mais toi les
joueurs ils jouaient bien en face parce
que guerrier je crois que ça a duré 20h
hein son truc ou 18h ou je sais plus
c'était hyper long mais le mec est archi
physique
à peu près ok donc je fais une nul
counter qui habite en France
où est Stéphane boy il est quand même
parce que je t'ai foutu il m'a proposé
il était gentille je cache pas les
règles
et sinon il y a votre célébrités de
célébrités je pense chanteur musicien je
parle un acteur comme ça et donc
relativement facile à un moment donné
j'avais un moment de crise à un moment
donné genre
après 15 minutes du jour quelque chose
comme ça je peux pas me rappeler
qu'est-ce que c'est pas sur 7e chez qui
j'ai oublié et donc il m'a fallu me
concentrer pendant 10 minutes pour
finalement retrouver ce qu'il est fait
en fait le pire pendant les simultané
virgule c'est le début ou pas la fin le
début c'est de ne pas confondre j'ai pas
5e et 8e échiquier c'est ça le plus dur
et puis
bah vers la France on devient facile en
fait parce que une fois tu captes les
positions tu les rages plus tu te
commandes
sinon parlons de ce que se passe sur
l'échiquier je suis pas particulièrement
fan de son cavalier
mais peut-être pourquoi pas
premièrement et deuxièmement avant
l'impression qu'il sait ce qu'il veut il
fait ouais on a l'impression que il est
toujours dans son fichier en fait donc
il vient de jouer dans cette si je me
trompe pas et si je me trompe pas l'idée
habituelle c'est toujours dans ce set
pour [__] ton fou sur une fuite donc
si tu veux tu vois la place comment ça
va
un gros d'habitude c'est rien du tout en
fait
donc préparation de Roscoff
pas très impressionnante peut-être
qu'ils ont sorti c'est du bof
non c'est c'est recours sont très
impressionnants mais aujourd'hui bah
écoutez non en fait ils sont
impressionnants mais pas souvent quoi
le 30 février
[Rires]
ça change rien en fait
je pense que tout à l'heure j'ai dit une
connerie en fait je pense en fait c'est
quoi le problème de Rousseau ici en fait
je pense que je peux me tromper
peut-être les gens peuvent se conseiller
d'après la base de données je pense que
bien sûr le truc a été préparé contre
Magnus mais Magnus je pense qu'il n'a
jamais joué de sang dans cette position
tu vois je pense que il est toujours
opté pour d'autres lignes et alors
je suppose que c'est peut-être ça et on
est d'accord que mise à part le système
nerveux
Ding est plus fort que nepo sur ce match
intrinsèque non il joue notre main et
dommage que il est fou
il joue nettement mieux je suis d'accord
avec toi j'ai la même impression que toi
dans le jeu il est nettement plus fort
oui son système nerveux est complètement
foutu quoi
ça fonctionne pas trop c'est dommage
hier par exemple
hallucinant de attends le mec joue comme
il veut pas jouer
ça aide pas bon alors joue pourquoi que
parce que
c'est que ça
c'est terrible
j'ai pas les mots vous détestez une
époque c'est délirant le meilleur jour
de l'année 2022 il mérite le titre à
100% bon il joue pas mieux là sur le
match je peux pas dire l'inverse enfin
moi honnêtement j'en ai absolument rien
à [__] de qui gagne je te dis tout de
suite moi je m'en fous mais d'une force
vous connaissez très bien mais sympathie
mes empathie quoi pourquoi est-ce que je
suis concerné pour je veux pas dire mais
je peux dire juste
trois mois pourquoi elle se conternait
pas parce que je le connais
il a gagné deux fois les candidats c'est
ouf non mais c'est sûr que c'est ouf
mais par exemple il a jamais été au sud
de 1800 et l'eau par exemple
mais bon il a été hyper fort sur les
candidats ça c'est évident et c'est un
très bon joueur mais
mais là sur ce match là mise à part les
nerfs digne par un peu plus fort après
il faut mettre les points
et il le fait pas donc c'est
problématique
mais j'espère vraiment que au moins Ding
arrive à égaliser à jourd'hui ou demain
et même si il perd son match ça va être
miso pour sa santé psychologique plus
tard parce que s'il perd le match et
légalise pas aujourd'hui de moi etc je
pense que la position de hier il voit le
voir souvent pendant il va aller voir
souvent en fait ça va revenir mais je
pense ça va lui détruire sa carrière
s'il perd le match digne parce que hier
c'était tellement facile quand même
sinon alors dis-moi qui est dame cette
dame ça c'est pardon je pense que ça
peut avoir comme un seul sens le coup
peut opérer
surtout quand tu as mis ton cavalier sur
assise et pas sur deux set donc pas trop
d'option pour le cavalier dans ce cas là
donc il faut absolument que tu déplaces
ton four pour que
pour que les pièces
respirent
après je pense que c'est un très bon
résultat pour Ding aujourd'hui s'il fait
nul
pardon je pense que c'est vraiment un
très bon résultat pour digne de faire
nul parce que je suppose que ça peut
être le la pression mentale peut
s'inverser à la fin du match si n'est
pas est devant et qui doit faire des
nuls je pense qu'il peut ça peut
inverser le rapport de force c'est plus
facile de jouer quand tu as plus rien à
perdre et c'est néo qui peut un peu se
tendre
tout à fait d'accord
bien sûr mais
ça dépend quand même ce que ne pauvre à
faire maintenant
parce que si il déconne
même pas trop de toute manière il faut
quand même mettre une pression sur lui
il vaut il faut essayer pour quand même
comprendre pour lui faire comprendre que
même avec le noir c'est sûr qu'il vaut
mieux essayer pour pour tenter n'est pas
d'effacer les pièces blanches et juste
de faire nul avec les Blancs et de tenir
avec les Noirs là je trouve que tu as
raison psychologiquement ça peut faire
une grosse différence
une grosse ligne théorique avec Dame de
fouet fuite
faux 3 cavalier C5 B4 car elle est prend
le 4 cavalier prend le 4 et prend le 4
B6 dame B6
[Musique]
alors que vous êtes très bien informé
monsieur parce que moi je connaissais
pas cette ligne
[Musique]
pas de bonne case pour la dent ça le
problème F4 pas top
et vas-y égale
bon comme le mec a blitzer tout se
couleur
mais merci de nous informer
donc c'est pas sûr qu'il connaisse mais
c'est sûr que ça existe
[Musique]
est-ce que alors il faut toujours
essayer d'obtenir quelque chose où il
faut déjà chercher de je pense que comme
il est très pragmatique il va effacer ce
que je pense moi le problème c'est que
je vois pas trop clairement comment tu
effaces parce que le premier coup qui
vient à l'esprit se fait trois
mouette
la tour est mal placé le cavalier est
très bien passé
d'ailleurs je pense que après 5 les
noirs sont un petit peu mieux
c'est minuscule bien sûr mais je pense
c'est plus agréable avec toi et sinon
comment tu le fasses tu peux pas effacer
tout de suite
déjà j'aime plus que tout que [__]
bien sûr
bien sûr jouer tour de
comme ça tout le monde que tu veux
absolument partir
du monde et tu le montre clairement
c'est humiliant donc ça se fait pas
alors d'un autre côté les noirs peuvent
pas faire grand-chose contre
oui mais tu vois très bien ce que je
veux dire non mais c'est relou hein t'as
pas envie évidemment et dans ce cas là
qu'est-ce que tu fais je sais pas
parce que
il y a pas trop d'idées et peut-être ça
permet au noir de d'obtenir l'avantage
juste après
ce qui doit calculer quand même mais ça
passe pas
mais comme je te dis n'est pas c'est une
des grotte de ces grandes forces quand
même je trouve c'est qu'il est très
pragmatique ah oui c'est bien ça
c'est une très très grande force donc
oui alors il va il va nous proposer
alors sa recette
pour s'en sortir aujourd'hui
[Musique]
il m'a jamais proposé
s'il m'avait proposé j'aurais refusé
direct
mais c'était jamais quoi bon ne cherchez
pas trop dans j'ai pas mais sympathie
antipathique c'est pas ça non ça marche
pas comme ça pour proposer au pas
proposer
est-ce que cavalier H4 un bon coup
oui bien sûr c'est l'un des coups qui
que tu considères et là dans ce cas là
je suppose je joue au foyer sans
réfléchir mais surtout
c'est pas tragique bien sûr tu peux
repartir
[Musique]
quoi d'autre en ce moment sinon d'autres
les autres cours sont de moi quand c'est
durable
mais le problème de boire c'est quoi
déjà l'un des problèmes de bois ce que
ok ils ont le fou sur ces quatre raisons
de cavaliers bien pensé qu'on quoi pour
essayer de faire quelque chose sur l'île
du roi mais le problème la dame n'est
pas sur eux deux elle est sur c'est de
la dame peut pas facilement rejoindre
l'attaque rejoindre la fête parce que si
il était sur la sur E2 qu'en H4 et
l'idée de Game of Thrones
[Musique]
positions vraiment difficile à jouer
très franchement
bah pour toi sur
scandinave trompawski ça se chauffe tout
de suite ici
[Musique]
c'est incroyable
incroyable ça peut arriver d'ailleurs
parlons depuis trop tu peux peut-être
mettre la pause en attendant
sans que les trois collectifs vous savez
que depuis toujours bien sûr le coup se
décide depuis la moitié de 19e siècle en
fait que c'est pas si facile en fait
c'est pas si facile mais pas du tout
c'est pas que ça et pas que ça il y a
aussi du beau
ce qui entamment les parties en blitz
sont rapides
moi je pensais que c'est pas si facile
mais c'est moins bien que quand le 4
des 3 c'est ça leur piège à la con c'est
[Musique]
[Rires]
si vous voulez je suis
le père de l'une des idées les plus
impressionnantes sur cette ouverture en
fait je suis fier en fait parce que à un
moment donné ils ont eu
5 demi sur 6
après quand les fils j'ai vraiment fier
parce que je trouvais ça par la tête
quand le 5 des 6 quand les trois que le
4 four de 3 et donc là maintenant il y a
200 qui existent mais bon quand les
petits c'est la plupart du jour
et maintenant pendant des années des
années des années
des années longs ils ont joué C3 faut se
dos de 4 logique logique et moi j'ai
trouvé tout
effondré
je fonce sur C4
je veux jouer les positions avec le
purnosaure
à un moment donné ça donnait des
résultats mais juste merveilleux
spectateurs
a gagné contre juvénient le champion
avant
le problème je peux dire
pour comment dire j'adore vous dévoiler
les petits secrets une autre fois
Saint-Étienne et c'est quoi le problème
tu joues pas dans cette le problème
c'est fou cette
faubourg d'amocrate
ça ferme
malgré le pion de plus
au courant c'est sûr vous donc vous
pouvez utiliser ça sinon
intéressant
marrant vous êtes introuvable sans
ordinand parce que tu comprends pas
pourquoi
selon l'ordinateur il est très
convaincant en fait il est
il tousse se positionner alors
moi tu me donnes ça c'est juste un punto
que ça alors maintenant donc
contrairement à ces habitudes mais pour
dépenses beaucoup du temps toujours en
train de réfléchir je sais toujours je
sais pas quoi faire exactement
donc bravo à l'équipe chinoise parce que
pour l'autre fois ils ont dominé alors
l'équipe russe
avec autant de moyens financiers
réussissent pas être plus efficace
ils sont trop directs
il peut pas penser comment dire
[Musique]
voilà un peu trop direct le moins que
joue Marshall
et puis voilà
ce sont de bons travailleurs ma pas de
génie
il en manque un rapport
de ce profil
ah oui des vrais créateurs il y a
vraiment pas beaucoup en fait parce que
c'est un compte mes collègues dans ce
boulot ok il est vrai que depuis un
moment je travaille plus avec le genre
de Lith mais à l'époque oui c'est un
conte mes collègues on est vraiment pas
très nombreux en fait on n'a jamais
entre 15 et 20 au monde
ce qui est alors c'est ça a été moi
de beau
que j'appelle little finger les dauphins
et donc
parmi ces gens-là des vrais créateurs
qui peuvent vraiment te choquer encore
moins nombreux concasse par exemple
quand je parle de quand je parle de
Kassim j'ai toujours le mur exemple
surtout pour ceux qui suivent les
chaînes de stream c'est les parties
toujours mais avant vos fraises bon bien
vraiment bien
en fait
quand tu regardes tout ce type là que je
viens de donner les nombres je viens de
citer en fait tu vois toujours les mêmes
tendances
les meilleures fécondants
au plus haut niveau c'est jamais les
mecs de 2016 c'est toujours les mecs
2006 50 60 70 40 après quasiment c'était
quand même il était mais il est plus
mais c'est toujours les gens de dans ce
milieu des gens de 2006 pourquoi me
rapporte c'est quand même un peu au
dessus
rapporte oui c'est une exception
[Musique]
de toute façon il est parti dans ce
milieu aussi et en fait très facile à
dire pourquoi en fait
tout simplement parce que ce sont les
gens qui n'ont moi y compris qui n'ont
jamais prétendu pour le titre mondial
d'accord donc ce sont les gens alors qui
ont moins d'égo donc c'est plus facile
de travailler à fond pour un joueur de
lutte pour de tels gens qui n'ont jamais
prétendu pour le titre parce que sinon
il y a toujours la question de la jolie
en fait parce que parfois quand un type
de 2007 beaucoup travaillent pour un
autre mec 2007 beaucoup voir 2008
il y a toujours une question qui te pose
quand tu regardes les parties
mais il est là pour aider ou il est là
pour
me prendre
casser quoi
alors pour avoir prendre le pognon et
pour casser
question mais après tout il est là
pourquoi
il a la réponse c'est souvent oui
et en fait les réponses
qui avait pris cramique comme secondant
ce dont tu as parlé pendant un moment
et d'ailleurs les fruits
récoltés c'est que peut-être qu'il a
juste arrêté les échecs
[Rires]
que tu arrives tu deviens non tu te mets
à François
et tu m'as dit qu'avec son petit verre
de rouge le soir j'en ai encore fermé un
quoi
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que je fasse demain c'est quoi
l'idée
tu sais j'ai une grosse idée c'est quoi
cette fois-ci
[Musique]
est génial je te jure ça va chez moi je
te jure ça va chez moi d'ailleurs tu
peux te casser parce que j'ai un très
bon vent quoi
il y a rien qui est passé
d'ailleurs je veux tempo
fichier
qu'est-ce que je peux dire je peux dire
un gamme très grand respect pour
l'équipe chinoise parce que même une
sous variante de la souverainte
il a toujours bah je sais à quel point
c'est dur de prévoir de telles choses
parce que fouados c'est pas le coup qui
tue qui te fait peur c'est pas le coup
qui tu regardes au premier tu vois j'ai
pas tu regardes comme les H4 d'un moteur
mais ils ont fait quand même bah respect
total respectable cette fois-ci un peu
déjà résumé que pour l'autre fois pour
une autre fois les Chinois ont
dominaient l'équipe russe en fait c'est
je pense que le
2 mai le lendemain de la fin du
championnat du monde je crois
qu'officiellement la cérémonie de
clôture c'est le 1er mai tu vas voir une
annonce arriver sur ebay vent clé USB
préparation de haut niveau Marshall anti
Marshall berlinoise
[Rires]
ça vaut le coup d'ailleurs mais moi je
peux pas
moi je pouvais pas j'ai mon marché j'y
crois entièrement
vu les ouvertures qui jouent ça
m'intéresse pas en fait
bon
écoutez pour moi c'est dur de dire
pourquoi bossin que pas faute mais de
toute manière j'aime bien l'idée
stratégique ma parole parce que en gros
c'est quoi son idée c'est de toute
manière déplacer le fou sur fit le plus
probablement éventuellement sur B6
cavaler 5 est forcé les bandes de jeux
ABC
et après tu peux jouer à 4 à 4 ou
peut-être un faux bosser parce que les
diagonales du ouf s'ouvre aussi
en gros je veux dire par mon pif j'aime
bien l'aider l'idée aussi qu'en fait si
vous voulez ça pose un certain problème
au blanc
effacer les parties mais comment
dame E2
je suis même pas sûr qu'il menace
prendre sur Bessac en fait je sais pas
sûr donc tourbes c'est le premier coup
qui te vient dans l'esprit et deuxième
degré toujours
je pense pas que tu peux bouffer le pion
en fait
beaucoup d'activités
[Applaudissements]
c'est ça fait quoi ça fait
3e album de Michael Jackson
pendant cette partie il écoute Michael
Jackson
[Rires]
ne sont pas bien maintenant
et tu dois trouver quelque chose contre
Berlin le problème c'est que c'est
impossible de trouver quoi que ce soit
compteur bureau parce que il y a rien
contre moi d'ailleurs
les amis maintenant à birlande c'est
carrément la première ouverture contre 4
parmi le joueur de lit mais en fait tu
sais ce que j'ai appris peut-être moi je
l'ai appris assez récemment en fait ça a
été le cas il y a un siècle il y a
longtemps
bah parce que ils comprenait bien qu'il
fait là il dort et ils comprenait bien
avoir les hommes en fait le respect aux
anciennes comprennent tout en fait alors
tu sais si il faut qu'ils écoutent s'ils
veulent réfuter Berlin comme musique
comment ça marche déjà un fruit
[Musique]
[__] j'arrive pas à la faire ok je
vois
je vais chercher ok tant que tu
recherches j'ai une autre proposition
ceux qui veulent réfuter
ah d'accord d'accord oui oui bien sûr
une chanson de culte j'ai les cheveux
j'ai une autre proposition si tu veux
réfuter bureau tu écoutes la chanson de
je passe son nom je me rappelle de son
nom de famille quoi
[Musique]
[Rires]
alors est-ce que ce serait pas l'heure
de la pause là oui je suppose que là en
attendant
ne quittez pas bien très bientôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors Mesdames et Messieurs les noirs
viennent de jouer à l'instant tour B8
donc il a protégé le pion on en avait
parlé juste avant la pose c'était pas du
tout obligatoire le pion n'était pas
vraiment
attaqué
parce que il pouvait jouer pour fuite
arrive sur assis le corollaire arrive
sur deux trois en gros ce sont les bons
plutôt qui doivent alors
[Musique]
chercher commande égaliser
normalement c'est possible mais il faut
faire gaffe
blanc d'après l'ordi à cause de cavalier
H4 jouer très vite c'est le coup logique
par Yann donc ouais Ding qui
fait n'importe quoi d'entrée c'était son
premier cours tout le reste c'était les
couilles qui connaissaient par cœur en
gros le problème éternel de ceux qui
apprennent une nouvelle ligne une
nouvelle variante c'est que tu connais
les théories moi tu te sens pas et tu
peux pas tout analyser
la case F5 puis la case G6 peut-être
ok en fait dans 2 si vous voulez
l'aider les plus importants c'était pas
d'attaquer le purmbo 5 en fait l'idée
les plus importants ça a été de déplacer
le cavalier et jouer dans votre avec les
menaces directes fois 6 la dame
appartient
à cette case F3 dans cette position et
donc maintenant alors il faut être
vraiment apprécié pour
ne pas se retrouver
dans les situations délicates à mon avis
il va se faire déchirer le fion
malheureusement je suis plus ou moins
d'accord en fait je vois pas te conduire
comme d'habitude
du monde je t'ai pour lui parce que je
t'ai concernais pas c'est les seules
raisons pourquoi j'étais pour dire que
mais il est pas en un champion du monde
malheureusement il tient pas la pression
il sait pas trop bien préparé en fait
avec le noir avec le banc fantastique
avec le noir non
tout déjà et les vigno avec son Marshall
c'était clair et net que ça va être un
problème c'est toujours Marshall contre
ça c'est pas compris donc il est bien
testé plusieurs fois puis il a changé
pour la française puis il avait peur de
rejouer le français je sais pas pour
qu'il ait raison il a joué Berlin mais
le problème c'est quand un nouveau dans
ce type de position que
trop facile de glisser
donc
[Musique]
maintenant alors Game of Thrones
donc il faut alors comprendre comment on
réagit
bien sûr on peut se permettre une grosse
concession
au moins on est sûr que on va pas être
mal direct c'est fou E6
dégueulasse certes
dis-moi faut vite dans
comment je fais
et moi je demande au lieu de refaire
déjà première réaction c'est
ma première réaction c'est pas drôle
c'est ma première réaction c'est la Tour
Eiffel
et s'il fait pas ABC
Game of Thrones
est-ce que tu peux te permettre
oh peut-être objectivement c'est pas
bien mais d'ailleurs au lieu de boire
aussi
tu peux bouffer sur 3
et je le connais 4
ouais
alors c'est quoi les menaces les menaces
logique
mais ce match nous montre souvent que
les logiques dans ce match marche pas
trop une fois vous êtes stressé
plus vraiment de logique en fait
beaucoup beaucoup d'autres
occupations
en fait ce match ça ressemble bien à
hystérique contre Obélix
parce qu'il est un peu comme Belmondo
c'est fortuite
[Rires]
s'il y a quelqu'un entre vous qui sait
faire le petit tableau qui s'est pas
interdit j'aimerais bien de j'aimerais
bien de voir les figures de hystérique
je voudrais bien voir comment
[Rires]
compliment
j'aimerais bien voir sa gueule
il passe complètement à côté de la
partie mais comme tu dis la préparation
est bonne mais comme c'est une position
qui connaît pas du tout il réussit pas à
la jouer
pourquoi elle est pas réputé les
Françaises
n'est pas au courant
par contre c'est marrant d'ailleurs tu
joues selon le Premier League tu joues
sur la première ligne en cours
c'est terrible
c'est ça la difficulté des prépas c'est
qu'il faut non seulement qu'elle soit
bonne mais en plus que les mecs soient
capables de la jouer
écoute toutes les recettes des dieux les
recettes magiques sont connues
quand tu prépares une nouvelle ligne
c'est pas que tu prépares tout ce que
théorique ce que tu joues gendre entre
15 et 20 partie d'entraînement et plutôt
plutôt de partie de rapide que les
parties en fait juste pour devenir
familier à ce type de problème si tu
devais
il a tout écrit comme une fois on a eu
une discussion avec toi et elle t'a dit
l'héritage de bouton est bien comment
dire
sous-estimé oui tout à fait d'accord
mais vous savez
Mesdames et Messieurs que par exemple
est-ce qu'il faisait par exemple il a
forcé son secondant qui s'appelait
ragozyme dont on a la défense magazine
et la force
de fumer
[Applaudissements]
l'autre j'ai plus ça a été qui il a
forcé de parler pendant la partie pour
être devenu habitué à Aubry
et en plus je me répète pour les
milliers fois de faut pas trop pousser
le théâtre non plus
on va arrêter là
mais je me répète pour les millions de
fois désolé pour le faire
il a sorti les phrases les meilleures
jamais aux échecs
vous voulez donc devenir champion du
monde il faut que vous vous posez les
questions est-ce que vous le voulez
vraiment
très libre si tu penses c'est vraiment
dips ça y est c'est digne de pas des
phrases de Bouddha quoi mais vous le
voulez mais vous voulez vraiment ou pas
parce que dans ces cas-là qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire de vouloir devenir champion
du monde ça veut dire que vous êtes pas
comme les autres donc on va se Biton
famille
[Musique]
il y a aussi une phrase qui a été dites
par un par un rappeur connu Booba et qui
correspond bien à ce que vit Ding li
Rennes actuellement dans son premier
album temps mort il a dit je demande un
temps mort parce qu'on se fait [__] au
score
et je pense que c'est vraiment ce que
doit faire digne là non
c'est un peu moins bonne vinigas que
mais c'est tout aussi dit non ah ouais
ouais
écoutez dans ce type de position alors
même si les bons perdent un tempo en
jouant danse de
toute manière
l'idée d'arriver avec la dame sur F3
et tu as tout en concert de pièces si je
peux me permettre une phrase il y a
quand même quatre pièces non 5 faux sang
aussi qui participent à l'attaque de
manière très directe en plus les noirs
peuvent supporter que peuvent se frotter
qui il y a que le cavalier
éventuellement le faux source 5 et un
petit peu fouillé mais déjà le noir sont
un difficile des moyens de défense en
plus il défendent de loin quoi
si ça passe à plus d'eux n'est pas
champion quasiment si l'épo gagne
aujourd'hui c'est quasiment fini topop
et
je pense que j'ai l'impression que ça va
être bien le cas
tu sais à qui ça me fait penser ces
pièces blanches à l'attaque
au grand Milan AC
je sais pas parce que je parlais du
grand Milan AC avec Fabien tu imagines
avec Pirlo Gatuso
il est pas pauvre
équipe de l'histoire tu avais malignant
défense t'avais dit d'avocage
non mais c'était quelque chose quand
même d'ailleurs ça a été lui avec qui se
tient quoi lorsque il est devenu lancé
il a eu des problèmes au début
dans cette équipe c'est toujours le
parent c'est toujours la voix en fait
qui dirige toi
bien sûr
italienne c'était peut-être une des plus
grandes équipes de l'histoire du foot
mais qui est un peu sous-estimé
pas trop beau et qu'est-ce que vous
voulez imagine que la taxe était chef
il y avait caca aussi un peu plus tard
mais
non
la machine qui ajoute tout écrasé au
milieu du terrain
[Musique]
mais moi évidemment mon joueur préféré
c'est tes gâteaux
parce que viril parce que toi tu es pas
viril et donc et lui mettez des bons
taquets à tout le monde non
tacle sur un autre joueur de l'équipe il
venait te défoncer après
non mais vraiment vraiment
alors free fit jouer
ou Game of Thrones
tu veux bouffer le fou tu veux mettre
ton info sur E3 et comme quoi reste là
reste là sinon dams 3 parce que tu
cherches tu cherches tu es quoi
mais je vois pas ce qu'il veut sur dame
F3 ok alors
excuse-moi courtoisie mais
je sais
abandonne
[Musique]
c'est pénible de regarder ça
en fait je sais pas pourquoi c'est que
plus un en fait j'ai l'impression que
c'est déjà plus
je pense que je comprends pourquoi c'est
c'est que plus en parce que dans la
position finale il y a un petit patch ce
que tu as pardon pas encore parce que il
y a
heureusement il y a un coup qui
va jamais
d'habitude tu casses pas ça
mais par contre
il a une idée sur Game of Thrones ça
peut être quoi alors ça peut être
peut-être je sais pas
il a fait n'importe quoi évidemment
aujourd'hui quand je veux partir je veux
pas lire les médias
ils vont être très heureux
toutes les chaînes
dont le résultat j'en ai cinq minutes
après la fin de partie
mais genre même les chaînes type TF1 en
France et tout
ça
pour moi oui pour les autres bien pour
moi
un vrai pays d'échec
en Russie à la télé
du monde je peux vous confier un petit
secret en fait je peux vous confier un
petit secret
en fait la plupart des joueurs russes a
été contre karakin lorsque le joueur
chômage la plupart toujours
et dans le mois je présente
vous pouvez vous demander pourquoi mais
c'est ainsi juste avant
j'ai pas j'ai combien
en s'écrit souvent
il n'y a pas de progrès qui me prend
pour
tout le monde aurait été pourri tout le
monde à la mamie à la manifester
mais qui aime pas du coup
sa copine
les gens sont secondaires ou même lui il
est non
c'est terrible ça genre vraiment
[Musique]
c'est trop
même les peaux ne s'aiment pas
mais pourquoi il est si désagréable
il y a pas mal de raisons
personnalité et puis les questions
financières
ok juste je veux vous donner comment
dire les gens par exemple oui bien sûr
ouais je peux juste vous donner de la
bouffe mentale pour essayer de
comprendre qu'est-ce qui se passe depuis
des années depuis Jeanne à 8 ans est-ce
que les gens de Russes filles ou mec
gagne le championnat du monde
juniorer avant 12 ans 14 ans 16 ans 18
ans 20 ans
c'est toujours les les Indiens les
Ouzbeks après tout qu'est-ce que je veux
dire avec cela il y a une impression que
la grosse toux que les fédérations de
Russes accumulent et les divisée pas
trop correctement
ça le problème tout va à ceux qui vivent
à Moscou au pire Saint-Pétersbourg si tu
vis je passe saratove la diva stock je
vais pas voir une neige
tu vois pas toucher en
des problèmes éternels tu veux dire que
Moscou c'est un peu comme pour nous
Paris mais on vient pire beaucoup donc
les gens doivent vraiment les détester
tu veux tu veux réussir quoi que ce soit
aux échecs
spécifique aux échecs non c'est pas
spécifique aux échecs mais je connais
moi bien sur les Autosports aux échecs
et c'est éternel d'ailleurs ça a été
d'ailleurs le cas à l'Union soviétique
bah il faut que tu vis dans les deux
vidéos
sinon plus ou moins foutu
d'ailleurs pour te dire j'ai jamais
profité de ça mais je suis né à Moscou
tu es parti trop tôt au Kazakhstan
et à cause de ça les gens n'aiment pas
né pour
notamment
les investissements à sa préparation
sont juste énormes et les gens se disent
mais pourquoi pas un jaune une jaune
lui peut devenir champion du monde
[Musique]
personnellement peut-être oui mais les
fédérations mais pas très populaire
que
et par ricochet ça lui retombe dessus
par exemple maintenant je travaille avec
les casaques ils ont cette année-là ils
ont donné la Bourse aux trois meilleurs
juniors et autres mecs
et la Bourse est assez redescente tu
peux te permettre les enseignants tu
peux jouer les tournois que tu veux
enfin bien
en Russie non
les hommes de la Fédération dans la
conscience collective oui ce sont les
résumés les offices choses quoi les
offices
on comprend pourquoi alors
mais bon il est pas pour grand-chose non
plus
Duba les gens n'aiment pas trop non plus
non je te donne juste un exemple il
commence dans ses situations là on peut
se porter
un exemple excusez-moi
mon pote les dernières fois il a gagné
le tournoi il y avait un il y avait
plusieurs étrangers il y avait des
Russes il a gagné le torrent
il a dit dans la cérémonie de couture il
a dit je vais pas prendre cet argent
donnez-moi la liste des vétérans sans
critiqueront et donc je je laisse tout
assez vite et j'invite mes collègues qui
ont bien touché dans ce tournoi de faire
les mêmes choses et c'était Hatem bien
fait karakim et l'homme soutenu de cette
affaire donc les trois premiers ont
alors envoyer tout l'argent au vétérans
genre d'échec vétérans
ceux qui ont plus que 70 ans
est-il vraiment si populaire en Russie
malgré son engagement contre la guerre
bah écoutez il y a aucun problème s'il
est contre la guerre
si vous voulez
la plupart des gens connus ça veut dire
des sportifs du haut niveau des artistes
machin la plupart des gens en Russie
sont contre les gars donc ça pose aucun
problème si vous êtes contre la guerre
non aucun problème vous pouvez être rien
à voir en fait
parce que parlant de joueurs de chèque
bah il y a une quinzaine de joueurs de
chez Christ qui est maintenant en
Kazakhstan parce qu'ils sont contre la
guerre il y a Jeanne
russe qui sont en Arménie parce qu'ils
sont contre la guerre il y a pas mal de
joueurs qui sont en Europe comme j'ai
pas vu du gaufres en République tchèque
puis en Espagne il fait d'essayer fan
Espagne qui sont à la gare qui sont
contre la gare il y a pas de problème
aucun problème mais ils sont partis
mais c'était leur choix ils pouvaient y
rester il pouvait y rester mais ils se
sont prononcés ok tu vois
tu peux être pour tu peux te contre il y
a pas de problème
bon en tout cas Ding il est en sueur
Vlad
en fait il joue juste nettement moins
bien cette position il a aucun coup quoi
c'est le pire scénario en fait pour les
Noirs en fait je peux me faudra te dire
que je me suis jamais retrouvé de ce
situation parce que des cavaliers H4D
toujours à votre peur et donc si tu veux
je faisais quoi que ce soit pour éviter
ce genre de trucs en fait donc ça m'a
jamais arrivé je pouvais gagner je
pourrais faire une je pourrais perdre
mais ça j'ai jamais permis parce que
j'ai toujours aussi que c'est c'est
catastrophique quoi juste peut-être tu
vas pouvoir tenir pendant trois quatre
coups et puis sur le cinquième coup de
toute façon tout slip et tu verras je
suis trop facile de jouer avec les bons
ici toi contre moi tu es un grand favori
avec le monde
grand
que tu marques quoi
je t'assaille
c'est pour dire
à quel point c'est gagnant et contre le
mien même si je t'ai jamais un
adversaire facile pour toi
je sais me concentrer donc je vais
résister mais
je sais pas faire ici c'est quoi
et si toi tu as les blancs contre moi
les réponses
c'est pas la peine de
formuler les réponses je m'en suis fait
100% non
[Musique]
le problème c'est que il laisse jamais
faire ça
oui il est comme moi il est comment en
fait il va jamais te laisser ça en fait
je sais pas c'est même pas pensé que
scénario en fait tu peux gagner ou pas
gagner mais tu vois jamais réussir à
voir ça une épaule il a quoi à 80% de
chance de gagner
20% pour sauver
80% que on est pour gagne parce que
c'est tellement facile ça coule comme ça
tellement facile de jouer tellement
agréable
il a joué
[Musique]
un petit peu plus tard aujourd'hui
désolé qui va nous quitter
mais peut-être en fait tu nous quittes
le jour où n'est pas en quelque sorte
parce que en soit le match cinépo gagne
aujourd'hui le match continue mais en
soit il sera terminé
maintenant je sais pas si vous êtes au
courant mais depuis plus que un an il y
a plus de vol direct donc quand on
arrive ici on est obligé de passer par
une autre ville soit Istanbul soit
Dubaï ou bien encore plus grand donc un
peu passé par l'hermini ou Kazakhstan
n'est pas trop populaire pour cette
variante là par contre point des Russes
font mal alors Moscou Arménie et puis
donc l'Europe
après tu pourras aller à Dubaï
oui mais qu'est-ce que ça prend du temps
la dernière fois que je l'ai fait
c'était l'année dernière et donc
j'ai passé plus qu'une journée pour
arriver ici au lieu de 3h et demi
parlons de choses sérieuses
et où le prochain stage de la de c'est
encore les stages en Serbie oh joli au
foot pas pour des raisons financières
parce que les billets d'avion sont
devenus trop chers pour aller en Serbie
excusez moi de parler de choses comme ça
mais rien que hier
je pense ah non avant
que peut-être c'est considérable
d'organiser les stages en France
ça m'intéresse ça m'intéresse je sais
pas si donc qui vit une fois pour s'en
occuper
ça m'intéresse
donc tu es pas chaud quoi
cette année dur
ça l'année prochaine faisable mais là la
petite elle est trop petite dommage
c'est compliqué avec la petite
parce qu'elle est tu as vu quoi parce
que petit est petit
et petit
parmi vous il y a quelqu'un qui est un
bon organisateur peut-être si vous
voulez vraiment vous pouvez peut-être
essayer d'organiser contactez pas pour
moi pourquoi pas je suis en train de
mourir donc
il y avait pas trop le choix en fait
parce que
bien trop passif et de toute façon
peut-être elle va pas permettre au noir
de défendre le roi plus tard donc boire
sans coup logique au moine sur X6
tourbedo peut-être et comme ça peut-être
un jour il vous renvoyait je sais pas ça
tourne le fou
ok si je joue mécaniquement
il y a rien en fait
[Musique]
alors sur quoi si il y a d'autres
alternatives alors peut-être peut-être
la fameuse vie
éternelle
2 c'était comment ça marchait
ok là tu bouges ton covoit
[Musique]
qui a dit ça mais j'ai pas refait la
variante parce qu'on était déjà arrivé
là oh oui Maxime bravo
peut-être même envoyé une c'est déjà dur
il a pris son
OK
bah peut-être il va trouver cette ligne
tout simplement par comment ça s'appelle
élimination
c'était déduction ok en fait élimination
c'est un petit peu aux déduction
s
les méthodes de d'élimination on appelle
d'habitude les méthodes de risques
d'ailleurs
pour vous informer donc si vous voulez
il y avait qui comme les élèves les plus
connus
et
à un moment donné quelqu'un je pense que
ça a été celui-là qui m'a dit maintenant
ils ont toujours le même problème les
élèves de dorisky ils sont très bien
quand il faut éliminer les coups
toujours mauvais quoi
Carlsen mais Pontus Carlson
avec qui tu dois sortir il se ferme
ils disent que officiellement c'est le
déduction de ma faute de l'induction ce
que les écrivent dans la dans la
Wikipédia mais c'est pas assez fort pour
me prononcer peut-être vous avez raison
tu es en fan de Sherlock Holmes ah oui
mais j'ai écrit même nouvelle
de Sherlock Holmes
18 vers la fin de la gare et pendant
l'épidémie donc j'ai écrit cette
nouvelle lorsque les pandémie est
arrivée mais tu n'as jamais publié non
je n'ai jamais publié en fait j'écris
pas mal de choses mais je n'ose toujours
pas de publier ça fait combien de temps
que tu écris maintenant
mais t'as jamais rien publié
j'ai écrit une petite nouvelle sur
Sherlock Holmes 18 pendant les pandémie
de ce qu'on appelle Espagne
j'ai écrit la nouvelle sur Yvan le
terrible quand elle était mort pourquoi
je l'écris parce que c'est connu qu'il
était mort en juin et donc ça m'a
inspiré j'écris une nouvelle et
plusieurs autres mais ce sont les deux
les plus importants
quelqu'un les a lu
bien sûr que non ah non pas dans le chat
bien sûr non mais sinon j'ai montré ça à
plusieurs amis
j'ai montré ça à une rédactrice de
maison de publication à Anne Serbie j'ai
bien nommé ses réactions
c'est juste que je veux si tu veux je
veux écrire encore genre 10 et puis
publié pour mes 50 ans
donc 9 novembre j'ai pointé donc si tu
si vous voulez je vais vous faire un
recul de nouvelles pour mes 50 ans c'est
ça va être le meilleur cadeau le
meilleur cadeau c'est que c'est le
cadeau que tu proposes à toi-même
ah non j'ai jamais montré ça
je sais pas si j'ai eu raison ou pas
mais je les ai même
[Musique]
il peut être piquant
et dans ce cas-là je veux plus avoir le
courage de continuer et j'ai besoin du
courage pour que tu as écrit un tel ne
comprendrais pas la finesse
[Rires]
non mais c'est juste que une petite
observation mais les amis
vous savez quelqu'un qui vous connaissez
et quelqu'un vous montre son
[Musique]
œuvre artistique j'ai pas une chanson
ou une nouvelle ou quelque chose de ce
genre et si vous recritiquez grave si
vous vous casser à ce moment-là et un
truc il faut quand même bien en avance
vous pouvez être complètement sûr quand
vous vous montrer votre truc plus tard
peu importe c'est quoi il va vous casser
ça c'est les règles d'or en fait
ça marche toujours comme ça donc c'est
sûr que Murtas va te casser
[Rires]
[Musique]
tu peux revenir sur la position de la
partie s'il te plaît
oui
plus ou moins oui en fait parce que ok
on a parlé de quoi on a parlé de fou je
sens
etc quoi dire d'autre
si paf je sens que alors
j'ai peur que les bandes peuvent pas se
permettre de
sang tout simplement parce que
je vois pas comment on peut justifier le
sacrifice de
soi
c'est plus mince en fait enfin une fois
les bois ont bouffé sur H6 quand les
soucis ce n'est plus une menace
autant de temps non oui donc si vous
voulez coller surprise permet au noir de
bouffer les pièces alors c'est plutôt
fou je sens parce que ça paraît d'être
le coût le plus agressif
tout bêtement parce que si tu menaces
sans réfléchir bien sûr maintenant sur
dame de Yaka
l'ordinateur propose donc je veux pas le
cacher l'idée de 3 dans mes trois
tourbes
pour la même raison pour la seule raison
trouvable parce que pas trop de choix
c'est comme hier vous avez bien résumé
d'ailleurs avec Fab pourquoi elle n'a
pas trouvé de tour de droite
qui a l'air hyper cool c'est pour ça
qu'elle n'a pas joué le coup qui gagne
tout de suite ouais mais c'est un
problème des fois quand tu as une option
qui est trop facile en fait
comment dire
sagesse
certes assez banal mais l'une de sa
chaise sagesse ça c'est marquante c'est
lascare si vous voyez un bon coup
passé du temps pour réfléchir un peu
parce que peut-être il y a mieux que ça
après dans les tournois sur internet des
fois il trouve
quoi qu'il en soit le meilleur coup
comme par hasard
là ils arrivent
le truc c'est que
il a vu où
c'est pour ça que je joue pas parce
qu'il est vieux ça
et donc il hésite alors est-ce que ça va
être assez est-ce que ça va être
beaucoup peut-être pas vraiment
il doit se décider là donc après avoir
déconné avec turboite après donc
c'est concentré donc braque les 5 c'est
exactement ce que il faut le faire bah
qu'est-ce que je veux dire
pourquoi les yeux sur Fougères
[Musique]
au niveau du temps c'est plus ou moins
égal
presque
56 minutes pour Ding une heure et 4 4
minutes pour je pense qu'il va bientôt
jouer
qu'est-ce que on peut dire bah le moment
critique en fait
le moment critique
avec quel numéro du cours cavalier
du match faudrait qu'il tienne la nul
oh oui bien sûr
parce que ça promet d'être peut-être
l'un des matchs les plus excitants de
l'histoire de
reste alors pour cela il faut absolument
que ne peut pas aujourd'hui
est-ce que à moins de
et encore combien six parties à jouer
c'est bien trop
probablement ça va être juste de la
boucherie vers la fin il va trop risqué
à un moment donné elle va perdre le
troisième ça y est fini officiel
officiellement faut que je garde
aujourd'hui et
j'ai l'impression il est pas élève de
The Voice Kim comme quoi il est presque
élève de dorisky
que je crois que aux échecs si tu
réussis à trouver les seuls coups juste
à bien jouer contre une option tu es
déjà hyper fort
d'ailleurs j'ai essayé de devenir
l'élève de risque à un moment donné mais
j'ai failli il a pas voulu de toi
je rencontre
c'est toujours bien trop cher
[Musique]
là tu vois craquer 3000 dans une semaine
c'était un peu trop pour moi par jour de
travail franchement c'est pas très cher
oui peut-être
mais il était vraiment bien
qu'est-ce que je peux en dire j'ai lu
tous ce livre les livres sont vraiment
bien sans aucun doute très très très
très compliqué mais
mais je m'entendais à ça et puis comment
ça se travaille avec lui perso face à
face aucune idée j'étais pas là
non mais c'est pas très cher parce que
après
que j'ai passé jusqu'à quart de finale
championnat du monde donc c'était
non mais maintenant ouais après c'est
vrai que c'était il y a 20 ans donc
ouais avec l'inflation et tout ça fait
cher parce que maintenant tu vois plein
de profs d'échec même en France
pas comme ça en fait je suis
l'entraîneur ça marche pas comme ça
la journée 500 c'est pas 60 euros par
jour parce que quand il y a beaucoup des
heures
tu fais toujours la réduction non mais
je sais mais bon quand tu vois
aujourd'hui tu as pas mal d'entraîneur
en France
même en dessous de 2005 qui prennent
plus de 100 euros de l'heure
tu dis que c'est pas
pour un tel que de vos redski ça paraît
même si on avec l'inflation et tout tu
dis que c'est 800 euros c'est pas ouais
bon c'est cher après mais
qui ne sont plus du tout fiables en fait
alors comment je suis
il veut alors je vois toujours pas
peut-être tu peux m'expliquer alors mais
qu'est-ce qu'il veut
je sais pas calculer par contre j'ai pas
peur
ok comprenons déjà pourquoi torréfié tu
marches pas
mais franchement je vois pas où est le
problème après faut 6 ah il fait cavaler
F5 d'accord
quoi que à vrai dire heureusement
parlant
c'est pas le fond du monde non plus OK
qui arrive tu joues comme le
c'est toujours jouable mais je suppose
que peut être mieux que ça parce que
quand même on a perdu le tempo avec eux
à 5000 avec uniquement la partie de
l'Opéra dessus pardon
[Rires]
ouais il faut aussi c'était pas obligé
mais ça donnait envie quoi bah si tu
joues pas que vous aussi c'est toujours
peut-être que vous voulez ou vite alors
oui un problème
certes c'est un petit peu désagréable
en tant que oui il a participé comme
d'habitude quand tu demandes des joueurs
énormes participent à quoi que ce soit
ça veut dire ta préparation le scénario
de film c'est toujours mauvais parce que
les grands joueurs pensent que quoi
qu'ils disent c'est toujours génial
c'est loin parce que le film est très
bas très bien mais ce que la partie
entend que un jour de chèque à ce film
c'est plus moignon en fait parce que
j'ai pas aimé son tâche j'ai pas aimé
les positions que il a rapporté le ok en
gros tu sais ce qu'il a fait pour le
comment dire pour la position dans les
femelles et la juste
copier-coller en Arctique il doit avoir
bac dans les années 60
il était avant
il avait la flemme de trouver une
position
un article peut-être qu'il a même pas
fait lui-même d'ailleurs
donc si vous voulez
je parlais déjà du film qui s'appelle
champion du monde lucide
un film rusco face assez récent il y en
a
c'est basé sur l'histoire des du match
de Carrefour
1978 et donc là le consultante c'était
pas casparo c'était pour
encore pire mais c'est pas lui qui a dû
donner les exemples non plus en fait
encore beaucoup pire les mensonges sur
chaque mot partir ce qui est bof voilà
bah demandez jamais l'aide à 2008
demandez jamais il est de 2008
adressez-vous toujours
là on a fait le livre avec Fab sur les
tactiques
il a l'impression d'en faire en fait
t'imagines pas la vitesse de travail de
femme en fait je pense que tu peux pas
imaginer ouais il clique il clique à une
vitesse incroyable
je viens de voir le tournoi il est cool
d'ailleurs je vous cache pas les vérités
j'ai jamais vu le temps
pourquoi j'ai pas vu
de tester
[Musique]
désolé
non mais là tu imagines pas à quel
vitesse il a fait les cahiers
d'entraînement quoi
en fait un moment donné il s'assied pour
travailler il s'assie reste assis
pendant 8 heures d'affilée et il écrit
il écrit TAPIS Tapis tapi mais il tape
hyper vite pendant hyper longtemps
au dernier stage qu'on a fait à Lisbonne
on a entamé un tournoi
et ok moi j'arrive le matin au tournoi
j'allume l'ordi et tout je dis Fab c'est
quoi le software pour faire les le
système suisse et là il sort un [__]
de calepin de 100 pages il m'a dit non
je fais les apparisants à la main
et il a fait pendant toute la journée
les appariements de tout le tournoi à la
main quoi avec des papiers il écrivait
et tout
les puissances jamais
mais quand il était petit il faisait un
truc incroyable il m'a raconté il
faisait des Tours de France avec des
cyclistes en plastique tu sais
et avec des dés donc il envoyait des dés
pour faire avancer les coureurs avec un
peloton
et à la fin de chaque étape il écrivait
les scores les temps des des coureurs et
il faisait les [__] d'étapes tous les
jours et avec cette petite figure il est
il mettait le maillot jaune sur les sur
les leaders bien sûr
et il écrivait et il écrivait les temps
après chaque course les vainqueurs des
courses etc
il faisait tout le tour de France comme
ça c'est en fait tu le prends
tu t'en rends pas compte quand tu
le vois
en fait c'est une [__] de machine
c'est tout d'un coup en fait tu le lance
et il est inarrêtable
en fait il faisait exactement les mêmes
choses avec les commentaires les
cyclistes que moi je faisais quand
j'étais gosse avec les petits soldats
quand j'ai rejoué toutes les plus grands
batailles en fait c'est ça mais en fait
tu sais ça me fait penser à une phrase
dans Batman avec le Joker c'est quand
une force un stop rencontre une pierre
inamovible c'est
sa femme en fait
écoutez les amis alors donc tourbe de
jouer alors
digne de plus ou moins de même humour
que moi donc en gros il pose les
questions je bouffe le plus on est
qu'est-ce que tu veux
maintenant si pour va jouer à tempo
cavalier
c'est pas les choses les plus évidentes
s'il le faut que il y a des soupçons moi
je suis toujours David d'appeler
l'arbitre pour vérifier quoi qu'il en
soit
et comme ça des fois pendant les parties
si jamais pour être sûr on n'est jamais
trop sûr
il y a fab qui regarde bizarrement la
position
qui arrive c'est une force en stop en
fait Fab
vous savez le problème avec les fouilles
il est vrai certes que souvent vous avez
envie d'appeler l'arbitre pour qu'il
fait quelque chose le problème c'est le
plus souvent c'est les organisateurs ils
veulent pas il va pas fuir il veut le
poids ils disent bah faut il faut avoir
l'accord de la police et la police
t'inquiète il va vérifier le fouilleur
[Rires]
avec tout le matos tu sais il sort
le matos si tu vois Fab tu triches plus
en fait tu comprends à quoi tu
tu t'exposes
Fab est le problème à tout et le la
solution à tous les problèmes ouais
le F d'ailleurs
très probablement jouer revenir ça
dépend de ce que on va voir hier par
exemple j'ai pas eu du temps tout est
terminé si je reviens pas à la prochaine
je vous retrouve à Moscou si je reviens
bah c'est une autre histoire allez les
francophones
et on revient après
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
le fi c'est pas passé grand chose
pendant qu'on a fait la pause en fait il
y a eu le cavalier ici du coup tu prends
mes deux on l'avait vu et qu'elle va les
prendre F8 mais il a pas joué de tour
des trois le cours recommandé par l'ordi
mais torpan est fuite mais avec vade on
savait pas trop c'est la position qu'on
avait tout à l'heure et on imaginait
tous ces quatre
pour les blancs
OK
bon ça a l'air pas trop mal pour les
blancs quand même ouais ouais mais après
à quel point c'est gagnant c'est ça la
question c'est peut-être un grand mot
mais mieux
juste le tour des trois c'était quoi le
c'était vraiment compliqué
et il te laissait le cavalier là-bas
pour le moment OK
ouais mais bon enfin c'est dur non mais
oui bon je sais chaque jour
tu contre-attaques de l'autre côté bon
c'est dur oui mais c'est pas un là c'est
pas introuvable
c'est dur
qu'est-ce-que
bon attaque le Caval a priori on avait
toujours cavalier H7 là-dessus
automatiquement tu te barres et tu
gagnes un tempo il retouche la tourelle
et tout quoi
il fait pas tout Français
bon
en fait pour ces deux c'est pas un coup
que tu as envie si tu joues pas en blitz
tempo mais si tu réfléchis peut-être
c'est trouvable quoi alors
il y a pas tu dis attends même sans voir
l'autre
et alors oui ça aurait été B3 qui vient
est-ce que voilà allez on va se faire
qu'il le fasse
mais j'ai discuté avec Vlad du coup du
perpète non trouvé par
dingue
[Musique]
les vêtements de perpète parce que
j'étais surpris que guéri donc pour tous
les vendeurs de guéri et à Nantes il y a
absolument inhumain introuvable et en
fait moi j'ai pris du coup j'ai regardé
leur vidéo bon évidemment ils ont tous
dit roi E5 parce qu'ils ont tous regardé
la première ligne de l'ordi et moi j'ai
montré à la droit E3 plus humain et Vlad
me dit non hyper facile à trouver enfin
facile même si tu commences à calculer
tu vois parce que c'est forcé bien sûr
mais il m'a dit non c'est pas dur ok roi
E5 déjà c'est bizarre mais donc ouais
non non je passe
en capacité de le voir je te dis pas que
je l'aurais vu mais je calcule je peux
voir ça quand même avec le roi E5 moi il
paraît plus dur qu'avec le 3 mais le roi
E3 en fait il y a plus d'échec tout de
suite non mais en fait c'est simple de
calculer loin quand c'est forcé enfin tu
peux faire des lignes de 20 coups quoi
enfin c'est pas c'est pas du tout
impossible 25 août c'était genre normal
[Musique]
d'ailleurs dans le livre genre il y a un
match de en 25
bon on le voit assez vite nous dans
lequel d'entraînement
mais du coup je veux dire oui enfin
c'est pas juste histoire de dire enfin
non non mais c'est
il va rendre direct moi je vais jamais
jamais compter le nombre de coups
ça ne me dérange pas en fait
quand c'est vraiment forcé c'est
de toute façon on peut faire une partie
entière à l'aveugle donc bien sûr donc
parce que je disais vlades contre 12
adversaires pas mal oui donc une
variante de 10
en réalité je pense que si c'est passé
dans ces commentaires c'est qu'ils ont
regardé la première ligne de l'ordi
très compliqué et du coup ils sont là
oui encore de la même machin échec ou
quoi ils ont jamais allé chercher qu'il
y avait trois en fait
mais pour moi ça prouve qu'il te dit si
qui commande sans là mais il a pas
trouvé ça prouve pour moi qui commente
beaucoup à l'ordi aussi un peu comme
nous
[Musique]
parce que sinon en fait tu regardes
droits si tu regardes sans ordi tu
regardes 3
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vrai que tous ces deux
faut bien
que la file là
tout le temps ouais bon c'était le thème
bah écoute pas trouvé
non mais
après je pense que ce qu'il a voulu
faire ce qu'on prend en fait et là vous
lui faire pousser quatre fois aussi faut
prendre puis on prend ok là il est
content là tu es content donc à vrai
dire il a dû trouver ça il est content
et maintenant il faut à trois
mais
ouais c'est dommage d'autant rater en
fait en fait bizarrement genre le tour
C2 je le trouve plus difficile que le
perpète parce que tu peux juste ne pas
regarder
bah c'est sûrement ce qui s'est passé
ouais tu dis oui je suis pas con j'ai
pas mon mur et la tour quoi et
[Musique]
ok ça c'est pas vraiment pas simple mais
bon malheureusement c'est que le truc
enfin si tu penses ça a l'air de moins
en moins con puis tu le vois et
tu es séduit par l'idée même en fait
mais c'est que je pense qu'il est juste
pas considéré
[Musique]
fallait voir dans la distance ouais mais
bon enfin quelqu'un est dans le truc des
perpettes mais bon au bout d'un moment
de toute façon tu vois pas toutes les
variantes à voir quand tu joues aux
échecs même quand tu joues les bons
coups tu vois pas tous les coups c'est
juste qu'il y a des trucs bon il trouve
que ça marche ça marche
en fait mais là ouais
donc qu'est-ce qui va jouer là
je me disais ce qui peut jouer fou ici
mais le problème c'est l'idée c'est que
sur Full prend aussi tu peux plus faire
cavalier prend mais bon est-ce que même
ça est-ce que ça tu es si mécontent
moi j'ai beaucoup de mal à juger ce
genre de truc
je surestime souvent les pions comme ça
ils sont ils sont plus pour que
d'habitude tu as pas de purge
donc tu es plus faible là-bas
mais après bon à part ça c'est juste une
observation
lambda je dis ça je dis rien en fait
c'est l'observation de femme mais ça
change de trois trucs enfin tu vois tu
as des cases tu peux les rôder le renard
est plus faible que la coutumée et
et donc ça peut poser peut-être des
soucis
[Musique]
mais moi ça j'aurais du mal à juger ok
je me sentais à mieux blanc déjà j'ai un
fou je suis content tu vois si je
t'envoie le pion là jusqu'à H6 c'est la
merde
je détruis complètement le rock quoi
donc je sais pas d'impsec4 je me place
juste en fait je suis pas très touchant
je sais pas il peut rester là peut-être
j'en sais rien H4 H5 on va aller voir un
peu là-bas et petit à petit j'essaie de
la tour en D8
je leur dis quoi et maintenant si je
fais faux aussi
faut prendre V5
bon ça ça m'a l'air moins clair que
l'autre moi j'aimerais bien on regarde
la tour non
pourquoi j'ai pas envie
pas facile enfin je veux dire ah oui
évident quand tu as la position sous les
yeux mais de loin déjà 8
[Musique]
et il faut ces quatre fois aussi c'est
quoi le truc là au moins on se double
pas les pions aussi cette fois non mais
ça je sais pas c'est pas net
peut-être c'est net pour l'ordi mais
pour moi pourquoi c'est net pour leur
dire
en plus le nôtre il est pas trop génial
je joue ces coups juste pour comprendre
non mais j'imagine qu'en fait tu arrives
pas pousser tes pions
concrètement
[Musique]
même ça tu as joué sa première ligne sur
plusieurs coups
peut-être enfin petit à petit aller vers
à 7 verset
et je sais pas quoi mais je serai pas
catastrophe d'avoir ça avec les Noirs
non non non non mais même
il va sûrement jouer
et c'est pas clair pour la partie et
non mais je comprends pas
moi j'aurais ça avec les Noirs
je vais [__] quoi
je sais pas s'il est mieux
j'ai mon cavalier j'ai mes pions et je
poussais quoi on va voir
je me dirais vraiment ça en partie
je sais pas au moins tu en as un plan
clair et voilà je comprends même pas ce
qu'il dit oui
[Musique]
non mais bravo
en fait peut-être qu'on est très content
de laisser le four en 6 qui bloque la
colonne
on va voir comment ça se passe
et du coup alors c'est quoi cette
histoire de français avec les deux enfin
moi je sais mon histoire mais c'était ça
t'en parler
de quelle idée non de Tour de France
avec les dés Tour de France avec les dés
les papiers les classements mais je les
ai encore je pense j'ai toutes mes
archives de mes tours de France perso il
y avait un bonus pour les grimpeurs ou
ouais je
faisais en fait je me crée enfin au
début je vais sur un jeu de loi et après
en fait j'avais pris le circuit tu as
des petites voitures où tu avais des
petites manettes et du coup j'avais peur
en ami du scotch rouge là du chatterton
un peu ce que c'est le rouge pour faire
des cases et puis je foutais des BD pour
faire des montées et enfin ça
ressemblait vraiment à une étape quoi
j'étais très chaud quoi mais donc du
coup si tu étais sprinter quand ça
montait tu étais pénalisé bah non des
fois le mec il faisait que des six fou
ils montaient très très vite et puis
dans la plaine il avançait plus fringale
je sais pas moi mais
ça revenait de l'arrière ça pouvait un
peloton entier c'était
hyper long
mais tu sais ça pendant le Tour de
France ouais souvent c'était l'été ça me
chauffait
et il y avait combien d'étapes dans le
tour je sais plus ce qu'on va peut-être
21 enfin c'est possible
[Musique]
ok je sais plus son nom mais tu avais
quoi tu avais 5 joueurs tu avais cinq
boutons tu peux
avancera et de défenseur tu avais le
goal avec un petit machin gauche droite
et tu avais les corners et les touches
qui sautaient tout seul automatique quoi
et en fait du coup je bon bah soit soit
j'avais un adversaire mais bon comme
j'étais fils unique des fois j'étais
tout ça donc je me le tournais main
droite contre main gauche c'était les
rouges contre les bleus et puis c'était
le coup d'Europe quoi
mais c'était pas subutéo c'était
un truc à pile quoi enfin c'était
électrique
ouais
bon
le goût
je sais pas ouais bon enfin je veux pas
trop mal
on a fait 17e de France et on va revenir
l'an prochain on va essayer de faire
mieux mais c'est déjà dur en fait de
faire top 1
ils étaient pas en Ligue 2 à l'époque
les Verts à ses terribles
après on a fait de la Ligue 2 on a fait
la nationale on s'est sauvé on a remonté
on est redescendu et qui sort des faux
passeports
j'ai connu des des années noires un peu
aussi
bon en ce moment c'est pas top là ça va
mieux je suis plus trop quoi enfin on va
pas descendre en National quoi
en fait j'aime pas du tout les règles de
la coinche de synthé on a une règle
n'importe quoi je sais pas quoi on joue
en fait
ça mais
c'est quoi votre règle notre règle je
sais pas enfin tu crois pas je joue au
même jeu quoi c'est que tu as que 6
cartes pas 8 au début j'étais annonces
les annonces vont de 5 en 5 pas de 1010
donc du coup tu peux annoncer tes as
comme ça
on joue avec les annonces les tierces
les 50 les carrés les machins bon pour
n'importe quoi aussi et
il y a le Sans Atout mais il y a pas le
tout atout
voilà
donc ça marche comment déjà tout bah les
valets sont plus forts
[Musique]
et donc et donc oui et puis les deux
dernières cartes tu les as appris coup
donc peut-être annoncé un truc et puis
tu te prends deux set de merde ou du
chopes
j'ai jamais je comprends pas
donc en fait quand tu es petit et que tu
as jamais joué à rien d'autre tu crois
que c'est normal enfin mais après tu
découvres
l'autre jeu il est beaucoup mieux et je
peux plus y jouer quoi ce truc en fait
quoi
en plus il y a pas une petite différence
de règle en fait et pourquoi ils ont
fait ça à Saint-Étienne
et à Lyon
à Lyon il jouait à 8 cartes
et après je sais pas peut-être qu'ils
font quand même les tierces les machins
ça faut enlever c'est de la merde on
s'en fout que les cartes se suivent ou
que tu es un carré ou pas
le nom du jeu
et ça fait une grosse différence
[Musique]
du coup et ouais
mais on est d'accord que tu peux pas
prendre à la toux parce que tu as juste
de l'autre belote ah non
après je sais pas peut-être que si tu as
10 ça se dit ça se dit c'est belote
rebelote
faut pas mal tomber si tu as les atouts
répartis de 2 ça va aller tu joues de
coude à tout il y a plus un seul à tout
tu fermes ça va parce qu'il y a que il y
a 60 points là
[Musique]
donc
ça va aller mais tu peux pas tu peux pas
aller trop loin non plus quoi mais bon
dès que c'est un peu mal réparti que ton
mec
je sais pas un quatrième en main
bah tu te fais couper tes trucs enfin
c'est la merde quoi
donc
mais après là encore il y a des règles
selon parce que quand je jouais à
Montpellier
en fait quand est belote et tu dis 80 tu
as que 60 à faire
bon parce qu'en fait on soit oui tu fais
60 + 20 à 80 mais j'aime pas parce qu'en
fait pour moi l'attaque de quand même
faire plus que la défense
en fait si tu fais 60 ça veut dire que
la défense a fait 100 même d'ajouter 20
points je trouve ça limite enfin tu fais
deux plis
au moins faire 81 ou 82 je pense
mais sans c'est bon tu peux faire 80 +
20 mais ça c'est normal je pense
tu vas jamais annoncer 80 ah tu peux
annoncer parce que tu veux dire ton
partenaire mais en soi c'est sans quoi
il y a litige tu fais 80 OK
c'est quoi litige
80 c'est que comme il y a 162 pendant le
jeu tu es vraiment pile à la moitié et
donc j'imagine mais toi tu as jamais eu
le cas non donc j'imagine
bah j'en ai fait qu'une condition
officielle
mais
moi en fait disons moi je sais pas je
dirais 82 c'est normal et puis voilà 80
battus et puis tu as qu'à faire plus que
la défense quoi
ah si je devais donner un avis c'est pas
moi qui fait les règles
là c'est ce que dit de faire 82 par
principe ouais je suis d'accord pour le
principe
bref voilà
le petit point belote
de belote je suis pas sûr mais je crois
qu'on y joue quasi en France en fait
chacun en Russie joue une balade mais
c'est pas tout à fait pareil
je sais pas quand
il aime bien mais je sais pas trop ce
que c'est j'ai pas joué avec eux en fait
donc
ils peuvent je fais un peu de tarot une
soirée
il joue bien je joue bon au départ il
est plutôt perdu sans là mais bon des
fois aussi quand même dépendant de tes
cartes enfin
ouais mon tour 8 on va voir on a vu de
façon la variante avec tous ces quatre
mais c'est pas surtout envie de rentrer
dedans non moi j'aime pas trop mais bon
après il peut il peut aussi calculer
loin et comprendre des trucs qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire d'autre à la pinceau C4
[Musique]
aussi si tu prends il prend tu viens en
F5 ça c'est sympathique comme position
quand même
ouais j'aime pas bien la position des
Noirs
à quel point c'est chiant mais ça fait
un moment que c'est pas terrible mais
bon
[Musique]
ça ferme le fou on va faire juste tomber
et si il prend puis on prend tu as les
doigts
avance
ouais
[Musique]
on le subit en fait mais au moins on a
viré le X 2 dans les ventes il faut
aussi
et là en fait et le X 2 qui te tapait F7
et le kf5 qui est bien placé qui se tape
gs7 la dame va venir en soutien je sais
pas où j'ai trois G4 bon tu te fais
mater en quelques coups là en fait donc
tu vas quand même pas tout donner au
blanc quoi tu aimerais mieux ne pas le
voir mais bon bah
des fois tu choisis pas enfin tu
supprimes le foot parce qu'il est chiant
bon voilà
c'est pour ça que de prendre avec le F
comme tu voulais faire ça veut un
certain sens tu te l'air pas qu'elle F5
mais bon je crois que tu défonces trop
le droit quoi
encore une grosse partie
je sais pas là il était pas impressionné
mais après mais il trouvait que ça
s'anime après après la pause en fait je
crois que c'est qu'il était prépa jusque
là digne ok il connaissait jusque là une
épo pas très loin et ouais tour B8
c'était vraiment pas top
en fait c'est logique tomber vite je
viens de dire mais bon mais j'ai en fait
ils ont fait que des coups logiques
jusqu'à maintenant en quelque sorte
mais tomber 5
ouais genre dommage en fait pour ces
deux c'était vraiment bien mais bon je
[Musique]
peux vraiment comprendre je pense je
n'aurais pas considéré en fait en partie
mais
du coup ouais là j'aime bien la position
de niveau
en fait le problème c'est que le pion B5
était pas attaqué tu perds un tempo ou
enfin je sais pas trop tu pouvais faire
juste direct
et si tu fais pion prend puis on prend
dame prank tu as qu'à laisser 5
et direct trop de jeu
donc c'est dommage d'avoir perdu un
tempo par ton V8 quand même mais
peut-être que lui il a pas considéré
il s'ouvre la colonne B ouais mais je
crois que Vlad enfin Vlad disait que
comme il joue jamais la berlinoise
Ding il a dû sous-estimer cavalier H4
d'un F3 enfin il a dû penser que dame 2
ça attaqué le plan B5 en priorité mais
il dit en fait le plan prioritaire
c'était quand même de ça de faire ça
après il a pas mal défendu hein
oui oui bon ben écoute on va voir il
faut qu'il file la qualité
alors bon on a vu que l'ordi mais bien
les blancs mais on demande enfin moi je
demande à voir voilà
c'est sûr mais moi j'aimerais bien les
Noirs en fait c'est marrant mais
j'aurais tellement heureux de jouer avec
les noirs
on a l'impression que les noirs
on va arriver à faire tomber vite B4 et
avancer et que vachement de compensation
pour la qualité bon alors l'ordi nous
contredit donc bon évidemment il y a
probablement raison mais évidemment
donc nous on voulait faire mais
peut-être que justement c'est il faut
qu'on ressent
je suis sûr que tu joues ça quand même
non mais notre problème c'est qu'on
arrive pas à faire B4 quand on regarde
tout à l'heure donc en fait on s'ennuie
en nos pièces on se les tiens c'est un
gros pâté de pièces par là-bas
et il y a pas de temps
ça c'est trop de matériel
donc faut aussi un KB ça a été obligé ça
même pas s'il va faire déjà mais
admettons il paraît qu'il y ait des 7 et
mieux alors peut-être pour venir verser
c'est
et sûrement que le fond aussi en fait il
est important parce que tout à l'heure
quand on regardait aussi des fonceuse à
rentrer vous en B3 il est bien il y a
pas de tourner
bon moi je sais pas ça me va la position
enfin on va on va suivre on va voir ça
va être ça va être animé mais
après je comprends tu as le droit un peu
faible il te manque un pion devant etc
mais
ouais mais c'est chaud c'est chaud
j'aurais pas l'impression d'être si mal
je me dis quand même je dirais pas à
faire
je me dirais je suis probablement mal
mais je suis peut-être complètement
perdant je sais pas comment dire je vais
probablement ça va mais il y a peut-être
un monde où je me fais attaquer trop
vite
de toute façon c'est fait c'est fait
trop mal au temps mort pour l'instant il
est un peu d'avance à la pendule quasi
40 minutes
c'est pas le bon moment enfin tu peux
pas enlever ta tante B5 qu'est-ce que tu
en fais allez vas-y
et il y aura sûrement un moment où ce
serait important d'être précis ça c'est
clair parce que ah mais d'accord mais en
fait il peut juste jouer par homme
cavalier
toute façon si tu prends tu prends oui
mais il peut attendre quoi
[Musique]
bon écoute on va voir intéressant
ah d'ailleurs l'ordi propose un Meudon
c'est peut-être plutôt ça l'idée
tout à l'heure
bon j'avais l'impression que c'était un
peu mieux blanc mais bon peut-être ça
joue
la même avec le pion réussi je crois bon
ça c'était plus mais ça
je pense qu'il y a plutôt partir pour ça
Yann
ouais enfin ça tu es plus en contrôle
quand même j'ai envie de dire c'est
peut-être objectivement moins fort
toujours pas on fait des coups autour
est-ce qu'à un moment on est trop gêné
côté noir ou pas
tu peux avoir un jeu de dupe quoi
puis un jour tu décides de la bouffer
ou jamais on sait pas
c'est peut-être bien joué ça
ouais ouais
et donc
et on peut enlever ce jour faire 3 ou je
sais pas quoi et puis bon
sur le roi et en réalité dame deux ça a
l'air hyper fort
et peut-être qu'il vient de le jeu parce
que là il a pas sauté sur la tour il
réfléchit
donc peut-être faut prendre quand même
se débarrasser de ce problème
et mettre la dame en
en fait a priori ça c'est notre meilleur
chance avec noir on est juste moins bien
mais on n'est pas foutu et on a vu trop
de trucs où c'était trop pénible ce
qu'on vivait donc faut sûrement faire un
truc comme ça mais oui bien blanc
mais après tu vas récupérer à 4 tu seras
égalité matérielle bon
qui F5 tour des 8
c'est le mieux que tu as c'est un truc
comme ça
bon mais on va voir
j'ai pas d'espoir de la tenir quand même
je suis d'accord
ok on va voir
une question
belote et il disait si tu annonce 90 que
tu les fais que la défense fait 72 et
belote elle fait plus que toi mais moi
non enfin je veux dire je veux que
l'attaque fasse plus que la défense en
jeu effectif
donc là en fait tu as fait ton contrat
quoi c'est tout
les discussions de l'autre c'est il a
fait alors on a pas regardé mais en gros
c'est un peu comme dame de quatre dame
prend C4 peut-être en version un peu
moins
un peu moins bien
maso bah écoute il va bien je crois
qu'il est en vacances il est peut-être
encore en vacances d'ailleurs
on était ensemble à Reykjavik pour faire
pour faire l'Open on partageait une
chambre avec Mathieu on était tous les
trois
et il va bien enfin on va se revoir
bientôt
[Musique]
le 8 mai donc
voilà je le vois bientôt dans deux
semaines je crois
et quand il va bien peut-être un petit
C4 j'en sais rien
il est en vacances donc oui c'est ça
[Musique]
et en fait ça fait 4 et demi sur 6 quoi
bon vu l'opposition ça aurait été mieux
de faire 4 victoires de nul j'aurais
fait une perte un peu au dessus de moi
et l'eau là j'ai fait un peu en dessous
donc j'ai rien fait de grandiose sans
être kata quoi enfin bon voilà
on est d'accord que tu es invité pour
ces tournois
[Musique]
mais du coup je serai pas choqué quand
l'ordinateur me dise comme tu es invité
t'as pas le Robin
et j'aurais toujours enfin tu vois où je
serai pas enfin après ça c'est autre
chose mais là je veux dire il me disent
rien il me laisse faire
donc ils sont l'habitude depuis 2015 je
fais ce que je prenne des bails quoi
mais donc
cool enfin moi j'aime bien ça me fait
plaisir je pense que si on organise il y
a des gens qui viendraient et qui
j'aurais juste pas quoi
pas très peu je pense mais moi peut-être
à prendre des bail alors bye c'est pas
pas
by ciao non c'est bye bye quoi c'est tu
comment dire en fait tu ne joues pas
enfin tu préviens l'arbitre tu dis voilà
cette ronde-là je la jouerai pas et ils
te mettent un demi pont au classement
donc comme si tu as fait une nul en fait
donc tu bouges pas trop de ta place au
classement quoi et donc la plupart du
temps bah les gens prennent quand ils
sont fatigués ou ou s'ils peuvent pas
prendre des congés tous les jours et
qu'ils doivent travailler ou que je sais
pas ils en empêchement un truc enfin
voilà juste on t'empêche de prendre les
bailles pour les deux dernières rondes
parce qu'en fait imagine tu es en tête
du tournoi tu dis je ne joue plus et tu
gagnes le temps du coup comme ça en
avance quand même donc voilà tu peux que
faire jusqu'au dernier deux dernières
rondes
et en gros voilà donc je trouve le
principe bien mais en fait en soi
on va faire ça
mais pourquoi pas je suis pas choqué tu
fermes le X3 tu donnes la case des cinq
entrepartie bien sûr
et ce qu'il faut absolument de faire ces
cinq ou je crois
c'est peut-être une menace
et c'est 5 ouais je me questionnerais
pour ces 5
dessins qui machin
tu as même du contre-jeu avec les Noirs
tout d'un coup
non parce que si tu fais C4 avec les
Noirs tu passes
mais tu reprends aussi c'est mauvais à
cause de cavale F5
parce que moi j'aurais pu partir pour te
retrouver
sur la 6e pour bien mais maintenant tu
t'es déjà fait bouffer H6 j'ai envie de
dire ça a changé
pas quoi peut-être que super facilement
on se dit elle est toujours bien placée
et que là en fait cette fois là elle est
elle est pas si bien je sais pas
je sais pas pourquoi
mais peut-être ton cavalier aussi il a
tellement pas de rebond parce que B3
c'est un peu un coup d'épée dans l'eau
non en fait il y a beaucoup de trucs
bizarres parce qu'en fait et tout aussi
c'est qui c'est bien mais en fait la
peut-être que très particulièrement
[Musique]
et je suis pas sûr que tu puisses tout
comprendre par le calcul c'est faux
comprendre parce que tu
faut comprendre quoi
c'est pas on les ventes concrètes
parce qu'il est touché aussi par le fou
oui c'est ça et puis tu as tombé
un truc
peut-être tu suis un peu le nombre de
ventes on a vu le qui est bettera où ils
en apportent quoi il a trouvé bien joué
5 tempo bon ça c'était sûr et là c'est 5
ok bah bien dit bonne séquence la très
bonne séquence là
et ça va il se met pas un peu la salle à
la pendule aujourd'hui
il a 33 minutes ça va ce que je rêverais
de voir ça genre C4 non ça arrivera
jamais ça prise puis on prend et là
tu vois ils avancent
et ils avancent tu peux plus les arrêter
il a fait dameuse
oui bien placé
[Musique]
pour faire
maintenant
[Musique]
ça peut juste rentrer dans un truc comme
ça mais j'attendrai avec les Blancs
avant de le faire
précis comme ça mais ça peut rentrer
dans ce genre de position
ça sent bon là pour Ding face ça sent la
nul quoi bah ça sent meilleur que
vous prend aussi quoi je pense très
douteux de la part de dépôt même si pas
absorbe comme choix tu dis jamais mais
bon le dame de thé vous avez l'air
chiant
en réalité dame deux tu provoquer un peu
fou français 4 comme on l'a vu et tu
gagnais deux tempos voire même 3
par rapport à ce qu'on analysé
mais ouais c'était pas facile de
l'imaginer
en fait
pour se défendre pour passer la colonne
ouverte en même temps mais peut-être
c'est pas obligé tu aurais B8 là pour le
coup il y a peut-être d'autres options
mais il y a peut-être une dame C6 aussi
il est bon quand même ce digne longtemps
il a craqué dans les positions il était
bien deux fois d'affilée autant quand tu
as l'impression que ça y est il va
chavirer que ça va être terminé
parce que en H7 bon c'est quand même
plus grand chose donc pourquoi pas
franchement oui c'est parti
[Musique]
est-ce que tu peux te retrouver mieux
avec les noirs
j'ai quasi l'impression non
je sais pas parce que c'est vite un
statu quo tu dois toujours faire gaffe
qui a eu trois cahiers des 5 ça tombe
pas dans ma fin
de notre trêve c'est de filer une pièce
en B4 et d'avoir les puntos quoi un peu
comme hier la situation inverse
plus de 30 minutes
OK
bah ça fait plaisir que pour une fois ce
soit pas digne qui domine qui se casse
les dents et qui perd enfin si c'est
Yann qui domine et qui gagne pas
peut-être que tu
enfin tu as l'impression d'avoir un truc
qui tourne un peu en ta faveur ou je
sais pas quoi ouais ouais ça te fait un
peu du bien non
pas faut oui faut avoir un peu des
signes positifs ça serait bien
je pense que tu souffres quoi
tu souffles tout le temps évidemment tu
es tout le temps en train de souffler tu
es là
mais non mais dans le scénario là tu as
quand même pris deux coups sur la tête
aller avant le jour de repos dire bon ça
va j'ai quand même fermé les Noirs j'ai
encore les blancs j'ai eu des bonnes
positions
tu as un peu une soufflante non
mais ça te fait du bien d'avoir des
signes positifs
en tout cas moi je le prendrai comme ça
je verrai ça comme une soufflante
mais bon rien de faire on peut la perdre
cette partie côté noir côté blanc je
l'imagine moins perdre quand même mais
bon
donc ouais mais bon faire disons ça tend
vers la nul mais peut-être un petit peu
ce qu'on appelle une craquante
je sais pas
je veux pas être trop optimiste encore
pour les Noirs mais ça va mieux que
avant avant
et donc je vous cache pas que pour
l'intérêt du match ce serait mieux que
nous ne gagne pas
parce que deux points d'avance
on serait être un peu trop quoi
beaucoup trop
donc un point il est visuel quoi donc
bon tu es pas encore en chasse patate
tu es là quoi
logique tu défendsions A4 bon qui était
moyennement attaqué sur C3 mais en soi
pourquoi pas alors faudra pas oublier
qu'on ne touche pas la tour E8 cette
fois moi c'est le seul enfin j'en ai pas
parlé mais je voulais le dire le seul
bémol pour moi c'est que tu as pas de
dames B5 aussi
mais bon de notre côté fousser un
cavalier F6 enfin ça retombe dans
la normalité
tu vois je pense vraiment que ça peut
rentrer dans une position comme ça là on
en prend un gars tu reprends à 4 donc on
se trottes
ouais bon là là je serai plus inquiet en
fait non mais j'ai pas personne n'est
mieux là enfin tout le monde peut gagner
ou perdre encore mais c'est
je préférais les noirs
[Applaudissements]
si c'est ça le truc
ça peut partir vers une craquante côté
dépôt
en fait faut un statut
c'est un tu fais KFC
il fait roi H2O
puis là tu commences déjà à suivre en
fait tu suis complètement tu vas en E3
je te bouffe le 4 verset peut-être
l'idée de dame C6 d'abord
non ok alors
tu fais nul mais oui bon ça devrait
aller mais là bon ok là pour le coup je
suis même pas du tout inquiète pas
énorme en fait si c'est la suite en
échange on prend ces trois on prend à 5
ça va aller quoi mais ça va même très
bien aller non
est-ce qu'on serait pas heureux Fab ce
match qui reste quand même serré parce
que à deux points d'écart bon faut un
peu la gueule
on est de nouveau
je vais appeler la vidéo quoi qu'il se
passe le coup de grâce point
d'interrogation les gens vont penser que
ce n'est pas gagné tu spoiles dans le
titre
et rien je sais pas j'ai pas lu les
commentaires parce qu'en fait tu as fait
croire que Ding avait gagné
[Musique]
par contre j'ai un mec qui m'a mis un
beau commentaire j'étais très heureux il
était très mécontent sur la chaîne que
ce soit encore moi qui commente les
parties sur ma chaîne sur
quand même dommage c'est ça
qui mais je sais pas mais c'est un peu
le concept de la fin en même temps tu
vas sur blitzrim je dis ah c'est encore
c'est le coup dur quoi tu sais issue
quoi il merde
non mais tu vois peut-être en fait tous
les jours il ouvre la vidéo
encore lui ouais
je pensais qu'il allait virer
mais j'aurais peut-être
renommer ma chaîne Kevin Bordier chèque
parce que je me dis que c'est beaucoup
plus égocentrique de quoi c'est plus
égocentrique et donc je ça va mieux avec
mon image c'est plutôt que c'est plutôt
psy comme ça parce que la vitrine en
fait je l'ai vraiment pensé comme un
truc collectif tu vois de base quand
j'ai créé le nom c'était collectif pour
moi ça devait jamais être moi seul en
fait d'ailleurs c'est pas moi seul mais
je veux dire par là que ça a été pensé
comme ça de base mais tu as genre
renommer parce que c'est vrai que ça
enfin je comprends le gars il dit oui
bon enfin pourquoi c'est encore lui quoi
sur cette [__] de chaîne
j'aime bien en fait j'imagine vraiment
le gars devant son écran qui allume le
truc merde
c'est quand même
plus quoi
et ouais non moi j'ai pas de chaîne
Youtube
[Musique]
j'ai jamais compris pourquoi je devrais
faire parce que j'étais souvent là quoi
enfin du coup quelle valeur ajoutée
j'allais faire
on s'en fout en fait
les vidéos en fait on n'y pense pas on
passe on pense pas trop comme ça en fait
c'est une Bandit le roi et les
intermittents nouveaux noms
mais j'imagine vraiment le gars qui
ouvre tous les jours la chaîne qui ouvre
toutes les vidéos et à chaque fois qui
est déçu quoi
en tout cas en tout cas c'est bien
marrant
en fait moi ça me fait extrêmement
plaisir ce genre de commentaire ça te
fait marrer quoi ça me fait vraiment
rire ouais
parce que là c'est pas méchant qu'on
sait que quand il y a pas des insultes
ou quoi ça me fait rire ou des menaces
ou je ne sais quoi mais
quand c'est que des trucs comme ça ça me
fait rire ce que je vais vraiment les
points serrés quoi
j'ai jamais su
par contre une chaîne pour faire un
review des matchs de la SS là pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas
parce que il y aurait
la plus-value
l'Oeil du Coach
quand il y a eu l'analyse de Cornetto ça
là-bas c'est la Varane dont on parlait
de être très content ah ça y est enfin
ils ont compris ils ont viré ce conte
cette vidéo
moi il y a cette vidéo
la première
et
là moi j'étais avec Sofia du coup qui
venait de naître qui avait quelques
minutes et il y a le chef du service
pédiatrie de l'hôpital de Cannes qui
vient et qui oui quand j'ai ouvert la
vidéo ce matin donc en fait elle est
sortie à 10h Sophia est peut-être né à
10h aussi elle dit j'ai compris que
votre femme venait d'accoucher comme il
savait pas toi sur le j'ai vu Mathieu et
lui je suis tout de suite venu chercher
dans les couloirs tiens machin et
du coup il est venu me dire bonjour et
tout vu comment s'est passé
l'accouchement et tout c'était marrant
et du coup c'est beau quoi il a eu
réflex inverse et il n'y a que Mathieu
et il est venu
il est venu dans le
dans le service ça s'appelle
neona toi je pense
néonata là et donc il est venu et tout
et du coup il a vu Sofia
bon Satan ce qu'ils prennent ces trois
positions qu'on a vu avec
cette finale un peu en disant que limite
on préférerait les noirs
marginalement quoi probablement ça tend
vers nul mais
que le danger semble être évacué côté
ligne
en français 3 ils disent fou B2
j'aime bien les Noirs mais après
parce que ça arrive moi je suis toujours
enfin le problème c'est qu'on a un biais
cognitif c'est que c'était tellement mal
tout à l'heure moi ça m'arrive de faire
cette connerie j'ai vraiment été moins
bien
et que la position égalise enfin
je suis un peu comme Amazon
je suis presque gagnant non mais qui
avait 6 à 4 ou quoi ça va arriver enfin
je sais pas mais l'ordi du coup il prend
pas il fait tour à 8 ok oui
7 qui est ici
bon qui est pas important
bon ça c'est bien
[Musique]
pour ce 3
je sens vraiment nul quoi
[Musique]
en fait ça me ferait plaisir
ça existe encore
il a fait comment il a fait tourner il a
fait ce qu'on aurait fait
mais là comme vous dites on l'avait pas
mais ouais c'est ce qui va jouer c'est
plus fort effectivement
bah écoute c'est pas si non
[Musique]
tu vas apprendre tu prends 4 tu forces
les champs
ton C5 doublement
[Musique]
non mais ça c'est juste nul c'est juste
nul
c'est pas grand chose moi je suis
toujours chaud quoi
[Musique]
tu peux perdre mais enfin tu je pousse
quoi
on devine tous les coups Fab ouais là on
a on a mis le turbo alors attends je
vais faire une mini pause de 10 secondes
pour faire la petite pause pub
même un peu plus parce que je dois faire
les chaînes et tout et ben
on est obligé de le faire à tout de
suite parce que là ça va se quitter
après ça peut ça peut faire nul trop
vite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça on souffle femme
il dégage tout ça là on s'en fout quoi
quand même globalement c'est moins que
ce qu'on pourrait faire
bon on va peut-être vite refaire
parce qu'en fait là ce qui se passe rien
on peut faire notre pause pour nous bon
on va attendre le 40e coup mais si parce
que déjà ils ont droit à proposer nul à
partir du 40e donc ça pourrait aller
vite et puis si
ils veulent jouer
[Musique]
le foot aussi à fond le foot de la tour
de foot échec quoi peut-être tu peux
faire gagner sa santé avec avec
des pions
une dame
[Musique]
je sais pas si ils font le basket aussi
après le cavalier ben en fait il a pas
tellement de cases il a que des deux
parce qu'il a F6 mais il prend ça qui
est jolie
Jeff pig
e il reprend on se dit bon bah ça je
défends tout bah attends j'ai 4
on prend le canal donc
si son appât mais pas de cases
[Musique]
de perpète comme ça
il prend GSM G4
il y en aurorin il va même bouffer la
Touran G4
mais bon du coup on va faire plus que
perpète là on va dire merci Monsieur
donc
on est pas très sûr
mais non mais bon oui on doit tenir mais
je suis pas vraiment non
puis on prend mais ça bon on va quand
même
j'ai pas une donnée un peu si je peux
éviter en fait
c'est chiant bien sûr
mais bon
j'essaye j'imagine je sais pas
j'ai 7 ans
[Musique]
ça peut encore représenter un danger en
fait
oui
ouais ok s'il est mal à l'aise là-dedans
il faut aller sur cahier des cartes
parce que fou prendre puis on prend tour
bon je sais pas de quoi il prend mais ce
qu'il veut et faudra défendre ça qui bon
ça va aller mais ça va pas faire le
direct évidemment
et tu peux jouer longtemps
[Musique]
enfin moi je joue à très longtemps avec
le nom
mais après c'est complètement nul
mais oui enfin j'imagine t'estime pas
très haute chance de bien en tout cas
tes chances de perdre
en soi non c'est pas un challenge
immense de défense mais ça demandera un
peu et oui donc
il fait ça bravo mais
c'est largement plus dur que le torse
est de tout à l'heure que déjà tu penses
pas pour ça
au pire pour faire nul
parce que
il va se faire monter là mais bon
est-ce qu'on a autre chose que j'ai ici
bon ok
c'est le coup mais on va pas trouver
il a vraiment pas de bol hein
[Musique]
on s'en fout pas
tellement pas de bol ok ça va c'est pas
grave mais il y a des quatre
faut pas partir sur
le truc
même il a pas de réussite
là
j'imagine qu'il y a 5 parce que
[Musique]
on prend le 5 et on peut quand même la
perdre
je savais pas trop exactement mais bon
sans se faire attaquer c'est un moment
c'est pénible quoi je travaille pas
là-dedans non mais faut jouer l'autre va
te faire de choix pratique il est clair
mais bon tu es pas ravi hein tu dois
galérer un peu mais pas des masses va ça
va pas fait peur non non ça m'a réfléchi
bah t'imaginais pas de voir défendre
rien du tout quoi tu te dis bon ok on va
faire nul c'est bon tranquille
peut-être je vais passer machin et
finalement c'est pas du tout le scénario
et là du coup sans les tours c'est nul
facile ou pas
[Musique]
moi je préfère
dans le truc complètement égal enfin
égale c'est pas le mot mais complètement
nul quoi
il part pour jouer un truc
logique logique logique mille fois
logique l'eau c'était vraiment trop dur
ok oui
c'est en 38e
[Musique]
autant l'essayer
gros c'est nul théorique mais évidemment
c'est les noirs qui ont qui vont d'en
faire gaffe
bon là on peut vraiment faire la pause
donc il y a plus de problème de pendule
ou quoi et d'une façon s'ils font du le
rapidement c'est qu'il s'est rien passé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez hop je suis de retour
donc on a pas raté grand-chose on sait
qui te garantie me coups on en était là
tu en prends des quatre
Dinga attaquer le cavalier qui est
reparti et il a fait roi G7 donc il a un
petit peu son rapport à la finale la
tour est parti sur le côté et Kaly G3
alors en prise mais pas vraiment puisque
Scipion prend on se venge sur le
cavalier 3
et voilà donc bon a priori évidemment
dépôt ne va pas prendre et puis
on verra ce cavaler si contre leur
diriger vers H5 ou faire un échec en E2
pour pour roder dans le coin
bref donc voilà c'est pas passé grand
chose il va pas se passer grand chose
pendant un moment mais les pots du coup
qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire lui de son
côté on dit on n'a pas le son bah
pourquoi vous avez pas le son
bon bah si on dit que si bah c'est toi
qui a pas le son en fait
[Musique]
ouais
donc Nebo qu'est-ce qu'il veut faire lui
de son côté éventuellement c'est créer
un pion passé hein puisqu'il a besoin de
plus 3 contre 2 donc petit à petit
chasser ça monter le roi
H4 G4 et probablement H5 voilà donc
ce genre de truc petit à petit
après mais le pion passé
il sera pas trop durable ok a priori et
chaque pion qui s'échange se rapproche
les nord de la nul parce que pour ceux
qui qui le sauraient pas si on tourne
une finale avec tour cavalier contre
tour ça ferait nul donc disons les Noirs
ils pourraient vouloir faire disparaître
tout ce que je mets en rouge c'est à
dire échanger les pions de compte 2 et
limite le Kai contre le dernier pion si
jamais le besoin sans être ressentir et
garderai une position de nul donc voilà
c'est pour ça que on se dit
il y a de bonnes chances de nul
donc tourbé 7 jouets
ok il est repartir F5 propose l'échange
des cavaliers c'est pas bête c'est pas
bête du tout bon Netto je pense il doit
refuser les changes parce que si il
prend puis on prend alors certes on a
l'options doubler mais ils seront pas
faibles facile à défendre et c'est deux
options doubler il bloque très bien les
bloque deux là
et puis on h bon une fois que sera là il
a pas bien plus loin donc
bonne fin bon coup de la part de Ding
pour tester changer d'ailleurs bah n'est
pas il ajouterait G4 il veut pas avoir
un échange
donc voilà après ça peut durer donc
longtemps ce genre de truc ce scénario
ou ça tourne un peu en rond mais comme
comme vous êtes tout à l'heure je pense
que nepo
doit jouer longtemps il s'en fiche il a
pas de risque de perdre
donc on audit tout recettes
bon te recettes c'est le coup que
j'aurais pas mais qui doit aller parce
que bon les blancs pour le coup doivent
échanger je pense là-dessus c'est la
meilleure chance de gain et de cette
finale donc a priori nul mais bon
elle me plaît moins elle me plaît moins
alors bon il y a une règle générale qui
qui que générale qui est pas vrai c'est
pas une règle mais bon regardez en tête
on dit que pour juger une finale de
cavalier c'est souvent pareil qu'une
finale de roi
alors là ça serait justement un des
quatre filles aussi un bémol mais donc
de jouer une fin avec un pion de moi
avec les cavaliers on peut quand même
les perdre même si je dirais que j'ai de
bonnes chances de tenir avec les Noirs
si je vois ça mais bon
franchement je préfère ne pas faire tout
recettes garder ma tour par contre là je
sais que si ils changent des cavaliers
je fais nul à 100%
j'ai aucun je suis pas du tout et donc
ton stage devrait vraiment dernier
recours si jamais je suis qui vient
m'attaquer F7 je peux pas défendre ok
j'ai changé les tours mais je me le
garde vraiment en dernier recours c'est
pas c'est pas le truc que j'ai envie de
faire maintenant après si ça se trouve
digne au courant que ça fait nul facile
avec telle ou tel setup et il va le
faire mais non je le vois plus je vois
rien
j'en sais rien rien ça peut être échec
et je fais ça
ou tu auras un tour 2 quoi voilà enfin
voilà passer son tour je bouge pas
j'attends de voir et puis et j'aviserai
selon ce que fait l'adversaire
qui est des 6 trucs voilà bon il va
bouger sa tour on va revenir par exemple
ça c'est l'équivalent moins cher et très
bien
en tout cas c'est les gens qui viennent
non non on change de cavalier c'est cool
c'est nul facile
[Musique]
en finale de tour ah bah il a fait tout
recettes ok donc moi j'aurais pas fait
mais comme je vous dis il doit savoir
que le setup va et pas de souci mais
j'ai l'impression que c'est un des cas
de figure où ça aurait pu déraper
et je leur ai attendu plus tard non mais
lui il est au courant en fait donc mieux
que moi mais
j'aurais prolon fait un truc comme échec
et taureau de ou je sais pas quoi genre
attendu par là
donc là bonne épo bon je sais pas à sa
place je prends
parce qu'en fait s'il part de toute
façon t'accompliras à rien donc il va
prendre on va prendre et qu'est-ce que
je ferai avec mes pots je commencerai à
essayer de monter mon roi je sais pas ça
par exemple donc Ding peut-être il va
faire un truc comme ça on va bouger le
cavalier
j'en sais rien ou quelque part ça on se
barre bon il va attendre on va dire ça
je vais monter mon bras il va attendre
ouais bon le truc qui veut nous dire
Ding et je vais pas bouger les pièces
random plus longtemps ça va être avec
ces deux pions
il veut bloquer dès qu'il y a un pion
qui arrive BIM ça dégage ils ont encore
reprenne ou ça peut être comme ça c'est
pareil et après quand tu as un option
passé BIM il dégagera donc on a un pion
contre 0 et il veut donner le cavalier
contre le dernier pion donc c'est ça son
truc donc c'est peut-être vraiment très
simple comme ça en fait c'est vrai
qu'avec cette configuration là
j'avais plus peur on va dire si l'option
reste un F7 et que les Blancs arrivaient
à accomplir
un truc comme ça
j'ai vu qu'il a joué un derrière il a
pas échangé la tour mais ok ce genre de
truc ça j'aurais été moins confiant même
si ça doit se défendre mais je me dis
ouais bon lui il va monter ça a chasser
le roi il va cumuler les menaces et bon
parce qu'il y a encore un peu envie mais
sans ces deux pions et c'est ça en fait
l'idée de défense sans ces deux pions
que d'ailleurs il y a un moyen de
dévider c'est de faire ça à ce priori ça
c'est imprenable
bref donc automatique dans la partie
surtout recette il a fait tomber 5 donc
il a refusé l'échange des tours mais là
on m'a dit il va rien faire j'imagine un
coup de tour sur le côté et voilà et on
va voir donc on est pot va quand même
tenter petit à petit de contraction
passé avec G4 H4 H5 il va amener ça en
jeu avec le temps
et voilà
c'est juste avantage bah les deux
il se trouve ça avantage blanc parce que
tu as un pion de plus mais
c'est censé faire
[Musique]
pourquoi il propose pas nul bah qui en
fait les blancs ce que je t'explique en
fait Ding il saute sur nul s'il peut
faire il a rien d'autre espérer que nul
et nepo il a quand même un espoir il a
besoin de plus pourquoi tu donnes nul
ton adversaire j'ai raconté à zéro
chance de perdre et même une chance sur
un million de gagner bah tu la prends ta
chance tu la joues et puis OK tu sais
qu'il y a probablement nul mais tu
restes à l'affût c'est une erreur un
moment machin et voilà donc t'as pas tu
as pas à faire nul enfin faut pas en
fait
je veux dire même une finale
tour cavalier contre Tours ok c'est nul
théorique mais tu la joues quand même 50
coups tu espères faire un réseau de
maths et que le mec se plante
[Musique]
ce qu'on peut avoir la partie depuis le
début si tu veux vu que là il y a pas
grand chose à voir avec nepo n'est pas
la table Nini d'ailleurs
[Musique]
et demain
c'est pas repos demain
si je crois que c'est repos demain ça
sera dimanche la prochaine mais oui du
coup reste à portée de tir il y a qu'un
point de retard il peut revenir alors la
partie c'était une Espagnole et cette
fois-ci dit il n'a pas joué à 6 son
cohabituel mais à proposer une
berlinoise donc refusé par des pots avec
des trois qui défend le pion plutôt que
faire petit rock et laisser les Noirs
prendre ce pion
des trois fousser 5 très bien donc c'est
5 c'est une manière de défendre ce pion
bon tout le monde sait mais suce pour
vous dire parce que ça en fait c'est une
menace latente quand même dans
l'espagnol côté blanc de dire bah voilà
je gagne un pion mais bon là il y a dame
là attaque le cavale Mona Smart pardon
ici donc bon bien sûr il peut pas donc
des trois voilà fousser 5 défend E5 tout
en développant le fou
sur quoi nettoie Festi 3 du coup ils
vont faire attention ça devient ça
devient un truc petit rock petit rock
donc cette fois-ci si on prend
c'est plus pour faire ça enfin ok si ça
se trouve ce genre mais je crois pas
parce que là les blancs gagnent un pion
mais c'est pour prendre de B donc ça
perd un pion mais après bon là c'est
concret est-ce qu'il y a des cinq
directs qui part dans la tronche pour
ouvrir le centre dire qu'il y a la paire
de fou etc prendre celui-là ça va
commencer à être un peu tout match parce
que le cavalier se retrouve un peu au
bois il y a du dames 8 oncloud on
l'attaque on va prendre celui-là donc
bon il y a tout ça qui est en train de
compte toujours est-il les Blancs n'ont
pas fait ils ont ok donc ils laissent la
menace l'attente et il y a eu des cinq
de Ding donc réaction centrale c'est oui
c'est pas obligé de jouer comme ça à
côté noir mais c'est devenu un truc un
peu un peu moderne il y a eu qu'il y ait
des deux et cette structure de pions
voilà alors après ça a joué digne
connaissait assez loin ça manœuvre etc
il replace leur pièce c'est une
structure symétrique où les blancs du
coup un petit peu d'avance avec ceux qui
avaient là par rapport à celui-là donc
on se dit tiens peut-être venir par ici
plus vite quoi
donc c'est plus ou moins un peu ce qui
se passe bon on est là on fait B5
ouverture du jeu gel dames dame 2
attaque le pion mais sans vraiment
l'attaquer mais bon ça on y reviendra
dans le grand résumé vite défend
cavalier H4 il fait de la place pour la
dame il veut amener les cavaliers par
ici ou là parce qu'il clouage donc il se
ramène vers le roi et là il y a une
phase un peu un peu tendue un peu charpe
fou prend H6 si il prend on reprend
celui-là donc là d'un coup les pièces
blanches à faire le roi ton premier
devant il a joué plus tard BIM
maintenant et voilà donc là je passe un
peu vite comme je dis je fais pas
vraiment résumé mon explique mais là les
blancs on avait l'impression que c'était
bien c'était mieux pour pour dépôt qui
pouvait gagner une qualité mais là
évidemment tu vois ça donne un cadre un
troupeau de pions et on se dit ouais ça
peut être avancé l'ordi avait l'air bien
mis pour les blancs donc on prend que ça
peut rentrer dedans et tête d'un meueux
pour défendre et reprendre toujours
est-il lui il a pris direct et la bonne
série de coup de Ding qui a fait C5
coupé le foot du jeu et qui reprend le
contrôle de certaines cases
et ça c'est assez vite simplifié à ce
moment là en fait il y a eu des échanges
massifs de dames de pions de trucs comme
ça ou tout dégagent voilà et là en fait
donc vite vers nul mais là mauvaise
surprise entre guillemets pour pour Ding
le cavale est attaqué on se dit oui bon
bah je rentre chez moi c'est pas grave
ouais mais là il y a ce coup tactique
qui fait mal puisque sur cavalier prend
on aura une finale avec un pion de moins
mais pourri quoi et si on prend du roi
bah il y a toujours G4 et c'est la même
sanction le cavalier clones ne peut pas
prendre la tour le roi doit bouger et on
s'est bouffer donc on peut pas retourner
en F6 l'autre cas ça a été de venir là
mais là faut compter sur torche G4 va
nous attaquer G7 c'est on suit il y
avait une défense d'ordi mais bon ok
introuvable et il a pas opté du coup
pour cette position compliquée si bon
ben je fais ça je me fais bouffer un
pion c'est le cas
mais j'ai une finale où tous les pions
sur la même donc il y a trois pions
blancs ici depuis on a ici il y a un
matériel limité et je dois pouvoir tenir
voilà et c'est le cas enfin il a pas il
a pris une bonne décision en fait et
donc voilà on était là et on en est là
ok donc j'imagine que Ding va nous
partir de refaire un tour au sein vu
qu'il a déjà fait tout à l'heure
et voilà
comment l'interprète la partie
aujourd'hui suite d'hier bon
j'interprète pas grand-chose le truc
c'est que dans les parties entre les
deux pseudos sur internet il y avait eu
des meringues donc c'était clair c'était
une option possible pour Ding mais je
veux dire après c'est parce que tu vois
que le mec a joué de berlinoise que tu
vas lui le réfuter parce que la
berlinoise ça serait fait pas comme ça
enfin c'est une bonne ouverture
juste tu enlèves l'effet de surprise
et donc qu'est-ce qu'on a eu comme info
dans les parties des lits donc il y a eu
beaucoup de H3 mais c'est déjà dévoilé
de la joue une fois de leur jouera plus
il y avait une fois le tour à deux là
bon ok
mais un truc non joué il y a eu quelques
attaques indiennes donc c'est les rétine
en fait j'appelle ta question
contre un joueur dans le répertoire le
grand bidame et la Nimzo il y a des
chances aussi ce dessin qui est aussi et
donc sans l'a pas vu et je sais pas si
on le verra c'était probablement une
idée qu'ils ont eu employer mais là c'en
est fait de surprise
si ça révise bien en face à voir même si
de toute façon sur des positions qui
jouent compliquées tu te fais passer
chez comme ça mais voilà et
ils ont fait aussi une fois une London
Joe Bava donc c'est genre D4 kf6 qui est
C3 ou des quatre lf6 ou F4 et KFC 3
après
bon ça du coup je dirais c'est très
improbable que qu'il le parce que ça
vaut surtout pour son effet de surprise
c'est pas une ouverture qui a une grande
réputation c'est allez on va dire
jouable c'est pas réfuter réfuté mais
c'est pas ouf bon si en plus tu as zéro
fait de surprises et que le mec a révisé
le matin même
ouais bon j'y crois pas trop donc voilà
ça m'est déjà arrivé
pas du tout à me concentrer
non normalement je suis pas mauvais en
concentration ça va je j'ai pas de
problème de ce point de vue là après bon
problème de motivation ça je peux avoir
bien sûr
problème de tu es mal dormi que t'es
fait d'autres trucs voilà bon ça c'est
mes de me concentrer non je ça va
est-ce que je joue encore beaucoup non
je joue plus beaucoup je joue beaucoup
moins que quand j'étais actif et voilà
je dois jouer
c'est rien entre moins de 50 parties
longues par an je dirais maintenant
cette année j'ai fait quoi
[Musique]
je par équipe en Top 16 j'ai joué un
petit peu un week-end de Ligue espagnole
vite fait un peu en ligament mais pas
tous les week-ends
[Musique]
et voilà je suis pas sûr que je vais
rejouer de l'année après
ou peut-être que oui mais bon enfin peu
importe
ce que j'ai toujours ma vie que j'ai
déjà bah oui c'est mon métier mais je
gagne pas ma vie avec les tournois bah
j'en joue quasiment plus des fous mais
je fais pas mal le truc là on a sorti le
livre avec Kevin donc déjà tu vois le
livre j'espère gagner un peu dessus
non mais je fais des vidéos
je fais des vidéos donc bon bah déjà des
fois j'apparais sur la chaîne ici je
fais des commentaires voilà comme là il
y a la chaîne Youtube avec Kev il y a
voilà tout ce qui est commentaire sur
Internet etc il y a aussi des fois j'ai
tourné des répertoires de vidéos par
exemple avec Jess base ou quoi donc là
je fais des stages donc sur des
week-ends
voilà et des articles que j'ai écrit
etc donc je fais pas mal de trucs qui
gravitent autour des échecs
mais je serai que joueur je gagnerai
très mal enfin en fait après ça serait
pas invivable parce que j'ai vécu dans
cette vie c'est que tu gagnes peu mais
tu es invité en temps donc j'aurais fait
des tournois à droite à gauche c'est pas
une vie qui coûte cher c'est une vie où
tu es beaucoup en mouvement
voilà donc ça c'est ça c'est autre chose
mais en fait j'ai eu le changement avec
le covid en gros déjà peut-être avant ça
me trottait ou je sais pas dans la tête
mais le covid je me suis rendu compte
que bon matin le truc c'est qu'on
pouvait pas jouer on était tous confinés
mais les échecs en plus c'est mis
longtemps à redémarré parce que c'était
un des trucs les pires c'était dans une
salle fermée donc tu es pas l'air libre
tu te joues face à face et coller tu es
dans le même air tu te touches les mêmes
pièces tu vois enfin il y a beaucoup de
trucs contre-indiqués quoi et donc
pendant un an et Cam j'ai juste pas
jouer une seule partie mais ça m'a pas
rendu malheureux
du coup je me suis dit bah ok voilà je
passe autre chose je fais plus coach
maintenant je donne des cours jeune des
cours donc les stages et je partage
voilà sur Internet aussi en gros
faut combien de vélo pour pouvoir vivre
des tournois bah je te dirai qu'il faut
être faut être très bon ou pas très bon
et je voulais les tournois moins de 2002
ou truc comme ça où tu as des prix pour
les amateurs
il y en a qui se sont spécialisés
là-dedans à jamais dépasser c'est-à-dire
qu'ils valent beaucoup plus ils font
exprès mal joué ils se sent bagues pour
regarder pourri quoi et voilà mais
bon mais ça c'est pas des grands enfin
ouais bon je sais pas quand je joue je
fais de mon mieux je vais pas exprès de
perdre les points je les perds parce que
je joue mal mais pas parce que j'ai
envie de les perdre
mais donc voilà après ouais si tu veux
être juste joueur professionnel je pense
faut viser
après c'est toujours compliqué tu vois
selon le pays où tu es ou quoi
parce que c'est dans un pays où ça joue
pas trop échecs tu évites une star des
champions nationale tu vas jouer
peut-être les coupes du monde tu vas
être invité tu vas faire les Olympiques
à chaque fois et donc tu peux mieux
vivre dans un pays qui s'y intéresse un
peu mais qui est pas trop fort que
c'était une concurrence de ouf genre je
veux dire tu es 2006 en Russie bon tu es
un peu tu as un No Name quoi
bon de 2600 francs c'était pas mal
en Espagne ou en Italie ou voilà donc
ça aussi ça joue quelque part
et le livre qui est le livre là c'est un
livre livret mais de tactique
d'exercices de 80 pages donc
il est des gens précommandes il sortira
le 25 mai 25 mai donc je
pense on a fait ce qu'on a pu vivre
qu'il soit sympa j'espère qu'il vous
plaira et voilà ce que j'ai déjà touché
2006 non non moi j'étais max
j'ai pas 25 40 3 je dirais je crois que
j'étais publié ça c'était mon plus haut
ça aurait pu être un peu mieux mais peu
importe après tu vois je savais pas
changé grand-chose
il me dit 25-47 max mais peut-être tu
vois je me souviens plus mais
j'étais à peu près dans la zone
qui ne joue pas en tout cas il y a un
tissu quel âge j'avais commencé les
échecs moi j'ai commencé très petit
c'est mon père qui m'a appris donc son
père il fait un jour de club tu vois
amateur mais il m'a appris quand
j'allais te dire trois ans mais en fait
peut-être dès le jour où je suis né quoi
juste je savais pas enfin mais j'ai joué
toute ma vie
ce que j'aurais pu atteindre de musique
au niveau est vraiment dessus
bah j'aime pas répondre à Jean de
question parce que
juge je l'ai pas fait je l'ai pas fait
j'ai pas l'impression que c'était
inaccessible mais
voilà c'est facile de dire j'aurais pu
faire si j'aurais pu faire ça
[Musique]
je vous ferai une vidéo sur ma ou mes
meilleurs parties bah je pense j'en ai
fait avec avec Kev parce que bon comme
je participe sur la chaîne de blitstream
depuis
je sais pas 2016 j'ai l'impression
2015-2016 et donc j'ai fait
quelques-unes de mes parties dessus
[Musique]
donc tu pourras trouver je sais pas
après faut bien chercher mais tu dois
trouver
faible l'ordi dit à peu près 0,1 pour un
épaule après le coup qui est D6 dans
cette position est-ce que c'est nulle
là c'est pas nul théorique je veux dire
je pense pas que la position était
publiée analyser spécifiquement avec les
pièces agencées comme ça mais en fait on
peut se projeter imaginer le scénario
qui va arriver que les blancs vont se
créer un pion passer etc ça va changer
ça sera passé de matériel pour gagner
mais c'est pas ce qu'on appelle une
ultérieure mais bon c'est nul quand même
c'est quoi donc les grands principes de
technique d'attaque et les blancs vont
se faire passer donc tu vois tu veux
faire ça avec les Blancs et puis un peu
occuper les pièces par là peut-être
faire des masses sur F7 euh
et tu n'y arriveras pas à priori sur une
bonne défense mais voilà les blondes
doivent essayer ça et les Noirs bah du
coup eux les Noirs plus d'échanges de
pions plus c'est facile de toute façon
ça c'est un thème de défense c'est pas
que pour te final là mais toujours le
camp qui défend il veut essayer de
liquider le plus de pions possible pour
le principe pour être il est simple à
comprendre c'est que si au bout du
compte disons tu te retrouves avec roi
et cavaliers qu'on trouvera tout seul
d'abord un cavalier de plus il n'y aura
pas
donc moyen de pion plus tu as une chance
de sacrifier tes pièces pour laisser
l'autre avec pas assez de matériel pour
te battre donc voilà
parce que ça existe des tables de sang
qui ont conseillé des chèques tars genre
après 10 ans je pense que oui mais rare
enfin très rare d'ailleurs
mais peut-être si tu apprends à 10-11
ans que tu apprends bien que que tu as
un talent pour ça que tu consacrer
énormément de temps et que tout ça
peut-être tu vas progresser vite et
rattraper mais
bon en général les joueurs apprennent
jeune quoi
en général quelle est la meilleure façon
de plus sa réflexion pendant que
l'adversaire réfléchit bah tu as deux
manières de faire enfin en général de
toute façon tu réfléchis à ce que tu
penses qu'il va faire et tu continues à
réfléchir
avec la même intensité que c'était à toi
de jouer après une fois que tu es à peu
près sûr et que pour toi l'autre il
plombe et que tu te dis bon bah ça va
j'ai mes conclusions je sais ce que je
vais jouer machin voilà tu penses pas à
grand chose quoi tu peux te balader
souffler allez au restaurant boire de
l'eau boire du café parce que tu veux
passer aux toilettes tu dis voilà c'est
des choses que je préfère faire pendant
que le temps d'adversaire cool plutôt
que que le mien
donc tu es pas non plus en intensif en
haute intensité de réflexion tout le
temps tout le temps tout le temps mais
c'est parce que c'est à l'autre de
réfléchir tu dois penser à autre chose
enfin tu restes quand même focus sur ta
partie des fois avant de baladant en
étant petit pense quand même mais sans
les intensément tu peux avoir des idées
tu peux d'un coup penser à des patterns
des trucs ah [__] peut-être j'ai stylé
c'est de le faire marcher donc tu peux
être plus en mode créatif que en
réflexion de vendre pure pure quoi j'ai
envie de dire
alors il a fait qu'il y ait des six il
attaque la tour OK
bon je sais pas il va il va le tour des
7 jours je sais pas il y a rien qui
change de spécial on va pas bouger les
pièces à chaque fois et analyser on sait
enfin voilà je vous ai dit mon ressenti
bon l'ordi confirme moi je vais rester
clair sur la position mais ça peut durer
longtemps donc on va voir on va voir on
va voir
[Musique]
mais tu es pas obligé de te lever à
chaque coup quand tu as joué enfin tu
peux aussi rester assis et tu sais très
bien que c'est déjà du coup
est-ce que je pense genre comme Paul
Murphy Ernest bien aurait pu réaliser
quand déjà comme Ding et ou dépôt ben
écoute Murphy il était vraiment fort
enfin c'était juste un génie du jeu donc
[Musique]
pourquoi pas le truc c'est que
évidemment tu mets morfi avec son niveau
de connaissances à l'époque il rivalise
rien du tout puisque il serait plombé
mais tu prends morfi tu laisses du temps
je sais pas quoi te dire peut-être mais
à voir quoi
et
falbire alors je connais pas bien mais
oui
j'ai peur qu'il soit pas au niveau mais
j'en sais rien tu vois
qu'est-ce qui est le plus dur d'un point
de vue stress je veux une partie longue
ou regarder un match de la grosse
question
plutôt je veux une partie Nantes pour
moi même si l'image de synthé je suis à
fond mais tu vois je peux gueuler devant
l'écran je peux trouver des moyens de me
défouler quoi d'évacuer
je twitch je suis là la partie tu vis
vraiment le truc solo dans ta tête et
voilà
bientôt
de loin
ce que je tiendrai mentalement 14 jours
de championnat comme ça
je sais pas oui enfin
[Musique]
je me suis dit oui et non quoi enfin
mais je serais pas dans l'incapacité de
jouer après je sais pas si j'aurais bien
peut-être que je me ferais dessus que je
serai mais en soit je veux dire jouer 14
parties en trois semaines ça me paraît
pas un surmontable en termes de de de
physique et compagnie quoi j'ai déjà
enchaîné des tournois donc je peux après
tu vois de jouer un truc si important tu
sais que tu joues pour l'histoire que
machin
bon je sais pas comment je leur ai vécu
dans ma vie j'ai pas été très bon dans
les parties en jeu quoi alors des fois
je suis arrivé mais en général surtout
jeune j'étais très très nul
je jouais quoi
et j'aurais laissé composer l'équipe
en outsider de pression est moins tu as
rien à perdre
ouais mais alors bon déjà tu dois les
mecs je suis pas sûr qu'ils se
considèrent tellement comme ça tu as
besoin d'avoir confiance de te dire que
tu vas gagner enfin tu es pas là pour
rien faire et puis tu as pas envie de te
faire défoncer de passer pour un con non
plus quoi donc
[Musique]
ouais
je sais pas non mais c'est pas évident
de vivre un match c'est autre chose
c'est un vrai combat en fait c'est autre
chose
elles sont connaît le les nouveaux
seconds mvl
je crois pas je crois pas qu'on
connaisse
l'arnaque de dépôtante
[Musique]
voilà il passe plus ou moins son tour et
puis il attend donc que Nico tenez
Peugeot fasse des trucs potentiellement
elle croit F8 on se décrloupion donc on
peut se donner dans le Range des coups
comme F5 chasse le cavalier pour prendre
F2
donc voilà ça c'est un truc à prendre en
compte pour les blancs qui a priori vont
donc défendre ce pion en faisant
peut-être 3 G3 ou un truc comme ça quoi
les pommes de terre selon toi je pense
je pense qu'il aime bien les pommes de
terre
[Musique]
et F3 oui F3 tu peux tu peux faire
j'imagine ça peut pas être trop mauvais
après juste si je peux éviter mais bon
là ça va je crois je peux le faire sans
souci mais j'ai pas envie de voir un cas
de figure lui saute ici et je me fais
taper G2 et compagnie mais bon une case
comme ça pour un calissez loin ces
quatre coups j'aurai le temps
d'intervenir des tickets de coup quoi
pourquoi les raisins jouent plus alors
il va rejouer pas mal il est inscrit au
grand chesto il y a pas mal de trucs
mais je sais pas pourquoi il a pas joué
plus c'était une surprise pour moi
[Musique]
l'avenir nous dira c'était une bonne
mauvaise décision imagine je joue super
bien qu'il a travaillé ou quoi mais sur
le principe
on n'a jamais trouvé ça quoi donc j'ai
pas l'impression que ce soit une grande
décision mais tu vois on pourra juger on
pourra juger en fonction de ses
résultats ce que ça donne et on pourra
dire ah bah ça lui donner du repos il a
pu bosser peut-être corriger certains
défauts
etc etc quoi
donc avoir
pizzaïolo parce que toujours dans un
coin de ma tête
oui mais concrètement j'ai pas trop
avancé
non mais en gros je me vois pas
forcément le faire de manière
professionnelle enfin peut-être pas du
tout quoi tu vois je veux pas te dire
ouais j'ouvre une pizzeria ou un camion
machin mais les faire pour savoir les
faire bien faire la pâte savoir elle est
temps de cuisson mâche ça m'intéresse
juste le savoir-faire et de m'en faire
pour pour le petit perso
et puis après qui sait je veux dire tu
vois peut-être ça ça me ferait plaisir
d'avoir un resto de partager d'aller
parier et de faire des trucs donc
voilà mais j'ai pas vraiment avancé j'ai
toujours pas faire j'ai en Islande il y
a un resto sympa ou
en fait il était pas mal de français en
fait il y a il y a des gars qui sont
venus qui viennent
qui sont que j'ai rencontré dans les
stages qu'on organise et qu'il y en a
trois qui ont du jeu leur premier
tournoi il y en a un qui qui jouait déjà
un peu et donc bon bah c'est du temps
avec eux et ils allaient souvent manger
dans un Italien et
donc dans le resto ils ont été hyper
sympa tu vois parce que ils m'ont laissé
faire une pizza quoi donc je suis passé
en cuisine
il y avait la pâte l'étaler la garnir
sauf que ça s'est pas bien fini après
c'est chaud quand tu vois de pour la
mettre sur la spatule pour une fois un
coup de main ou quoi et elle c'est un
peu un peu troué quoi et après au four
elle a mal cuit elle s'est collée au
fond du four elle a fait de la merde et
il a fini au feu à mangeable quoi donc
je sais pas ce que ça a donné c'est déjà
la pizza ou pas elle a juste été pas
consommé j'ai rien pu servir
donc voilà pour la première expérience
déjà savoir attraper la pizza avec la
spatule c'est chaud
du coup j'ai réfléchi à comment je ferai
en tant que débutant c'est qu'en fait je
ferai déjà sur la spatule tu vois je la
mets hop elle est sur la spatule je la
garnis sur la spatule hop j'enfourne
voilà prochaine fois j'essaierai ça mais
en gros oui normalement enfin tu sais
faire quoi enfin mais juste c'est juste
pas simple en fait je veux dire
voilà donc première expérience j'ai été
nul j'avais fait ça avec amour et tout
ce que j'ai pu pourtant mais bon ok
[Musique]
mais je retenterai toute façon il faut
il faut échouer pour pour apprendre mais
du coup là j'ai appris un truc et
voilà comme disait Wawrinka un fail
again fake bêta et jusqu'à savoir faire
quoi
il faut blinder de faire une ça va non
mais je comprends qu'il y a des mais bon
vrai personne m'aiguiller quoi enfin je
faisais ce que je pouvais quoi j'étais
là je découvrais par moi-même c'est
comme quand je suis allé faire du ski
personne n'explique comment ça marchait
bon je fais que de la merde je fais que
tomber quoi j'essaie de tourner les
pieds je faisais n'importe quoi bah j'ai
passé ma journée à me casser la gueule
quoi bon c'est plus simple quand on dit
faut incliner les mais bon ok tu fais
tout seul tu tombes tu tombes après tu
as dit ah tiens ça marche un peu mieux
merde je retombe bon voilà quoi donc là
j'ai fait la pizza quand même technique
quoi j'ai fait j'ai mal fait mais je
comprends ce que j'ai mal fait quoi
et voilà non je m'étais pas fait
ligaments mais ouais [__] j'ai passé
j'en ai par terre quoi je dis mais c'est
vraiment nul le ski quoi qui prend
plaisir à ça
alors je suis pour qui dans le match je
suis pour qui
en fait je suis pour personne que le
meilleur gagne
[Musique]
j'aime bien
juste que je disais c'est que pour moi
avant le match ni peau favori parce que
Ding voilà je trouve qu'ils jouent moins
bien que avant le covid
voilà il se passe beaucoup moins bien
mais un peu et une épaule et d'une
trajectoire inverse il a été très solide
de gagner deux fois les candidats et la
jeune expérience en match donc voilà ça
c'est juste le côté objectif après moi
je les connais pas personnellement quoi
donc tu vois je peux pas te dire j'ai
pas d'anecdote avec eux
donc j'ai pas de raison d'avoir plus de
sympathie ou quoi enfin voilà
après là je suis plutôt content du match
qu'on vit il y a pas mal de victoires
c'est animé c'est vivant et sa faillite
tu vois c'est pas des petites nulles où
il se passe rien c'est pas que l'autre
donc c'est
un match agréable à suivre à commenter
niveau de jeu est pas toujours parfait
mais pas si mal et puis voilà quoi il y
a de l'intensité
donc voilà c'est pour ça que là
aujourd'hui moi j'ai pas envie que ni
peau gagne cette finale mais pas voilà
j'ai un compte lui mais pour l'interview
du match quoi
sera pas plus intéressant de faire un
championnat du monde en mode tournant
plutôt que ouais alors
je sais pas c'est plus intéressant pas
ça pourrait ça pourrait après j'aime
bien le format match parce que les
échecs à bout du compte c'est un
affrontement incontrint et
traditionnellement c'est ça après il y a
déjà eu de ton aide championnat du monde
donc là je crois donc il vient voilà il
monte le roi il active le rapport la
finale et il défend il défend les pions
il passe devant mais bon ça change rien
l'évaluation qu'est-ce que je racontais
oui donc un tournoi des championnats du
monde
48 je dirais
avec
qui neymar et ils ont dû faire un
tournoi pour qu'il y a un champion du
monde donc
[Musique]
voilà c'était un peu la seule fois alors
après je sais qu'il y a eu le tournoi de
Saint Louis et de concert ça comme un
championnat du monde bon moi non en fait
mais
mais pourquoi pas ça pour arriver enfin
mais j'aime bien le format match j'aime
bien alors après faut Cayenne nombre de
parties ça j'en sais rien tu vois ça à
voir les cadences
ça ça peut être sujet à débat
j'aime bien peut-être quand même les
Califs sont en format match format coupe
ça me plaît plus quoi voilà
on me dit d'analyser pour ceux qui
arrivent bah en fait ouais bon c'est une
finale qui doit se terminer par nul
parce que les pions risque de s'échanger
les blancs ce qu'ils espèrent faire
c'est ce que je disais c'est écrit un
pion passé ils ont plus donc faire un
plan comme ça avec ces deux pions qui
passera en G4 H5 et avoir un pion passé
c'est d'avancer et accumuler les masses
un peu sur F7 un peu avec le pion h bon
c'est un doux rêve parce que
on n'arrive pas vraiment à voir de cas
concret où ça où ça existe mais en tout
cas il faut l'essayer au cas où les
Noirs se trompent et défendrai mal tout
d'un coup friend gaffe
par ça il y a pas vraiment d'idées
demain ouais ouais demain se repos tous
les deux jours là ils reprennent le
rythme de partie un repos deux parties
un repos
donc moi j'ai 3 à Digne bon après comme
je vous dis tous les coups donc
j'imagine que tu ressens doit être un
coup jouable comme il a déjà fait avant
il peut jouer un coup de tour latérale
attendre il peut je sais pas il peut
sûrement faire les chèques repartir
[Musique]
bon enfin en gros tous les coups il met
pas un truc en prise bon quoi
c'est plus intéressant qu'en 2021 bah
ouais
en demain matin c'était intéressant
pendant 5 secondes pas le temps où il y
avait des nuls au début ou même une
époque jouait pas mal enfin
[Musique]
Magnus puis la partie très longue
dans la dans la catalane qui a duré je
sais plus combien de coups mais autant
de 150 très longue ou même niveau était
bien un moment et ok il finit par perdre
ils n'arrivent pas à défendre et il est
minoscore
il était méconnaissable après quoi enfin
il jouait vraiment pas bien quoi et donc
à partir il y a plus aucun intérêt donc
le match a eu un intérêt pendant
pendant un tiers du temps peut-être mais
après plus du tout
mais en plus là il y a beaucoup plus de
parties gagnées donc
[Musique]
je veux dire on sait pas trop ce qu'on
va vivre
chaque fois tu dis tiens ça va être
qu'aujourd'hui
il envoie F5 ok
j'aime pas je sais pas quoi dire mais
j'aime pas voilà peut-être c'est un bon
coup mais en fait j'ai l'impression que
c'est mon avis Ding il arrive pas à rien
faire alors que là il pouvait vraiment
rien faire comme je dis tu bouges ta
tour à droite à gauche c'est fini enfin
c'est fini tu attends que les Blancs
avancent et voilà là tu fais 5 c'est
quoi le truc tu te crées un pion faible
c'est pas je peux aller chercher
peut-être un truc cavalier tu te coupes
le roi sans la 8e et Edding en fait je
crois que ça c'est un problème nerveux
qui veut faire nul vite il veut pas que
ça dure et ok après faut voir alors
après peut-être concrètement ça a marché
parce qu'il y a du qui avait Lucas et à
prendre ça j'ai pas calculé mais j'aime
pas du tout la gueule du coup quoi
après si ça se trouve ça fait nul en
force parce que je vais bouffer F2 et
Machin mais visuellement ça
[Musique]
mais je sais pas le signal que s'envoie
c'est que je peux pas rester dans une
position à juste attendre et rien faire
ou je suis confiant de enfin il veut il
veut que ça fasse nul et vite quoi
et
bon alors là peut-être te recettes
de ça son idée ouais ok c'est tout
recette en fait si on échange les tours
c'est bon parce que là on va il va faire
ça
j'imagine
j'imagine ça
parce qu'en fait ok si les tours
s'échangent on a vite à l'heure que
normalement voilà tenir après est-ce que
la ça change que il a le temps de venir
ici on peut regarder qu'il y avait pas
là
peu importe voilà voilà
ok ça doit aller mais
ouais on va voir
le truc ouais si on fait un coup droit
peut-être même ça ça va mais bon je
pense que vous lui courir après avec la
tour moi le cavalier bouge il veut
peut-être se tente comme ça il a plus le
droit couper si je vais venir par là bon
attention à la fourchette mais
ok on va voir on va voir mais je sais
pas je trouve qu'un coup un patient ce
F5
pas très grave encore mais
j'aime pas trop quoi
donc sûrement je sais pas enfin vu comme
il joue je m'attends à toi
j'avais contre trois pions c'est perdant
ça va dépendre où sont les pions où sont
les rois mais
bon j'imagine mal le cas de figure
arrivé là en fait
échanger les tours et que les Blancs
puissent une cavalier contre deux
ça fait c'est beaucoup
pose une question ouais je l'emmerde à
repartir après le tournoi est-ce que
c'est une passion cachée ou pour le
délire
pour les deux non mais c'est pas une
passion cachée c'est un peu pour le
délire
donc c'est quoi en fait oui donc j'ai
joué dans le tournoi donc c'est un film
tu parles d'échec c'est le sujet et
Murder Party c'est que en fait je
connais
[Musique]
le réalisateur et il cherchait quelques
figurants et c'était à la période covid
et tu vois enfin donc
c'est un moyen de s'échapper de faire un
truc pendant ce moment-là lui d'avoir
des gens qu'il avait confiance tu vois
je me faisais testé avant machin
j'allais pas j'allais pas choper le truc
pour pas lui contaminer son film et
voilà mais en fait faire figurant c'est
pas une passion quoi c'est pas c'est pas
top top d'être figurant quoi mais là
c'était sympa de voir des gens que
j'aime bien
et voilà donc c'était cool mais voilà
après
tourner c'est c'est sympa mais sauf que
enfin voilà je me considère pas comme un
acteur quoi c'est j'ai eu une fois la
chance j'ai découvert et ça s'est bien
passé je suis très content je suis même
je remercie même pour l'expérience
qui m'a été qui m'était offerte je suis
jamais un jour par hasard tu vois ça
peut arriver c'est cool mais voilà donc
c'est pas pour te dire c'est pas un
délire non plus mais c'est
l'occasion fait le larron on va dire
voilà mais je cherche pas du tout
activement à ce que ce que
a joué quoi enfin tu vois je suis pas
allé faire deux casting je suis pas allé
faire des trucs depuis
donc voilà il a joué au 8 donc il veut
bien échanger les tours
comme on avait dit et en fait les blancs
peuvent pas trop
[Musique]
peuvent pas trop fuir donc il va il va
échanger et voilà quoi
alors des moyens ouais mais bon il
gueule pas alors il donne pas plus 5 ou
quoi donc
faites ça doit aller mais
ouais je sais pas enfin
ça envoie un peu un signal que si jamais
tu as des défenses longues et
chiante à faire je suis pas sûr qu'il
sera prêt à le faire
de dire ce que caryat King faisait
contre Carlson ou quoi
ça peut donner une indication de où le
viser d'essayer de lui donner une
position un peu déplaisante longue chose
comme ça ce F5
il a beaucoup commenté depuis le début
du tournoi si il veut souffler trois
secondes aucune un truc à faire il peut
faire quoi donc tu reprends vite échec
il va prendre probablement avec le roi
enfin je vois pas l'intérêt de prendre
avec un cavalier de se mettre passif
là-bas même si c'est peut-être jouable
donc on est 52e
il a pris du roi
et voilà mon épaule qui avait attaqué
donc de choix soit là soit là peut-être
5 pour attaquer le G6 bah on n'a pas le
choix que de le pousser
et bon il y en a un phares qui se
dépêchent d'améliora ici mais bon a
priori on va y arriver quoi
non pas le temps de faire autre chose
donc je sais pas est-ce qu'on fait G4
est-ce qu'on fait G3 pour casser un peu
les pions j'ai 4
j'ai 4
[Musique]
bon après par exemple là un truc qu'on
veut pas c'est F4 parce que on se prend
H4 dans la tronche on se fait saper la
base de la chaîne de pions qui on prend
on prend on a créé deux pions passer lié
lui on va on va s'occuper de son cas
bientôt et
bon ça on a de bonne chance de perdre
avec les Noirs donc ça c'est un catcheur
qu'on veut pas par exemple j'ai 4 ça
pose une question parce qu'on veut
prendre monter le roi bouffer lui tiens
donc
avoir bon probablement comprendre je
sais pas peut-être 700 coups d'être à
trois
peut-être ça un coup comme ça surprise
on peut venir ici pile poil attend quoi
parce qu'on a repris F5 et du coup on
bloque les entrées
mais c'est pas loin de dégénérer ces
conneries enfin je veux dire ça je serai
pas ravi de voir ça avec les normes
[Musique]
là l'ordi te dit que c'est nul on va
recettes ok parce que tu as une
fourchette tu prends il y a ça et tu
reprends lui bon ça c'est la force des
cavaliers toutes les finales ils ont une
agilité dès cavaliers qui fait que faut
surveiller les fourchettes c'est très
tactique ça c'est pas très dur c'est
juste moi qui bon je regarde comme ça
mais ouais ouais faut quand même
ça fait nul si tu as le droit là tu sais
que tu fais nul tu as plus rien à
calculer plus rien à faire mais faut pas
faut pas qu'il y a un truc comme ça qui
se passe quoi
mais ça doit aller
est-ce que c'est la première fois depuis
72 qu'un champion du monde n'est plus le
meilleur joueur du monde
plus ou moins plus ou moins
à partir de quand on considère plus
Fischer je veux dire c'est la première
question parce que effectivement il a pu
jouer après son titre mais est-ce que
est-ce qu'en 75 objectivement car pas
fait plus fort bon déjà on saura jamais
tu vois mais donc à voir après dans les
joueurs qui étaient actifs car pas fait
très bien picasparov
[Musique]
et casse pas avait été battue par
cramique en 2000 mais bon il y a pas de
scandale à ça mais probablement je pense
que c'est toujours plus fort
à ce moment-là il est quand même il y
aura mondial
donc on a quand même une période où le
champion du monde c'était pas casparf
entre 2000 et 2005 avant sa retraite et
je pense c'était quand même le meilleur
joueur du moment mais oui il a pu le
remettre revanche et Machin et c'est
comme ça
mais bon cramique cramique c'était
costaud quand même quoi
et puis après tu as eu un an des cars
scène et voilà
mais donc c'est peut-être pas la
première fois enfin tu vois
ta question je peux pas te répondre noir
ou blanc quoi mais
[Musique]
disons
que là en ce moment 45 et le meilleur
joueur et oui il sera pas champion du
monde donc là on a la certitude que
c'est le cas mais même avant il y a des
petites questions quoi
après on se la dit comme je disais enfin
Carlson serait venu jouer le match
contre il aurait été favori mais je peux
pas te dire qu'il aurait gagné enfin
faut le gagner le match c'est pas c'est
pas fait d'avance c'est jamais fait
d'avance donc
peu importe enfin c'est son choix
pourquoi il a pas défendu le titre Bosch
le format lui plaisait pas ou peut-être
s'entendait mal avec la fille ou je
connais même pas les raisons profondes
enfin juste ça lui plaît pas trop de
genre truc en fait donc
bon je sais pas c'est comme ça en fait
on écrit les coups alors au début je
sais pourquoi on les écrivait c'était
pour reconstituer la partie s'il y avait
un litige pour vérifier qu'il y avait un
coup illégal si un mec dit tu vois
imagine avec les Blancs tu notes pas et
puis tu joues cavalier qui avait là bon
bah là
tu dis tu appelles l'arbitre dit oui bon
il a joué un coup il a pas le droit mais
l'autre il est difficile j'étais là dis
non tu étais là bon bah tu crois qui du
coup tu notes et
puis bah il y a pas il y a pas de tige
quoi enfin voilà c'était une
reconstruction reconstitution de la
partie alors maintenant avec les moyens
modernes et les parties diffusées sur
des échiquiers digitaux tu pourrais t'en
passer potentiellement mais c'est
peut-être juste une double vérification
c'est aussi par tradition parce qu'on a
l'habitude et que la personne s'est posé
la question si c'est utile ou pas
après bon voilà enfin bon du coup on
note les parties lentes et bon c'est
comme ça en fait mais effectivement il
pourrait s'en passer
notamment pour ce tournoi là où tu as 10
000 caméras et tout ça
dure avoir trois non trois civils le
jour mais il est pas meilleur que G4 ou
que j'ai trois ou enfin ça va pas
changer la face de la position
on peut prendre une licence pour faire
un tournoi directement à la ligne sans
faire partie d'un club
ok je sais pas trop les points de
règlement comme ça je crois quand tu
prends une licence tu es quand même
affilié un club même si tu vas pas y
mettre les pieds dedans souvent en fait
les tournois les ouais les tournois qui
vont prendre une licence dans leur club
à eux
de toute façon toi ça te change rien et
puis ils sont contents pour leur stats
et puis et puis voilà enfin donc
mais je crois que tu es quand même dans
un club quand tu prends une licence
après tu peux choisir peut-être ton club
qui peut dire je sais pas c'est une
ville que tu aimes bien
ou quoi tu pourrais quoi
parce que le fait que Ding soit souvent
plus short en temps comparé un époque un
indicateur d'une fibrilité/ d'une moins
bonne connaissance de la position ou
s'il n'a pas de corrélation entre le
temps pris par les pros les résultats
bon on va dire quand tu es à l'aise en
général tu te mets pas super mal au
temps donc voilà mais après tu as des
joueurs qui aiment bien faire un peu
plus que d'autres genre tu vois gris
tchouc qui est toujours mal au temps
[Musique]
c'est pas corrélé lui fait qu'il soit
bien ou mal dans la position c'est juste
qu'il aime bien réfléchir
donc ça va dépendre aussi des joueurs
mais allez d'un point de vue général
c'est vrai que si le mec il a beaucoup
beaucoup réfléchi la plupart du temps
c'est plutôt que il y a un truc qui
tourne pas dans sa position ou que lui
il la juge pas bonne parce qu'il n'aime
pas il est pas à l'aise donc il peut
quand même y avoir un
une relation là ici
ok il y a 20 minutes d'écart tu vois
c'est pas non plus un énorme écart et ça
change pas grand chose quoi aujourd'hui
Ding a pas mal gérer son temps quoi
c'est que les Blancs
oui mais ça devrait pas gagner quoi
allez regarde contre les deux pions
tu peux avoir un espoir si c'est le
calque sur un pion tu gagneras pas bon
tu parleras pas si tu vas liquider le
dernier on s'en soyez ça mais voilà
alors Xav pige qui me demande à partir
de quel Hélo est-il intéressant de
travailler les études donc les études
c'est des exercices des puzzles
particuliers qui ont été composés
qui sont souvent un peu sympa il y a des
idées cachées etc donc ça peut être
intéressant à n'importe quel niveau mais
c'est bien pour travailler le calcul et
la créativité
donc j'ai pas de dire de faire ça quand
tu es trop débutant parce que tu as
mieux à faire avant mais ça peut devenir
intéressant un moment et puis tu es pas
obligé d'y consacrer un temps de fou
mais en faire de temps en temps pourquoi
pas
est-ce que je connais personne qui aide
à préparer Ding alors non enfin on sait
qu'il y a rapporte mais après je sais
pas qui a d'autres et s'il y en a
d'autres d'ailleurs probablement oui
mais c'est même pas certain quoi
bon les pots qui réfléchit donc là vous
voyez à moitié
[Musique]
on va s'y endormi non mais il essaye
d'imaginer éventuellement à setup qui
pourrait être piégeur ou quoi
c'est pas qui fait la tranche ou quoi là
c'est il réfléchit il en intense
réflexion
et il va y arriver tu peux aller
organiser que je vais faire ça tu vas
prendre
ok bon après là il faut essayer de pas
se faire du xvanguer quand même
c'est bon alors je vois quand même deux
coups c'est roi là où cavalier là parce
qu'on peut perdre lui pour se venger sur
celui-là en disant qu'en face ça il va y
avoir F3 j'imagine on doit repartir ici
défendre le pion
et si les blancs passent leur tour on va
encore voilà qui fait que on ne perd pas
pour l'instant on s'accroche au pion
donc les blancs peuvent être contentes
targuer d'avoir cette casse pour le roi
et d'avancer mais bon ça va on a encore
échec
heureusement j'ai envie de dire mais on
l'a et là le problème c'est qu'on
repousse le roi parce que si il monte
bah on fait ça et on va bouffer de lui
donc là merde n'importe quoi pardon il
est défendu donc on ne bouffe rien du
tout pardon
mais donc ici il revient on répète si
jamais ici s'en va il s'en va et à ce
moment-là on peut attendre à tourner
avec le cavalier je dirais-je pas ici
moi
j'ai du mal à voir qu'on est blanc
avancent mais bon faut faire rire de pas
se faire du xangre comme je vous disais
genre on serait comme ça les blancs on
aura de sauter ici ce serait peut-être
un souci
voilà et donc ce que Ding espère voir
dans un scénario pareil c'est qu'à un
moment les blancs se disent bon bah ok
je peux pas gagner le pion je suis
obligé d'avancer et là à ce moment-là on
va ramener le cavalier pour aller
bouffer spion et on en parlera plus donc
par exemple on l'attaque il esquive on
l'attaque il esquive on l'attaque il
peut plus qu'il est donc il joue un coup
et on le sacrifie et on fait nul voilà
bon en gros c'est ça ce que veut les
noirs et les pots il essaie de trouver
des cas de figure ou justement il
pourrait trouver un petit exemple ou
quoi et voilà
est-ce que je pense que je prenne une
éponge position alors ouais enfin la
plupart du temps peut-être je suis
capable de faire le coin de craquer une
fois de temps en temps aussi mais bon
normalement je devrais y arriver
mais bon
et j'ai 4 bah j'ai 4 je crois qu'on a
regardé tout à l'heure
j'ai quatre il faut pas il faut surtout
pas faire ça c'est ce qu'on avait dit
mais le truc que j'aime bien moi c'était
recette
puisque prise en fait on ramène le roi
il est pas là-bas sur les 10e rangée
loin du jeu et on va reprendre celui-là
et ça va aller
mais bon de toute façon on va pas trop
moyen il a priori il y en a pas pour les
blancs mais les pots va juste de voir
essayer de trouver la meilleure chance
pratique ou peut-être il y a un petit
piège un petit truc
à éviter et voilà
bon ok Ding doit trouver enfin là c'est
pas non plus si dur
pour qu'on me voit rarement faire des
gros tournants alors qu'est-ce tu
appelles gros tournant parce que en fait
les gros tournage juste j'ai pas le
niveau pour les jouets quoi
tu vois les grandes chaises
les candidats c'est pas pour moi quoi
c'est ça les gros tournois quoi
moi je préfère les open donc ça ça va
j'ai le droit mais j'appelle pas ça des
gros tournant en fait
mais je peux faire des bons open j'ai
joué Gibraltar de nombreuses fois
c'est juste le plus fort au moment
j'avais joué de l'Open au Qatar quand il
était Mégaforce
j'ai commencé le temps à la dernière
table quoi j'étais le plus faible fort
du tournant donc ça ça m'arrivait jamais
de ma vie joie la dernière table quoi
donc j'en ai fait des beaux open quoi
même Reykjavik il est pas si mal mais
c'est pas un gros tournoi non plus c'est
un bon open tu vois différence de terme
quoi
c'est lequel on entend habituel préféré
pas moi donc j'aimais bien requie parce
que j'aime bien leur en Islande et c'est
cool Gibraltar quand il est organisé
j'aimais bien je faisais quasi chaque
année
après je mets bien aussi le temps dans
le sud de l'Italie petit open tranquille
ou au bord de la plage tu manges bien
tout cool quoi
mais après voilà
après vous pouvez choisir des enfin si
vous voulez jouer des tournois vous
pouvez choisir
j'en sais rien en fonction du lieu en
fait faites-vous des belles vacances et
jouer aux échec en même temps pour faire
plaisir voilà
vous avez le temps ouais non ils ont
fait ils ont pété l'hôtel pour
rénovation en fait il donnait vraiment
sur la mer donc peut-être qu'il y avait
une érosion qui avait un truc je sais
pas trop et donc il reconstruisent alors
après une fois que ça sera refait il
faudra que que qu'il ressent un
partenariat sponsor ship faut avoir
voilà ça coûte 15 de l'argent
d'organiser un ton appareil ça risque
d'invite énormément de monde tu avais
les tops joueurs genre Maxime qui jouait
Naka il y a eu so carwana des grands
maîtres ribambelle tu avais pas mal des
meilleures choses au monde et voilà tous
ces gens là tu dois les inviter
donc voilà faut
les sponsors derrière j'ai envie de te
dire
mais donc je sais pas peut-être ça sera
réorganisé à partir je sais pas quand
l'hôtel est prévu d'être fini enfin les
travaux donc je sais pas c'est genre
2024 enfin
ça sera pas j'ai envie 2024 a priori
disons parce que je n'aurais déjà
entendu parler j'imagine peut-être 2025
ou
mais je sais pas en fait j'ai pas de
news mais en tout cas c'est ça le
problème en ce moment et voilà
quoi le prochain gros tournoi
de chest aller qui reprennent en mèche
rien mais juin et le prochain tournoi
important pour le cycle et les
championnats du monde bah c'est la Coupe
du Monde qui est
fin juillet et août
sympa en France je connais le cap
Saint-Affrique la Corse mais quoi
d'autre bon tu en as plein tu peux
attends un peu de partout quoi dès qu'il
y a des vacances scolaires toute façon
il y en a beaucoup donc l'été il y en a
plein
ça dépend ce que tu aimes tu vois à la
montagne
plus campagne
tu as même des tournois récemment il y a
ton nom Martinique donc si tu veux te
faire des belles vacances tu vas
Martinique tu vois j'ai le temps là etc
donc
c'est cool et puis ta toilette on a
l'étranger aussi si tu as envie enfin
bon bref tu vois
que je pense que Magnus va essayer de
regagner le titre
pas tout de suite
pas tout de suite parce que je veux dire
là s'il a pas joué cette fois c'est
qu'il y a un truc qui lui déplaît dans
le format et tout ça je pense pas que ça
a changé si vite donc pourquoi il
changerait d'avis du jour au lendemain
ça m'étonnerait quoi mais bon après
juste je sais pas trop enfin tu vois je
suis pas dans sa tête je peux pas parler
pour lui quoi donc faudra faudra lui
demander quoi
en Grèce ou Athènes s'il y a des bons
tournants en Grèce à la fin il y a un
tournoi qui est sympa que j'ai jamais
fait mais j'ai eu des bons échos ça
s'appelle pas les autres chaura et c'est
plus dans les îles je sais pas si crête
ou quoi
je crois que c'est très bien
pourquoi je joue pas en pro de chez
League bah
je crois que les joueurs qui jouent ils
sont mieux quoi
déjà tu dois faire une moyenne élo donc
tu faut que ça rentre
et donc on a
[Musique]
là la prochaine fois
on a des chances d'avoir bâti donc c'est
mieux que moi aussi
il y a Katia de toute façon il faut que
je joueuse et puis bah elle est très
bien qu'elle tient et donc après on a
mal qui est jaune motivé et qui clique
bien après je sais pas si moi j'aurai le
droit déjà de jouer concrètement mais en
plus je peux pas te dire que ce soit
mieux que je joue mal quoi
c'est peut-être pas beaucoup plus mal
non plus mais c'est pas il y a pas il y
a pas de scandale
donc voilà en fait keV il essaie de
faire l'équipe la plus compétitive et
elle est bien enfin tu vois l'équipe est
qualifié donc c'est bien quoi
est-ce que je dois jouer pour ce ouais
ouais plusieurs fois j'adore le tournoi
je l'ai joué je sais plus trois fois
deux trois fois au moins enfin non non
très bien très beau tournoi encore à
côté d'Ajaccio nickel très beau cadre
bien organisé
[Musique]
je recommande quoi enfin c'est bien beau
tournant
je peux toujours mais en fait pourquoi
faire enfin tu vois je fais pas mal de
trucs à côté pour gagner ma vie et toi
entre les stages les cours les livres
enfin ça prend du temps c'est pas juste
claque des doigts et voilà là dans deux
semaines on fait le stage avec Seb à
Montpellier ben je vais être
physiquement là-bas je vais laver je
dois préparer les cours je peux pas
aller m'amuser à les gens en tournoi
voilà
donc donc voilà quoi j'en fais un autre
cet été on a d'autres projets de livres
avec Kev bon bah déjà faut écrire tu
vois enfin bon et du coup sur mon temps
libre en plus des fois j'ai envie
d'avoir de souffler quoi tu vois enfin
un tournoi tu souffles pas tu
joues ça te prend toutes tes journées tu
as du stress
donc
ouais non en fait je vais pas beaucoup
rejouer plus que ça
[Musique]
alors j'ai jamais réussi à prendre les
coordonnées aux échecs et c'est un
handicap pour pouvoir s'améliorer et
lire des livres des conseils alors bon
connaître les coordonnées ce sera pas
mieux au moins jouer mais c'est vrai que
pour lire des livres écoutez même des
vidéos parce que quand on analyse tu
vois souvent on dit on parle pas
coordonnées parce que faut bien situer
sur le gigué si je dis bah là il y a G4
machin tu sais pas ce que je dis ça peut
te gêner donc après c'est pas dur enfin
tu vois c'est vite sur 8
tu peux normalement je connais personne
qui arrive pas en fait si tu t'y mets un
peu ça va aller et au cas où tu as
une option sur cheeseccom je sais plus
comment ça s'appelle attends c'est sur
le côté c'est
[Musique]
c'est
une vision je crois il s'appelle tu
regardes sur le côté de toute façon dans
ce cas tu as tu as un menu avec jouer
problème à prendre regarder un faux
social machin et tu tombes sur vision et
puis bah tu cliques et puis te poses des
questions il dit tiens eux deux c'est où
tu es avec ta souris tu essayes de truc
là que tu cliques et puis B7 et essayer
de faire le plus possible en rentrant de
seconde et puis voilà donc
tu vois bien arrivé quoi
ce chemin le tournoi de Saint-Affrique
bah bien sûr je le connais je l'ai joué
plusieurs fois je n'ai jamais gagné et
normalement je devrais y aller cet été
donc oui c'est un truc j'aime bien moi
c'est un truc c'est tranquille ou dans
l'Aveyron c'est la campagne on mange du
roquefort c'est bien quoi il y a
d'aligot il y a du on est bien quoi
donc H4 jouer
alors H4 je m'attends à ce qu'ils
prennent on en a parlé tout à l'heure
donc l'idée il a pas trop traîné l'idée
de HK donc c'est de casser le duo de
pion pour c'est un petit passage pour le
roi et créer peut-être des petits
problèmes donc mettre le roi là qui
avait les G6 qui allaient prendre pion
presser un peu F5 et voilà mais on avait
vu tout à l'heure qu'il y a pas de cas
de deux exemples donc
[Musique]
ça se vit pas pour gagner mais ça peut
problème ça peut poser des problèmes
pratiques et on va voir comment
c'est quoi la technique pour réussir à
visualiser les filles qui est sans
regarder par exemple en jouant à
l'aveugle
mais en fait j'ai du mal à te dire
[Musique]
en fait ça me semble évident mais bon ça
c'est parce que je jouais déjà l'aveugle
quand j'avais genre 8 ans quoi en fait
donc je viens plus comment je me suis
familiarisé avec le truc mais faites
l'échiquier je sais comment il lâche où
il a je connais
je sais où sont les cases chez les
pièces qu'elles contrôlent enfin j'ai
pas d'efforts à faire donc dur à dire tu
vois mais c'est comme
comme si tu demandes un pianiste comment
tu fais pour jouer du piano en lisant
tes partitions le regard des touches
quoi
c'est une histoire d'habitude je dirais
mais tu vois j'ai pas eu affaire de
d'efforts
c'est pas très dur quoi
en gros mon père me faisait jouer contre
l'ordi quand j'étais petit à l'aveugle
pour me faire calculer et voilà quoi
donc voilà après bah essaye de jouer un
peu à l'aveugle
[Musique]
tu vas y arriver pendant quelques coups
avant tu vas bloqué et puis à force tu
iras plus loin mais franchement c'est
pas très dur quoi enfin c'est souvent
impressionnant tu vois
les gens qui savent pas jouer aux échecs
ils disent incroyable mais pas très
incroyable en fait
on y arrive tous
que ça prend en vente on est déjà dû en
fait au pire on s'en fout de jouer à
l'aveugle si tu arrives pas si il compte
c'est que tu joues aux échec normaux le
mieux possible et que tu t'amuses quoi
mais mais
ça va pas forcément de faire mieux jouer
mais normalement c'est plutôt bon signe
parce que tu arrives à te présenter le
jeu sans te perdre donc quand tu vas
faire des calculs de vente en partie tu
vas moins être gêné tu as plus de dire
mince midi ou lui déjà il attaque quoi
il fait quoi est-ce que je l'ai déjà
changé ce que je l'ai plus enfin là
dessus quand c'est comme ça mais
donc j'imagine que plus tu progresses
plus ça devient simple
est-ce que je serai fort parce que les
échecs sont aux JO
oh je suis ni favorable ni défavorable
déjà bon faut décider est-ce que c'est
un sport ou pas tu vois première
question donc des gens vont dire oui
d'autres non
[Musique]
bon moi je suis pas convaincu enfin je
veux dire un sport donc bon c'est comme
ça de toute façon je m'en fiche il y a
une certaine dimension sportive mais
c'est aussi un jeu
etc donc est-ce que ça a sa place par
rapport à d'autres gens qui sont des
athlètes et qui font un sport vraiment
physique bon donc voilà c'est la
question après si c'est oui la réponse
bah pourquoi pas en fait il y a pas les
échecs
mais moi je m'en fiche
tu vois enfin je sais pas ce que ça
apporterait spécialement ou pas
je suis pas con je suis pas pour je suis
puis c'est pas c'est pas ma décision
quoi enfin tu vois je vais pas changer
avec mon avis quoi que ce soit donc peu
importe
il y a le curling aux JO alors à partir
de là non mais je veux dire pour moi
allez pour qu'un truc au JO j'ai envie
qu'il y a une dimension physique mais ça
peut être de l'adresse le physique hein
donc il y aura les fléchettes aux JO tu
vois c'est pas ça paraît si
physique que ça quoi de jeter des
fléchettes donc je te demande pas de
faire de l'haltérophilie uniquement quoi
mais qui est une dimension ouais adresse
ou physique quoi
tir à l'arc pareil tu as une adresse
pour le truc
donc bref voilà mais
peu importe la pétanque aux yeux
tu dois tu dois voilà mais bon peu
importe enfin les gens qui pourraient
pas un scandale non plus hein
[Musique]
moi je comprends que la question se pose
et puis bah c'est au Comité olympique de
décider si c'est bien c'est pas bien ce
qu'ils en pensent voilà
la belote mais je veux dire oui non mais
si tu mets les échecs tu as le droit de
mettre la belote après enfin c'est
pourquoi pas enfin il y a pas de
problème c'est pas pire enfin c'est pas
juste après je pense que les jeux
doivent être quand même
comment on appelle ça universel je crois
que quand même on n'est pas nombreux à y
jouer en termes de pays donc
[Musique]
je vais un peu sur toute la planète quoi
mais le poker aux JO bah voilà pourquoi
pas enfin je veux dire oui tu peux
mettre enfin tu mets
tu peux tout mettre en fait je veux dire
pourquoi pas
donc bref non alors rêve 4 jouets en
tout cas donc on est dans une région
qu'on a déjà regardé et ce qu'on avait
pensé c'est que peut-être faut ramener
le roi
faut ramener le droit un peu vite
alors je vois que l'ordi il dit H3
j'aime pas ou je sais pas trop quoi dire
je comprends pas le coup en fait parce
que on prend enfin ok on comprend mais
je file un pion passé cadeau quoi et qui
va pas s'échanger et on garde un pion en
vie donc c'est pas un coup que j'ai
envie de jouer je sais pas alors dédique
ça va moi je te dis non quoi je veux pas
voir H3 du coup moi ce que je fais là
mon roi ici donc je pense qu'avec les
blancs tu veux pas avoir droit ici
mais tu peux pas trop faire différemment
parce que si tu fais ça pour pas que je
vienne toute façon je vais te bouffer F2
donc voilà donc à priori je m'attends à
ça je viens tu prends et on avait dit ça
attaque le pion on a regardé F3 pareil
hyper logique on repart j'avais fait
j'ai trois coups d'attente parce que là
les blancs peuvent pas améliorer
beaucoup plus ils ont le droit actif ils
ont le cavalier qui attaque ça de toute
façon j'ai pas de casse voler G4 je veux
pas faire parce que j'échange le pion je
dois garder des pions pour gagner donc
j'ai trois je sais pas quoi dire d'autre
et on avait dit voilà qui tient parce
que sur Roissy on a échec le roi rouge
on revient
merde j'ai une connerie on fait échec
oui donc ça c'est une connerie parce que
là du coup il y a un nouveau coup
d'attente vu que Zang si je bouge le roi
je me fais bouffer si je bouge le cas et
je me fais bouffer et il défend au
passage champion donc ça c'est la merde
donc pas qu'il est ici pardon
le roi bouge je le remets en échec il
vient je le mets en échec s'il se barre
ailleurs tant mieux et j'ai le temps de
revenir
donc en gros voilà mais bon en fait il
se trouve ça va donc ça va c'est tout
mais faut juste pas faire de conneries
quoi la ligne elle est pas si dure à
voir quand même et puis bon il l'a voulu
c'est lui qui a joué F5 avant qui a
voulu se finir absolument d'échangeant
les tours donc bon j'imagine qu'il
devrait être en état de la tenir et qui
va le faire parce que là c'est hyper ça
c'est
faux professionnel enfin je veux dire là
bon ok tu m'arrêtes pas d'être champion
du monde quoi il y a vraiment il y a
rien à dire ça très très grave d'un
point de professionnel
mais
c'est pas possible quoi enfin je veux
dire
donc voilà
pourquoi ils partent à Tours drôles
comme ça bah ils sont pas obligés ils le
font s'ils veulent en fait en gros une
fois que tu as joué ton cou
tu fais ce que tu veux tu restes assis
tu te balades tu vas boire de l'eau tu
vas aux toilettes tu vas bouffer tu tu
marches juste pour détendre les jambes
et souffler si tu veux aller faire du
yoga enfin tu fais ce que tu as envie
quoi donc tu peux aussi rester assise
concentré et tout le long mais là n'est
plus il a fait une grande réflexion et
maintenant en fait toi j'ai envie de
dire il a envisagé les répliques adverse
recette machin qui me dit bouge truc bon
c'est plus entre ses mains donc il
attend que l'autre joue pour revenir
donc pourquoi pas mais ça te détendre
marcher un peu aussi de d'évacuer un peu
de la tension et voilà
donc voilà bah pourquoi il a joué encore
bah parce que il y a des cas de figure
on n'est pas gagné
il sera content de faire nul
Ding si il pouvait s'arrêter là et dire
ok c'est nul on arrête mais il signe
direct il veut pas jouer Dingler il veut
juste il veut juste que ça s'arrête mais
une peau
a complètement raison de de pousser
l'adversaire de ses retranchements
et la prochaine partie c'est quand donc
c'est pas demain demain c'est repos et
ce sera dimanche à 11h du mat comme
d'hab
ce qui est 30 secondes par contre
maintenant pas encore mais dans 5
couilles à partir du 60e
donc non bedding il vérifie juste mais
enfin je peux pas imaginer qu'il perde
ça quoi enfin si il perd c'est ça
parce que enfin je rappelle
j'en étais comme ça il se passait rien
et bouge le roi
veut pas prendre si il se fait bouffer
on se fait bouffer lui bon il propose
d'échanger Cavelier il fait un coup de
tour tiens je pars machin je bouge donc
en fait il se passe rien de rien quoi
dire que on bouge à droite à gauche si
je ramène la tour là si je me mets la
tour à droite si je veux faire échec
revenir enfin ok rien et de lui-même il
fait
donc il provoque toute la suite attaque
la tour il vient là venez l'échange bon
bah je te force l'échange tu te barres
je te bouffe ton cavalier donc tu dois
faire et donc là bah on attaque le pion
seul moyen de le défendre c'est le
pousser il y a aucune pièce qui
intervient et il y en a ça donc c'est
forcé de chez forcer donc il rentre
dedans parce qu'il veut rentrer dedans
donc je veux dire je peux pas imaginer
qu'il est pas tout calculé sinon c'est
c'est invraisemblable quoi
donc écoute on va voir
un format différent ce que je pense que
personne pourra le jouer pour le fun
j'ai un nom mais en fait je comme je
sais pas en fait ce que Carlson il
veut exactement
rien me semble impossible avec lui mais
vu de l'extérieur ça paraîtrait
spectaculaire d'aller jouer un tournoi
dont le seul but est de qualifié pour un
champion du monde que tu veux pas jouer
donc je dis rien non mais
on a l'abri de rien quoi en même temps
ce qui est une méthode pour bosser une
ouverture ah bah oui enfin il y en a
sûrement plusieurs mais en gros si tu
veux jouer une ouverture
la méthode c'est quoi c'est que tu
prends la théorie donc moi je suis
plutôt du principe de dire prends un
livre sur l'ouverture et comme ça le mec
qui t'explique les enjeux et voilà si tu
veux pas acheter de livres tu peux avoir
des logiciels genre chaises bases ou
regarder sur la base en ligne cheescom
par exemple ou quoi
tu regardes les parties des meilleurs tu
essayes de comprendre pourquoi les coups
sont joués tu apprends pas juste par
cœur et après tu regardes aussi en
faisant les arbres c'est à dire que tu
vois que ici il y a trois coups qui ont
été joués c'est celui-là celui-là
celui-là a été joué à 4000 fois celui-là
attends nana et tu te fais une sorte
d'arborescence des possibilités et tu
élargi ton
ton panel de connaissances
et voilà mais pareil donc tu dois
essayer de comprendre les coûts tu fais
pas juste un coup parce que Carlson a
joué ou parce que Ding a joué ou quoi si
l'enjeu c'est qu'il y a sûrement une
raison et c'est de dire ah tiens
qu'est-ce qu'il est derrière la tête ou
quoi si tu fais que du Parker tu vas
confondre tu vas pas comprendre un
moment de toute façon ton adversaire va
pas jouer tout ce que tu connais tout le
temps et puis tu sauras parce que tu
fais donc vaut mieux connaître moins
loin mais comprendre les idées les
enjeux les plans que d'apprendre par
coeur 30 coups bon bah moi en façon le
mec va changer tu sais plus ce que tu
fais tu es là tu es perdu
quel prix de ce match hormis le titre
ben il y a 2 millions en jeu en fait il
y a un virgule deux pour le vainqueur
800000 pour le pour le finaliste
donc ça c'est les prix ça s'est pris
pour les joueurs après je sais pas il y
a aussi des coûts d'organisation de
donc c'est un coup d'organiser ça
donc Zim qui me dit que on lui a parlé
des parties références c'est intéressant
de les connaître les ouvertures ou quoi
comment comment les choisir
en gros tu tries par Elo tu regardes les
mecs forts comment ils ont joué mais tu
peux aussi avoir une approche historique
regardez l'évolution de la vente à
travers le temps parce que peut-être
qu'à liquide la joue une certaine
manière que tu comprends des trucs
comment il joue et puis que tu as une
partie 1 et 5 ans je trouve ça un peu de
vinique qui révolutionne le truc on se
dit ah non mais en fait ça va pas c'est
du coup c'était mauvais enfin l'idée
était bonne mais concrètement ça va pas
puis tu en as un autre mec dans les
années 60 tu te remets le truc au goût
du jour parce que il irait plus que
l'autre idée donc tu peux avoir cette
idée là avec les parties des forgeurs à
travers le temps tu vois l'évolution et
vers où ça va mais oui ça c'est pas
évident de faire tout ce boulot tout
seul mais en fait c'est un travail de
recherche
et c'est pour ça que je vous disais que
finalement avoir un livre sur les
ouvertures c'est pas mal parce qu'en
gros l'auteur il est censé un peu
t'expliquer tout ça
te dire voilà ici il y a ça qui est
possible ça ça moi je préfère ça je
pense que c'est meilleur parce que
tatati tatata et petite des parties et
en fait il a fait tous boulot prémâcher
pour toi après ça reste que son avis à
lui il a le droit de se tromper ou
d'avoir des préférences différentes des
tiennes et quoi qu'il en soit dans un
but de compréhension du truc c'est qu'un
utile parce que tu es au courant de ce
qui existe de ce qui existe pas de ce
qui est censé être bon mauvais ce qui
était joyeux à une époque qui ne l'est
plus maintenant
et
donc pour toutes ces raisons là tu vois
pas bête d'essayer d'avoir un ouvrage
sur sur les ouvertures après évidemment
tu as des livres mieux que d'autres mais
bon après faut voir les avis tu peux
essayer de demander
voilà après ouais
est-ce que c'est les deux premiers
candidats qui jouent la finale du carnet
n'est pas la exactement Hugo c'est les
deux premiers des candidats qui jouent
Ding refait des dingueries autant
dans 5 minutes donc il va avoir encore
un rajout il me semble il aura ses 30
secondes
donc ça va aller mais bon
comment il est entré dedans de gaieté de
cœur et si là il est pas sûr de lui mais
c'est celui-ci non en fait c'est juste
de la chance c'est hyper peur pas alors
donc je sais pas c'est quoi
mais normalement il tient pas trop dur
ce qu'on a calculé ce qu'on a regardé
mais oui il faudra pas se tromper faudra
pas se prendre des exemples
et oui j'arrive pas à conduire c'est
juste concret mais c'est un coup
[Musique]
a priori débile mais juste bon il va
mais
[Musique]
bon mais il le fait c'est incroyable
qu'ils disent songer et qu'il ait trouvé
donc j'en ai déjà bravo si ça non comme
coup parce que a priori débile vu que
bah de toute façon on va prendre c'est
clair et que ça donne un pion passé et
que t'as pas encore réalisé cet échange
là après donc
qu'est-ce qui est censé se passer
ramener le roi
je sais pas est-ce qu'on fait H4
maintenant ou pas admettons voilà
H5 et peut-être il dit qu'à un moment tu
avance pas beaucoup plus mais là je vois
des cas de figure hyper moi enfin je
veux dire là je serai pas sûr de la
tenir moi avec les mains je me dirais ok
ça doit aller je vais le bloquer ce pion
je tiens celui-là il va pas grand chose
peut-être transfère mon cavalier là ok
mais bon
franchement il joue avec le feu j'aime
pas enfin
en tout cas il calcule beaucoup c'est un
très bon calculateur donc par le calcul
il peut te le faire tenir mais j'aime
pas le j'aime pas la stratégie derrière
les coups en fait j'aime pas ce que je
vois
c'est que le top 3 des livres que j'ai
lu non mais il y a pas de secret
t'inquiète si je peux aider alors moi il
y en a un que j'ai beaucoup aimé
[Musique]
en livre moderne enfin plus si moderne
il doit avoir une petite vingtaine
d'années c'est understanding chess move
by move de John nun c'est 30 parties
commentées très bien commentées qui qui
couvre un peu tout toutes les faces du
jeu très bien très bon livre non une
bonne hauteur j'aime bien
ok ça premier deuxième que je pourrais
te conseiller c'est un classique des
échecs
c'est le tournoi des candidats de Zurich
1953 écrit par Brunstein l'art du Cambo
aux échecs très bien énorme livre plein
de parties
commenter de l'intérieur par Brunstein
qui était pas quand même vice champion
du monde quoi donc
pas un mauvais quoi donc très bon livre
et
ok après tu en a plein
mais moi qu'est-ce qui m'a marqué donc
là je parle personnellement
j'avais un peu je réfléchis un peu j'ai
lu les livres de droit à qui j'aimais
bien par exemple positionnalplay quand
j'étais petit probablement que ça m'a
marqué probablement que ça ça influencé
mon jeu et tout ça mais bien sûr tu as
plein de livres
par partie de Fisher pourquoi pas
[Musique]
oui c'est un bon livre j'avais bien aimé
le livre de Larsen aussi qu'elle nous
faisait partie très bien je créatif etc
cool j'avais lu mon système d'enzovic
jugement j'en ai vu des livres quand je
veux dire donc mais là on va demander
trois donc
je dois faire trois quoi et voilà
le livre de vikings c'est 200 meilleurs
parties j'avais le tome 2 etc
est-ce que je conseille l'auteur Jérémy
simmann et ben je sais pas en fait comme
je connais pas je peux pas te dire
mais c'est peut-être très bien mais je
les ai pas lu ces livres
c'est quand même on me parle souvent de
la méthode wood Picard là j'ai jamais
fait donc j'en sais rien c'est peut-être
bien c'est peut-être pas bien du tout
peut-être c'est du pipeau je sais pas
enfin
je mets plein de maxeux bien bon livre
bon livre franchement quand c'est un
champion du monde qui a écrit un livre
normalement vous pouvez le faire quoi
vous pouvez vous pouvez y aller plus ou
moins les yeux fermés
un livre que Vlad adore c'est celui qui
casse pas les preuves du temps test of
time très très bien
casse-toi sur les prédécesseurs moi
j'aime bien j'ai lu après sur mon test
of time mieux
parce que en fait
c'est ça donc très bon enfin je veux
dire en plus c'est bien l'approche
historique donc tu apprends les échecs
les grands champions du passé leur vie
machin les contemporains qui sait qui
était bon etc donc c'est très cool
[Musique]
mais sûrement que c'est pas casse pas il
écrit il a peut-être dicté les trucs les
grandes lignes et il a analysé ça je dis
pas le contraire mais que c'est pas sa
plume quoi alors que dans le test of
time c'est casse pas grave casse pas
grave qui te parle quoi
voilà
ce que je retourne le livre les
professionnels de Family oui mais c'est
pas du même niveau que ce que je viens
de te dire ça c'est juste agréable sympa
à lire et enfin moi je relis pas fait
quand je fais des trucs j'essaye de les
faire le mieux que je peux donc tu vois
je vais pas dire ouais non c'est de la
merde après quelqu'un pourrait faire
mieux que moi et bravo à lui enfin mais
je n'aime pas m'engager dans des trucs
et les prendre par-dessus la jambe donc
j'ai essayé de faire le mieux par
rapport à ce qui m'était demandé et
l'intérêt du livre donc c'était un livre
qui était un peu en mode cool ou tu
découvres un peu les joueurs français
bon lui il y aura déjà 10 ans donc il y
en a d'autres maintenant et puis il y a
pas tout le monde c'est pas c'est pas un
inventaire c'est pas un catalogue
c'était juste voilà je crois qu'il y a
peut-être plus ou moins 10 15 interviews
quelques positions d'exercices tissus
des parties une partie de chacun donc
c'est un livre qui se veut tranquille
détendu ou t'apprends quelques trucs et
agréable c'est pas un livre de travail
de ouf ou tu le fais pour
enfin ça a pas la qualité d'un Greg
prédécesseur quoi enfin tiens je dois
être honnête quoi mais dans l'optique
dans laquelle il était écrit c'est c'est
agréable c'est sympa voilà
et donc voilà puis après oui c'est vrai
qu'il était pas cher je crois qu'il est
au 10 euros et donc et dans ce qu'on
fait le livre là qu'on va sortir avec
Kev le 25 c'est pareil il a 9,90 donc ça
reste dans ce prix là de faire un truc
ludique sympa pas franchement livre à 10
€, c'est quand même accessible joli tu
vois il vient se rendre au coup là il y
aura des petits quizz et petits machins
d'apprendre à des choses moi j'aime bien
toujours un peu l'aspect aussi
historique avec les échecs
et voilà mais
mais oui enfin tu vois j'ai pas le
comparer
un livre de casse pas pourquoi c'est
autre chose quoi mais
moi je suis content du rendu je suis
content du travail fin voilà
le nouveau livre pour quel est
dure à dire que il pensait entre 800 et
2000 chezcom mais je veux dire même
quelqu'un beaucoup plus fort pourrait le
lire pour résoudre un peu les quiz
machin et voilà après après oui ils
exercent c'est pas des exercices pas de
grand-mère non plus quoi
[Musique]
mais bon tu peux la regarder comme ça de
toute façon ça aiguise même faire des
exercices faciles ça exerce ça exerce
mais après les exercices ouais ils ont
été plutôt progressifs tu vois ils vont
entre 1 et 3 étoiles donc une étoile
c'est plutôt simple de un peu plus chaud
trois bon des fois il y en a des
passants
voilà c'est un peu progressif c'est par
terre voilà
et puis et puis l'en format qui va être
pratique tu peux tu peux me prendre en
les transports en commun à la plage ou
tu veux quoi
je pense préparer les candidats ouais
bon peut-être que Carlson il peut il y a
un peu le niveau pour lire autre chose
si il veut mais
il y a mes Chine qui revient qui dit
quand on est pas un pion de plus bas
Ding va donner enfin c'était un bon
choix de sa part c'est pas le problème
mais maintenant il faut encore tenir
j'ai pas été invité à jeun pour voir les
petits non j'ai pas été invité à jeun
après de toute façon je suis ici donc je
peux pas être partout
même si j'avais été invité je crois que
j'aurais dû décliner mais non j'ai pas
été invité
facile ou pas du tout
je sais pas semi facile mais
peut-être des cas on peut perdre
donc on va voir
qui est le genre le plus fort que j'ai
joué en partie officielle
je compte sur il était petit mais je
compte sur c'est fort je compte Maxime
bon la dernière fois ça doit être en
2007 donc il était moins fort que ce
qu'il est maintenant mais il a été déjà
il était déjà grand maître et genre 2006
quoi
[Musique]
en échec basque donc toujours deux
échiquiers mais c'est des échecs
voilà j'ai joué qui c'est plutôt eux les
tout meilleurs
j'ai pas joué carne j'ai pas joué Ding
j'ai pas joué
j'ai pas de fil rouge à
donc c'est quoi ça c'est le top 4
mondial après je sais pas rognon j'ai
pas je compte lui
j'ai pas je compte bacille mais moi je
joue quasiment tout enfin tous les
joueurs français est-ce que j'ai une
j'ai gagné à l'époque alors pendant 2007
mais
en 99 et
je sais plus 2004 2005 par là j'ai perdu
aussi en 2004 contre Maxime un
championnat de France junior
et en effet quelques nuls je rentre en
ouais j'ai battu mevelin en 99
exactement mais quand je l'ai battu en
2004 ou 5 les déjà quoi 15 ans plus ou
moins c'est déjà pas simple enfin il
était probablement déjà meilleur que
j'avais fait nul en 2006 2007 par là
mais oui bon évidemment tu vois
c'est déjà bien pour moi de faire du
contenu il était plus fort et bon après
je n'ai jamais joué quand il a eu 2007
ou quoi donc bon je reste un peu plus
quoi
mais bon 99 j'étais pas adulte non plus
j'avais 15 ans
[Musique]
mais oui non mais du coup oui je l'ai
pas joué quand il était à son top top
niveau mais pas plus ça s'est pas fait
et puis on joue plus les mêmes tournois
aussi il faut dire tu vois
et sinon sinon j'ai joué je sais pas ça
veut dire quelque chose mais un mec qui
était bon c'était beau Logan
j'ai joué contre une grande dazuniga
gaming Jones Harry Krishna
je sais pas
[Musique]
Ie j'ai joué tous les Français en fait
j'ai pas joué
mais bon de toute façon tout ça c'est
genre ils font pas même temps avec moi
tout cela
bon elles sont beaucoup plus forts
par contre j'aurais pu on a on était
dans les mêmes tournois mais non j'ai
jamais je comprends des lieux
shopping
j'ai joué contre l'autre
je sais pas ce que j'ai déjà fait
longtemps j'ai pas joué j'avais fait nul
en tournant de Blitz récemment mais
forcément je crois que j'ai quasi
toujours perdu en fait
deux fois mais ou trois
[Musique]
la plupart j'ai déjà
fond
présent de la FFE actuelle donc qui est
loin
possible qu'on est fait nul très vite en
Top 16 il y a quelques années
probablement
mais du coup quand je fais des millions
de 10 coups je vais moins m'en souvenir
mais je crois bien
c'est quoi les échecs basques c'est un
beau jeu quoi c'est
[Musique]
si tu joues sur deux échecs en même
temps tu as un blanc et noir
oui je veux qu'on ne peut pas la fin
j'ai mal le temps exactement
[Musique]
j'avais perdu mais c'était une partie
intéressante je veux qu'on charte au
siège-moi le tard enfin je veux quelques
bonjour ici voilà
[Musique]
et toujours en même temps donc tu as
deux pendules et
si tu fais un partout devenu ou bien des
fêtes bah ça fait match nul et du coup
c'est un tournoi
à élimination donc si tu faisais ça tu
refaisais mais en particulier et donc le
concept était très bien c'était sympa
et ils appellent ça chèque basque juste
à Saint-Sébastien au Pays Basque et
franchement c'était cool c'était
vraiment sympa
est-ce que j'aimerais refaire un film
oui et non enfin
pas je pense pas que ça va trop arriver
qu'en fait tu vois on cherche pas à me
poser la question bon ça arrive ça
arrive quoi si je donne un temps
[Musique]
j'ai jamais joué
mais ouais enfin la plupart de ces
joueurs comme ça comme je vous dis on
fait pas vraiment les mêmes tournois
donc
c'est un peu par accident je pourrais
jouer ou après je peux jouer sur
internet peut-être mais bon je parle que
dans les tournois IRL
[Musique]
j'aime pas trop ce que ça devient
peut-être on en a trop bouffé aussi
j'entretiens sur le filon et que la
qualité a baissé mais là j'aime pas trop
parce que
j'aimais bien jusqu'à un Game
voilà les Marvel je trouve sympathique
pas tous égaux mais voilà cool mais là
un peu dur là allez Hoffman est-ce que
non j'ai jamais fait
[Musique]
qui s'est réveillé
ouais donc du coup qui est ici juste
pour parler un petit peu vieille échec
donc il faut bouger le rat et bon perso
j'irai là parce que ça me semble le plus
logique je viens me coller à mon pion je
me mets assez loin pour pas être mis en
échec et voilà il m'en va voir il va
essayer de tout ça un peu le pion h
franchement elle va dur reste partie bon
il a joué bref si je crois si j'ai pas
dit exactement
qui avait eu des quatre donc il se place
là assez logique dans le sens où il veut
te créer un une sorte de zigzang alors
si je recule l'orage par le pion si je
bouge le cavalier je parle pion alors si
je viens là bien sûr je me venge donc
c'est un coup envisageable qui avait
lieu aux quatre mais pas les autres
coups de cavaliers et on va voir
mais j'aime enfin je me répète j'aime
pas comme il a défendu Ding c'est final
ça me plaît pas
ouais moi j'ai 6 c'est peut-être jouable
c'est peut-être jouable
probablement d'ailleurs bon ce que
venait peu enfin premier truc à regarder
après je passais le meilleur mais c'est
de monter par ici mais
c'est que c'est beaucoup de calcul c'est
très tactique tu peux beaucoup moins
maîtriser la situation que dans les
finales de Tours ce que je veux dire par
là c'est que c'était un fou ici bon tu
sais que tu fais ça tu dis bon ben je
défends mon pion il y a pas de problème
je peux pas me faire casser mon setup un
cavalier ça bouge ça te fait des échecs
ça rebondit ça va à droite à gauche
c'est moins stable donc tu peux beaucoup
moins te dire ok j'ai un setup il
bougera jamais une tour tu te dis ok
elle est là elle coupe le roi s'il vient
si je mets je reviens nanana donc donc
voilà enfin le cahier très différente
donc tu peux te tromper beaucoup plus
facilement et tu c'est ça le truc après
Ding qui calcule bien normalement quand
même donc
[Musique]
voilà
donc il attaque le pion donc voilà s'il
est blanc prennent on se venge là-dessus
et on fera un nul très facilement donc
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui doit faire
mais c'est soit F3 soit descendre le roi
bon en descendre le roi ça donne envie
je suis quasi sûr qu'il va faire F3 mais
keV nous dit qu'il y a une finale connue
Gritch shooting que Grisha a gagné et
alors le problème c'est que j'ai pas la
ref donc je connais pas cette finale où
j'ai déjà vu mais je l'ai oublié mais je
peux pas répondre
mais si vous faites la recherche
peut-être vous la trouverez
mais là je donne pas 100% de nul moi
enfin comme je vous dis je
m'inquiète un peu
vite fait mais un peu
ouais échange c'est un standroid
donc ça sera facile là si tu le sacrifie
maintenant dessus bah il te bouffe et
puis il aura de plus en finale mais tu
es encore un pion donc ce pion là
deviendra une future dame et on va
perdre c'est ça les normes
donc il est venu là
bon je m'attends en acheter quatre je
veux dire le pion est vraiment il l'a
fait est-ce que Ding peut perdre autant
écouté tout est toujours possible mais
non je pense pas qu'il va perdre autant
donc tu as eu des trois échecs ok donc
le roi va devoir qui s'appuition active
venir là où là
et on ne coûte 60 donc peut-être qu'il
reprenne encore du temps et il y a les
30 secondes maintenant donc là j'ai
trois jouets et maintenant il faut stand
non mais ça va probablement aller un peu
je veux dire je suis pas plus inquiet
que ça mais
je trouve pas que ce soit la manière
clean de défendre la finale voilà
je pense qu'il y a 60 coups sur les
feuilles et donc là ils sont au bout
c'est la partie la plus longue du match
pour l'instant je sais pas s'il y a déjà
eu 60 couches je crois pas et du coup
bah voilà
une deuxième feuille
ici oui
tu fais ce que tu veux que je le cavale
tu fais ranger 6 l'un ou l'autre vont
bien mais voilà j'ai 6 bon c'est le coup
le plus logique parce que ben on empêche
5 on reste au contact du pion et puis on
regarde le cavalier ici qui fait un bon
job parce que il prend la Casa donc le
roi ne monte pas elle peut en F5 qui
prend ces deux cases là donc on a mis
une petite muraille en place et donc
tant que le roi vient pas nous embêter à
faire le loup dans la bergerie bah ça va
donc roi ici je pense que c'est logique
partiellement c'est à quelle heure elle
a commencé à 11h comme tous les jours
donc
[Musique]
c'est une finale rentre dans les tables
de finale il faut qu'il y a moins de 7
pièces
et on a 7 oui tu dois pouvoir tu dois
pouvoir la rentrer bon il va devenir nul
enfin je pense je serais pas il va pas
nous révolutionner l'évaluation mais
après ce qui ce qu'il faut c'est juste
annuler en pratique un truc nul et avec
la tension et la fatigue accumulée
machin c'est plus ça les problèmes tu
vois ça fait déjà quoi 5h30
[Musique]
donc tu as une petite fatigue tu as la
fatigue du match ça fait déjà deux
semaines qui sont là machin un moment
coup de mou tu déconnes tu as perdu
c'est ça aussi qui
donc il y avait lui aussi bon on n'est
pas en tout cas si une occasion de il va
la saisir donc bon voilà bouge rebouche
de cavalier bon de toute façon on
pouvait pas ne pas jouer mais là le
piège c'était sister blanc ça aurait été
de faire caler F4 parce que ça force
l'échange
donc ok kfk bon alors là sur ton échange
pas on part alors où est-ce qu'on part
sur ça là là bon je dirais plutôt
mais avec la main sans calculer parce
que je trouve qu'en B4 on va loin mais
bon après peut-être pas très grave
oui normalement enfin c'est censé être
nul
mais
parce qu'il y a plus beaucoup de pions
et puis aussi ils sont tous la même tu
vois le pion serait là-bas beaucoup plus
difficile à défendre parce que le pion
avant si t'immobilise soit tu cours avec
ton roi le chercher mais du coup tu
auras du mal à la défendu parce que je
viendrai là ou tel cavalier qui va
défendre là-bas ouais mais à ce
moment-là peut-être que j'amène mon
rapport de chasser et puis j'ai mon pion
donc c'est beaucoup plus dur là comme on
est tous dans la même zone c'est plus
simple de défendre
pure H qui avait écran 3 c'est nul ah
non ça ça gagne en fait le pion h bon
c'est le pire pion dans les finales
hachoir
et donc des fois il y a des nuls quand
il y a pion et fou parce que
tu serais sur la mauvaise couleur alors
tu as une chance sur deux c'était un fou
de casse noir Jean-Louis et ce pion tu
gagneras si tu as si tu as l'autre fou
tu fais nul
donc ça je sais pas si vous savez tous
mais
j'aurais du mal illustrer je peux pas
ramener de pièces comme ça mais en fait
la raison est simple imaginez un
échiquier vide où il a un droit là les
blancs il sera qu'un pion et un roi là
tout là ça n'existe pas si j'ai un fout
de case noir je te mets en échec
je dessine pour vous visualisez bien je
demandais en échec ton roi il doit s'en
aller il serait là mon pion qui est ici
vous vous souvenez je fais échec j'ai
manqué le défend vous dégagez j'ai une
dame facile j'ai un foot qui est blanche
dans le même cas de figure roi pion roi
je vais faire le foot de case blanche en
bleu
roi pion bleu et le Renoir en rouge
bah le renard il fait ça toute sa vie en
fait si je le mets en échec quand il est
là il retourne au coin et là je peux
rien faire de spécial déjà il est
quasiment pas ok il revient et je fais
quoi je pose échecs dans le coin il me
bloque et c'est ça le problème avec les
fous c'est pour ça que ça peut être nul
mais un cavalier tu as pas ce problème
vu que vu qu'il peut aller là de déloger
ton roi et puis il y a des le truc à
pousser
donc donc voilà
bref ça c'était pour le
bon j'imagine beaucoup de gens étaient
au courant mais pour ceux qui savaient
pas ça et lucide un petit mystère
et donc la réciproque est vrai c'est un
pion a ou des unions
le foot de case blanche gagne pas le
footclaz
OK
il défend
bon je m'attends ici deux
sur quoi va venir là où là pour coller
exactement ça a été joué vite
et
peut-être qu'il y avait là
du coup on attaque ici et ça alors on me
dit qu'il aurait pu prendre un filtre
alors j'ai même pas considéré mais
peut-être parce que je me dis ouais mais
lui je l'envoie pas
ok mais là bon faut vraiment se casser
la tête là pour faire nul les gars
je veux dire faut faire ça
alors on sait que ça peut enfin il se
trouve c'est nul avec un pion fou contre
une dame mais quand le roi est dans les
parages ça peut vite dégénérer alors là
pareil qu'est-ce qui pourquoi ça fait
nul en fait ça par rapport aux autres
normalement la méthode pour gagner ce
genre de position c'est de mettre des
échelles avec la dame bon vous êtes où
dans la chaîne facile de guerre mais bon
je redis je suis sympa vous mettez des
échecs vous rapprochez donc là bon ok on
fait des échecs qui se passe rien vous
attaquez les pions vous empêcher qu'il
fasse d'âme s'il fait dames il vient là
dans le monde échec et donc en champion
BD où j'ai donc voilà cela en fait
seulement ne pas perdre l'option c'est
de venir là dire bah je le défends et
puis et puis voilà sauf que le jour il
est là les normes n'as plus de pousser
qu'on n'est plus obligé de faire échec
on dit ah bah tiens je vais en profiter
pour ramener mon roi je me rapproche et
en réitère la même manœuvre et puis on
sera là dans je pars quelques cours et
puis m'en prendra plusieurs à mettre bon
là ce qui fait que c'est nul c'est qu'en
fait on n'est pas obligé de passer
devant le pion et de se bloquer on va
dans le coin et c'est un autre pion ben
on aurait pu le bouffer là c'est pas
qu'on peut pas mais il y a pas donc
c'est pour ça voilà donc ça c'est la
raison
donc oui mais c'est ce que c'est la tête
pour pas grand chose qui ait des quatre
c'était logique mais bon c'est vrai que
il aurait pu calculer Ding c'était pas
invisible mais mais bon moi j'arrête pas
regarder en fait là je peux comprendre
qu'il est pas regardé échec roi bouge et
voilà donc bon on est toujours dans le
statu quo de de ce genre de position
bon en fait
je bouge pas je te mets des échecs dès
que tu as dans le coin et puis voilà
ça se passe que ça tend vers la nul mais
bon on sait jamais
ouais on va voir enfin oui
[Musique]
si jamais je crois qu'il y avait perdu
une finale Ding dans le match qu'en gris
tchou qui était allé en Chine ah ok je
vais contre lui il a joué une super
longue finale de cavalier je pense aller
ça dure 70 coups mais grisou qu'il avait
finir pas il avait fini par gagner bah
la différence elle partait gagnante mais
elle était hyper dure tout trouvé
mais là ça doit être nul ce truc là
mais bon
c'est sûr que comme je te dis je suis
pas trop content de ce qu'il a fait quoi
en fait mais bon
avec les cavaliers ouais parce que tu
peux pas triangulaire
si tu es dans le bon tempo tu es dans le
bon tempo quoi et puis c'est terminé
et l'autre truc bizarre c'est que enfin
les seuls coups c'est un peu dans les
finales comme roi tour qu'on croit
cavaliers
tu as une séquence qui paraît hyper
difficile à trouver en fait c'est
vraiment à chaque fois pour faire nul
mais le truc c'est que c'est tout le
temps le seul coup
est-ce que digne des opportunités
correcte dans l'ensemble
je crois que tous les coups ça fait
le 2 roi F2 qui est des quatre trois qui
est deux
qui est des quatre
je pense ici
H5 H6
peut-être ça passe pas
[Musique]
je crois pas je vois pas de trajet mais
est-ce que tu es content
non bah si les blancs
[Musique]
donc surtout pas échanger les cavaliers
tu sais pas à quel point il a du bol
Ding à quel point il savait
parce que ça a pas l'air trop dur à
défendre non mais ils savent mais
en fait j'ai l'impression que tu peux
mal tomber
en fait j'ai détesté
c'est quoi
rien mais du coup il est rentré en force
là dedans donc je pense qu'il sait mais
[__] ici est-ce que tu as tout
calculer que H4 G4 machin qui est jamais
rien sur rien je sais pas tu peux avoir
des mauvais cas de figure quand même tu
es obligé de faire H3 ou quoi enfin
j'ai pas du tout aimé quoi
non mais c'est sûr que j'aurais pas du
tout fait ça non plus
[Musique]
j'ai quand même fini par faire mais
j'avais pas montré une bonne technique
quoi
mais tu avais fait nul
là mais
quand même
H5 énorme chance de
donc là il va faire 3 et moi je me pose
la question en plus la ligne d'ordi
pas quoi
c'est très bien enfin c'est très bien
bah ça va aller
là je crois qu'il a il a passé le plus
dur
non mais après c'est possible aussi
qu'il savait tout qui a tout bien
calculé avant de faire son F5 et voilà
c'est pas impossible mais
de ma chaise ça me laissait pas une
belle impression
ouais
ition bah ils ont en tête les couilles
de toute façon et puis tu as ta feuille
de partir ça sert aussi à quoi
est-ce que les Blancs faut pas jouer F4
pour passer le roi par la gauche alors
tu aimerais bien en fait avoir oui si tu
peux faire ça bon maintenant je fais mal
jouer mais que lui il passe
et que tu arrives à un moment
[Musique]
par ici et que bon la forêt de passer
ton tour et qui te laisse ça bon là
c'est heureux mais en fait tu as vu j'ai
quand même dû faire très n'importe quoi
avec les normes ne jamais réagir et le
laisser là mais en fait si je te laisse
pas là en fait je te dis oui non en fait
je bouge plus roi je bouge le cabane
il se passe quoi
donc bon tu peux le tenter mais ça va
pas amener bien loin sachant qu'en plus
peut-être pendant que tu pars là-bas
j'ai le temps d'aller tenter un contre
jeu là ou que lui je l'amène là
j'attaque le pion je peux aussi faire
des choses donc ça suffit pas
parce que c'est nul c'est le cheval
[Musique]
normalement non
F5 ce sera mieux
pas de tribulations avec les cavaliers
et en plus dans l'exemple qu'on est tout
à l'heure lui il pouvait bouger de
mettre des échecs
on avait un roi ici un pion là
et on disait qu'il y a ce coup d'attente
mais si on veut faire à chaque revenir
quadrulation en fait
je sais pas trop comment dire mais
donc solution
j'ai même l'impression qu'il y a pas
trop de
[Musique]
en fait
vu qu'on n'est pas un coup de perdre
donc une ligne
tout
semblable mais ça peut durer ouais bah
c'était 60e déjà jusqu'au 110e ça peut
durer sans qu'il touche à rien et puis
il y a moins il peut faire H5
en tout cas sa chemise est bien repassée
alors nous on a vu des chemises qui se
froissent pas partant t'as pas besoin de
les repasser tu la passes à la machine
400 tours minute pas plus sinon tu perds
la forme et après hop tu la poses sur un
cintre et voilà donc pratique pour les
gens qui voyagent ou qui n'aiment pas
repasser
important
mais là il reste plus que 23 minutes
avec le rajout oui ils ont ils ont
rajouté là les je pense
qu'on arrive à 6 heures de jeu
on a une partie longue dans le match et
tout de suite c'est chiant enfin nous du
coup on a pu papoter avec le chat mais
en fait en soi là
la position en elle-même
les plus grand chose
qui doit pas être bien pourquoi
[Musique]
je suis en train de payer pour ça et
d'ailleurs je me demandais est-ce que il
a la certif sur Twitter en orange est-ce
qu'il a payé
je suis très étonné de chaque décision
de dingue en fait
m'étonne pas trop pour le coup non mais
non il a pas la certitude
comme ils ont une certitude d'oreille
ils vont lui donner du peu
mais donc du coup il va pas payer si tu
veux ta réponse
il fait jamais de rester en place la
position quoi même ça moi j'aurais fait
aussi non mais si ça fait l'autre tu
sais que tu es nul
tu prends le risque de te tromper quoi à
chaque fois en fait
tu prends le risque évidemment
rien
bon basiquement il a mis le pion là
c'est pour ramener le roi ici
et attendre tranquillement comme ça
bloque tout comme ça si lui il pousse un
moment on ira le chercher
je crois j'ai un
du coup je m'attends à ça
ouais en fait le truc qu'on veut pas
faire c'est ça
parce que là en fait merde si on
bougeait
donc on va bouger le roi peu importe lui
il vient là et on perd le pion donc ça
on veut pas voir
donc ici par H5 alors peut-être qu'un
coup d'attentative
et on revient
donc ça c'est ce qu'on va a priori voir
c'est pas si simple
non mais je peux te tromper
individuellement tous les coups sont
faciles mais il y en a beaucoup quoi
le pire c'est que ça part d'un truc où
il a pas de bolding ah oui le 3 à 4
[Musique]
jouets
il y a pas de
bon là je crois que ça a pu durer trop
très longtemps
si ça joue mais il est pas revenu là du
coup
[Musique]
moi j'étais encore dans le délire de pas
je voulais commencer par qui a été 4
pour être bien sûr
mais c'est une partie pas mal pour dépôt
dans le sens où donc il a jamais été en
danger de perdre il a mis un peu la
pression gentiment à la fin et voilà
donc statu quo dans le match
ouais après après il reste
à portée de fusil de Ding et du coup il
peut pas se détendre dans un bon ça y
est de points d'écart j'ai fait le break
il a la tête sous l'eau non non pas du
tout le match n'est pas n'est pas
terminé il y a qu'un point on a vu hier
que est complètement en état de pouvoir
gagner faudra conclure s'il a une belle
position encore une fois pareil donc le
mano Amano continue on se retrouve donc
pas demain c'est l'un de repos mais
dimanche matin on vous donne rendez-vous
à 11h comme toujours pour pour de
nouvelles aventures merci d'avoir suivi
et on vous dit à dimanche matin ciao
tout le monde